uh party's locked
really of course
oh my mom's is not calling right now i'm
not answering that
[Laughter]
[Music]
i see you yeah great
you won't leave that voice message
though and i'm gonna get back
you're gonna leave that voice puncher
not at the right all this time is she
gonna coordinate
you don't know my mom's she's gonna talk
the air off
[Music]
listen
it's the rain
and let listen she know me if it was a
bird you should be sitting by my car
going away
you don't call me mama cargo on the
radar
[Music]
mm-hmm
he said that's foul
listen you know damn it's rain we waited
all year for this
i was not dims down right now
oh man the laughs the last
it already begins
oh just fly to the tower oh you goes
okay
i didn't know i was hooked
wilhelm
it's not working
i'm over here like why we haven't
started
unbeating yourself well
y'all hear well
for every super chat addict's gonna
accidentally die
[Laughter]
are you ridiculous you're gonna die so
much
gonna put the podcast out of business
trying to kill us what's going on
this guy here is good
brick
[Music]
no
more all right
so we need to make sure our screams
communications right before we start
right
i have not heard him
all right teammates
let's get it frost
welcome to the day one situation
thank you thank you
look at my look at my eyes when i shake
your hand
i mean she looked deep in my eyes
does does party chat automatically come
through your stream or do you have to
forget that you have to set it up
to do that you have nothing
that's what we have
calm check home screen
told you about being quiet
[Laughter]
it's like trials call outs call outs
call
goblin on the left
[Laughter]
here we go
let's get it
i'm
done
all right let's see all right
do we get a little cinnamon actually
what we get
yes
that's hive in the swamp though
it's loose and high though yeah could be
losing hobbies
let's get it boys
yeah
oh man i love it
all right i'm scared i'm turning around
and
no orders running a warning the pyramid
ahead is not like those you've
previously encountered this one was not
left for you to find you were not guided
to it not beckoned
this domain belongs to a dark entity
unknown in power
it seeks domination of the throne world
your presence within how
welcome
children of light
more hulk
uh she's weakened i believe
you've got no more yeah
she's
weak knights on the left or right yeah
things hurt
oh man she just one shot man
good stuff she didn't look at me once
but that butterfly did
yeah
i actually got the music on for this for
the first time wow
[Music]
i've been muted this whole time
all right how does the chat sound how
does the audio sound compared
disciples
i'm kidding
you find one though you do just that
there's got to be a way this guy's going
to be
all right
lucky
oh we got surprises
oh down in the deep
there's a way all right what about now
scoring
yeah oh there's a ship y'all is that a
ship that we get on like the uh
i'm hitting him with the weakening
yeah i'm getting it back
it's not moving
okay he's dead i think we have to kill
these knowledge barriers first
[Music]
i'm going blind
oh yes
oh he threw me against the wall
circle on this yeah
i think we have to get arrived from the
beach i'm grabbing all around
yeah there's relics on the ground
yeah i'm getting one
yeah
do you have to take them back
maybe yeah
yeah okay yeah bring them back
bring them back
again nice yeah this is like a public
event started in a way yeah we ride this
low
[Music]
snipers
cyphers
to the pyramid we go
all right i turned it down again guys
i died
let's go come back and get you
oh wait you're all the way back there
man oh man don't worry about it i'm on
the ship pick me up
uh what's going on get off that it's i
don't know what it's doing
here going up front with a bubble
of course muscle
oh i'm going blind
i'm going blind i can't see
you gotta go next to the ship next to
the ship to take the blindness off to
take the blindness off
yeah takes it off
i think we're good i'm about to come get
you
oh no you're gonna figure it's all right
let's go get these go get these giants i
see one
there's a couple up top yeah i think
you're gonna need two
height knowledge there's one up here
there's another one
it only carries four
four maximum all right cool
i like that it's called height knowledge
uh there's still an artifact all the way
in the back
i see this one over here about to get
ooh i racked up
anymore missing
um
i don't see it oh it's moving
it's moving let's get on the train i'm
getting on don't leave
got a me dollar super trap from lord
sovereign day one raid our uh
uh they won't raise our iop gold ready
to watch the massacre by the way i don't
give a rat's ass about no destiny
yo stop
just so you know i text you bro
i'm sorry
it turns it turned sideways this time oh
yeah
put it down
there
go freezing boys
[Music]
nice nice
yeah you like that see stasis
oh damn those things are strong
okay here's two i'm getting two
i like that we ride this little train
thing funny yeah
stand clear of the closing doors
oh it's going back
sniper sniper
oh i got sniped oh they're coming by the
sniper behind us
behind us okay
press
big boy big boy big boy yeah i see him i
see him
tethered tethered
let him have it
left that
i switched to the threaded needle
yes
i might have to go rock it as well
because
they're not respecting that machine
they disrespect me with it
like if you don't stop tickling me with
this
that's it
watch the closing doors please
oh my god
this is a southbound
train wall street
what's this pervading darkness
oh because i'm too far from the thing
you can get a sparrow
yeah i thank you i did not know
the number is not always now it's going
down okay
bubble in the middle
putting some turrets and spaces outside
crowd control crowd control got one
i got four ones up there
land damn it
snipers on the right got snipers to the
right yeah
all right get in the well
yeah it's leaving us
i don't know i only put it up to get the
overshield
right
we are at
hey
that one didn't go that far
a children of the darkness
i wield that
kind of go get those uh things for today
let's go
all right i got some over here
bubble going in the middle
i'll get the river
oh there's still one up here
yeah
oh it's all the way up there
i like wells on my train
awesome oh
look at this design dude yeah it's crazy
oh that's crazy
earth scorches
suns fade
look
beyond
or what's his name
[Laughter]
i think it was someone leveling up oh
somebody leveled up oh oh yeah
i heard something
ready like oh no i think we might die
what's that right there what's what that
little circle did
what the hell we fall down here yeah
let's fall down you know go into the
darkness into the deep it's a hit it's a
drop
don't break your legs don't break your
legs two pathways
i actually stopped trying to stop but it
didn't stop
okay so we can go behind us or we can go
before actually
right too finding spawn location oh yeah
the door closed but i got close
oh remember things aren't as they seem
see
look look look oh you shoot that little
thing
nice
please don't crush me
okay
okay right here
triangle triangle
okay so maybe we have to go the
there's a lot of stuff over to the left
and right of the room too i don't know
if there's openings but
there's these little things on the wall
here too
like blood splatter on the wall
that door doesn't open
these look like portals
yeah they do
all right so it has to be this way
lovely egyptian y'all know we actually
further did redeem right now i can't
believe it let's go
look at this sliced up world's first
world's first huh
yo it feel like we're in an egyptian
museum let's just fire
oh what the hell
what
if i've never seen hive there's going to
be hive in this right here we go here we
go
here we go okay where's the triangle
square
oh we need to know the triangle activate
activate
oh
did it look like this did it look like
this one right here yes it is yes yes
yes yes that's the one
something changed
something changed
the activated button
um hold on hold on hold on
there it is there's more here
hold on
something's up in this room
okay i'm coming
board
ato ten dollar super chat watching king
attic for take a few weeks so maybe you
really want to put it together
with a triangle downwards
great game horrible like this is in a
series secret time level is addictive
this is
it's right here it's right here by me
just to make sure send come to me let's
verify this one yeah that's it that's it
yeah that's it that's it perfect all
right we gotta find one more most likely
one more secret room
so there was a door back here do you
think it might have opened let's split
up let's split up
all of us don't need to go in the same
direction let's split up
there's a door right here
did they shut the
sorry about that watching king addington
forte a few weeks ago made me really
want to put effort in destiny
great game horrible life decisions a
serious time sinking and leveling up is
addictive i appreciate it i just wanted
to make sure that i read that i
apologize for that man come over here
come here
right here
all right i'm coming i'm coming i'm
coming
so this is where you can reach that
there's no there's no uh
gate here right here right here oh
[ __ ]
yeah this is like the gate
someone stay here
maybe that changes when we do stuff
yeah all right i'll stay and watch
i'm gonna go remember the rules see if
we missed one body triangle circle god
bless you
maybe that's the sequence maybe that's
the sequence maybe that's what we got to
do but okay
but then there's a symbol above that
what's this this one above this screen
right yeah right it looks like a brain
right there yeah the brain
i like that these have faith for like a
bird
cherokee
um behind you guys too there's two
circles kind of little bend on the left
and
right just noticed that frost looked
just like me
yeah yeah or maybe you look just like me
okay i like that i like that
spicy i like that
look look at every look in the wall and
stuff there might be secret
holes in the wall
how did you get up there dude
i i started climbing because i'm looking
for one of those things
i don't see the symbol we just set on
this uh on here
i don't know if that necessarily
corresponds to um the thing we just did
yeah yeah it has to be a door because
they they wouldn't show these symbols
nothing
there has to be a door somewhere
[Applause]
another thing let's go back towards the
beginning
forte come with me back towards the
beginning of the race
okay i'm coming back i'm coming back i'm
looking to
yeah i'm kind of looking
in this big room with is there anything
behind this door here
this
no no no no
also keep an eye out for just maybe it
might just be the plaque on the wall and
maybe we don't have to go inside the
door maybe it's just
sitting there in in you know
should we get ready to sit on it once
and see what happens no no no okay
is this just a worm cut in half
yeah like cut into little sections yes
like they don't feel like a study museum
where like they've taken all the races
and like it feels like they're
collecting the races or something
yeah i think it's going to be the veil
kind of taken yeah
it's kind of shadowy instead of just you
know
because if you look in the room that i
meant they have things trapped inside of
these
kind of like stasis crystals
and i gotta die i hear something over
here
yeah and the room that i was just in
there was really obvious music playing
but we've already been in that room so
i don't know
i hear something
listen
okay
maybe is where the worm is
yeah we oh that worms pretty far away
though
yeah but the first um identifier was
pretty
was the furthest further the norm
right
okay
i don't know i don't feel like they put
it all we got to do is find a panel or
is there anything down here
he's wearing so far i ain't seen nothing
there's nothing down here okay
i mean
we could just do the first two and then
every other one
just click reset let's see what happens
click reset
i'll hit reset now
all right i hit reset let me know if
anything will are you over there with
the triangle did it change yeah nothing
changed on the triangle no nothing
changed
what if what if the spot where i'm at is
kind of the sequence
that's what i feel like it is yeah like
what if anything change
no we i think we have to put it in the
order that he's looking at if they want
yeah like they may want the order where
i'm at
so come come back to me for a second so
y'all can see all right so you see i'll
be like god bodied and it did
what if it's the one not here
you think so you think they play
opposites okay so there's a triangle
with a light
a bean with a goat of it a square
a mountain side and a triangle sticking
through a
circle if you notice these four here at
the top are the same and then there's
just one that's the same as the top i
bet you we have to get the missing
sequence that's on these two and they're
using this as an indication that it's
missing how about this
how about this is just like the campaign
where they had the symbols and stuff
yeah yeah
one of these are not the same as the
answers
everything is not as it seems
what if it's the switch queen symbol
i bet you it's this witch queen symbol
right here yeah
at the end probably man all right this
is what we're gonna do this is what
we're gonna do everyone
okay call go to the middle we're gonna
click every one of them and then we're
gonna reset let's see if we could
we can finesse this
every time we reset
all right
reset it now
all right
it reset all right activate
now reset again let me see if it
disappears
all right just reset it again okay that
is how it resets how you do it here
all right so
does this wall have a reset on it too
forte come here
this one over here where are you at no
it doesn't i don't see anything all
right all right all right all right this
is what we're gonna do tell me the first
symbol what does it look like
what's up
who me yeah the first symbol
um upper left is that god what the one
that i'm calling god body the man with
the hands the thing over his head
okay is it blue
yeah it's blue he got a little ghost
mini thing over his head he got his arm
you call that guy body look at the look
at uh bring up whoa what happened
oh right here
right here
i'm coming i'm coming give me a second i
gotta get over there it was the mentor
too so that's cool so wait wait so i
know the sequence i was just sitting
here
was right he was picking random good job
at it
total [ __ ]
free of chains
do me a favor go back in that room and
take a picture of that
oh now you go all right yeah take a
picture of that raw
because i don't know because i see the
same symbols down here
yeah raid banner symbols
hey let's look around let's look around
that's an awesome car bone man
yeah they're collecting races
we have to like complete that entire
season before the raid is actually
completed like every single symbol opens
up another encounter
that'd be like what nine encounters
i bet you were gonna fight everything in
this raid i'm taking a picture part of
me feels like we're gonna fight
everything in this raid
if they're collecting i think that it's
gonna be just one or two races it's
gonna be every single raid because they
had
yeah i don't know man
he's the uh
where you want me to send a picture just
just hold on to uh send it to uh
just send it to everyone
yeah send it to me forte and will on
xbox i mean on uh twitter
just in case if we have to like look at
it
or you could just make a group chat and
put it in there um
oh that's how you start it never mind
i'm just saying i'm sending the other
xbox
oh that's fine that's fine
um
[Music]
so we see that here
i hope i don't start it but i want to
look around
yeah i'm looking around there's a thing
in the middle if if we start it we just
white it's fine uh there's symbols on
the ground to the left here actually i
don't know if they're
they symbolize anything but there is a
floor right here it looks like there's
doors like on every corner
i think i don't know sin right here
there might be a door that opens up
right there
to go down
oh that's a
really big bone there
i think the i think what's gonna happen
is something's gonna glow and we have to
go in a specific door
frost how do you spell yeah
um
oh there it is f4rrs7
yeah
just the regular frosty was taken so
you could put a seven there instead and
then why two seven okay all right
there you go
so i wonder if once we started these
symbols will pop up on a circle i think
though i think they'll glow
yeah that's what i'm thinking i think
what happens is they glow on this door
and then we have to go into the
corresponding
door because they're for everyone
there's a door i don't know we'll find
out we'll start it just to see what
happens when call gets back
best way to learn is to do it but yeah
just so y'all know one door and uh forte
saw it it's a dark star the first symbol
all right i said you had a guy body
manual
yeah just in case if we need that
did y'all hear right here well i hear
you the first door has a dark star with
like white it looks like a white with
the star would be sprayed let me bring
it up on
on my computer so i can see it like
clearly we might have to study
go ahead and start it well let's put a
right boundary don't start
let's put a ray banner down first
alright cool
look for triangle look for the triangle
this takes damage
this middle thing takes damage i don't
know why
i might actually is there any more of
those immune though
over here
okay so there
whoa oh god
it's like a rainbow kind of star
okay across from the star there's a
rainbow star let me see
look for the rainbow star that's
probably rainbow star
i'm looking i'm looking i'm looking wait
wait
the enemies just shot the bell
really really an opposite the first
populace went up
yeah
it gave an indicator
yeah it gave an indicator obvious
sustained damage sustained damage
yeah
i found an enemy that says disciples
compass over here is he hard can you
kill him by yourself or do oh
activated so the glyphs
are probably in the room that we went
into sinister with the two
um
two symbols in the back do you think
all right look
all right so look
the first one i saw was on the left so
let's start there open that one and head
to the other one so hold on before you
start like this thing right here
in the middle this thing
yeah i shot that and i did something it
started the encounter
yeah
damn it i got to stop starting without
getting that again we're just testing
don't worry i don't know what that does
though what does that do
that
activated the encounter
oh it does that activates it
yeah i'm saying you just grabbed
something from up here
i opened it again oh there's taken in
here and obelisk was under attack
there's taken in here
there's taken in here
look there's a guy over there i'm gonna
throw an oval bomb [ __ ]
where do we head okay we can't let it
get to the top
look look look for
uh frost look these things are uh
they're starting to show up
look at it
once triangle
okay
[Music]
go to triangle find triangle right here
triangle i don't know where it's at at
the math though
yeah i'm just going to stay here and
protect this i don't know
i don't know what happens if they
just destroy it
it's a fail
all right all right all right all right
i think
let's look around for those pillars find
out how many of those pillars are i
think there's three so so we need two on
each two on each yeah
okay
let's just defend them and see if
anything happens
can i touch the raid banners yeah
uh maybe
okay let's try one on each
and have the other three look around
because i think if we're only defending
they clearly want us to do something
else besides just defend
what were the symbols popping up on the
totems from is that from us defending or
from them getting in
i think it was us defending i think it's
time related
i don't know but the the triangle did
pop up
yeah i think it's time related
they stayed depending on how much time's
uh been gone by let's let's let's
continue are you did you get it called i
know there's one in the back left
yeah i got it all right i'm starting it
now
okay hold up um i'm just going to this
one let's do two let's do two at a time
and let's defend them and see what
happens
we'll go with forte
i'll go with sinister you're defending
this villain
is there more than two three
no no there's one right there all right
and there's one down there i'll i'll go
with will i'm starting it now
okay got the little pyramid in it yeah
yeah yeah okay
all right well we gotta we gotta protect
this man
they come before oh
there might be one where do you want me
to go at it
come to me
i'll go to the center i'll go to center
street you stay with forte you stay with
forte i'll go with sinister it's gonna
be really difficult
all right i got you i'll put spaces down
baby look look look it's lighting up the
longer the time goes by the little
things
filling it up
okay okay
exhibit
that's right
we're going to have a champion or
something you can't take no more damage
what did they shoot how where are they
shooting it from are they hitting it are
they hitting it they're hitting yeah
they're shooting but they're shooting
the little bell that we were trying to
shoot in the middle when we started yeah
it was taking damage that's what they
shoot so you can't let them get close
enough to shoot it
let me switch to a sword
i'm telling y'all big stasis i'm telling
you i i have a whole void builder i
would control the whole rule bro
switch or suppressing them so they can't
listen to cats
i'm a big stage i think i might do some
discipline so that i can throw more
grenades
i'll put up the ray banner
ambix i'm carrying a squad i'm big
stasis
in the chat there's a bell
i feel like there's a mechanic we're
missing that we were shooting that you
said was immune so it's basically they
come out
yeah they come out in different areas
and they shoot it and then
yeah
i think you know okay
so what if you put your bubble up here
and just protect it with your butt
oh i was gonna i was good that would be
i think all the spawn rotations are
exactly are the same for every wave
so
um just keep it in between for over here
like there's a group that spawns here
and there's a group that spawns like
opposite this
so if you just like stay in the spawn
and just like nuke them on the spawn
that's probably going to be okay
okay i got it right i got an idea
i think they want us to break up and
i think a big frost got it i think they
big spaces i think they want us to break
it up into teams of two
and how it goes is one person defends
and the other person gets these symbols
that's on here because if you notice one
of these symbols is lit up beside it
one of these things here let's start it
go to your theme
yeah go right there forte you see that
thing there
yeah
yeah look at that i think one of you
have to do something with that symbol
and the other person has to protect the
bell
yours is
yours is right here
yeah yeah yeah all right now look at
that look at that defend it and look at
that okay okay
all right i'm starting circle so maybe i
was supposed to go right in here okay
don't worry about the door
no
no shooting him
the bubble
[Laughter]
i love the bubble all right man i see
your trigger is actually coming
all the way
no that seems to be filling up no matter
how many yeah yeah it it's it goes by um
okay triangles up top for us
all right now look for triangle look for
triangle like on the doors it's right
behind us yeah triangle is right behind
us go in there see if there's anything
to pick up or
um there's nothing it's there's not an
opening there's nothing hold on let me
go down below maybe you have to kill the
taken to unlock it
maybe i don't know
but there's yeah it's just triangle up
top is a triangle for you guys too on
your uh your total or no our totem
hasn't gone up yet
oh okay
all right you gotta come back and find
the game ago
i'm yeah
is under attack are you able to revive
me
all right clearly all right
i i think what's going on here
is we there's something with that taking
because there's one taken and then
that gate that glyph there's a taking
for some reason like there's got to be
something related to that taking because
he's a yellow bar too
um yeah
that's trying to be happy
i'm still okay so glyph keeper defeats
is probably the taken but where are the
glyphs
that's where i'm confused what are the
what about on the back walls here these
two boxes you see those boom and boom
well hold up let what we need to do is
let's
let's start it let's find that taken
thing and because sin you said something
like compass or something didn't you
yeah it said disciples compass disciples
compass maybe you go back and put it in
the uh yeah everyone there's these
things in the back here too there's
glyphs
there's glyphs over
yeah we noticed that we got to find what
to do with that compass maybe you like
dunk it like right here
do you see this let me see
don't start it yet obviously what you're
looking at
this thing right here
maybe you bring that compass thing here
because it's like this looks like it was
designed for a reason this thing right
here
maybe when you have it it'll let you
dunk it there
okay
so i just have to keep a lookout for the
taken
killed the tag yeah yeah there's
something here too oh no yeah sorry
that's just that's just [ __ ] water
guys i'm sorry you're good you're good
but there's another room
there is another room
there's another room
yeah we opened up top left yeah and
there's the room see if there's one
see if there's a room on every side
that might be some secret chest [ __ ]
though it looks exactly like the
triangle room
there's these four doors here
or three
i don't know if that's that worm in the
back would say look crazy
you know what bro
can you hold that by yourself and then i
look at everybody yeah yeah yeah i'll
hold it by myself i'll go towards
i'll go towards whatever um symbol shows
i'll go
in that room all right let's go ahead
and start it and let's just look around
get back to my position okay tell me
when you're ready
i'm on my way
on my way
all right cognito always deal with the
guys on the left here yeah okay and i'll
deal with the middle one over here in
the back
yeah
just follow yep i'll get out
they aren't spotting up here so i'll
just come home
oh i burnt down [ __ ]
you're good
they hit hard
oh yeah i see the taking he's at the end
he's at the back coming coming coming
yeah he killed me
okay
so that taken the significant i don't
know it's significant yeah i agree gotta
have some significance
to the right to the right here's uh
something
i don't know what things are filling up
i think the yellow bars what's the
symbol anybody get a symbol yet
no we have circle and then brain it
looks like circle brain circle brain
look at it
yeah come take a look at ours man
i'm gonna die
we
there's nothing in here
i'm going to circle now
okay we have compass
rainbow compass
ours filled up no matter who hit it
we have triangle
[Music]
oh
it's time
i
hold up if you notice yeah that's why i
said one person properly the other one
does if you notice there's three
sections of that i feel like there's
going to be three to four rounds and
every time you do a successful
completion it's going to take it down by
one
all right cognito do you want this order
switch to swords switch to swords swords
easily does it
you run around
okay
let me switch to you let me switch to a
sword
so
whatever pillar you're you're designated
to right now that's the pillars you can
do
and sit and run
everyone stays together and so the
moment you kill you're taken i think
that's when it opens that's when you go
find that so stick together until that
taken's killed and then whoever's
supposed to run around that's when you
run around
okay so just for the people running i'm
running citizens running who's running
from middle sinister's running for me
yeah
okay okay okay
so just for people
who are running just in case brains back
yeah i got you middle and then it's um
i don't even know what to call this
the witness
with a
triangle in his left hand
so for this one where does it open at
for the circle
what
what
there's these little symbols around the
arena
i saw this circle one right
right where do you go in for it i think
the biggest thing we we gotta look into
right now room to the left
like up top where you guys were i don't
know but question was any of those rooms
ever open
yes they opened when you called out the
symbol some of them opened okay so you
probably have to do it in a
i i don't know let's let's just start it
and let's see what happens hold on hold
on okay i gotta switch up my light up
i'll check what's under here okay
there's a person with a hole in this
chest bottom
yes this is the right okay so there is
stuff on the bottom
oh man i'm just trying to
yeah i'm trying to just familiarize
myself with each area yeah i'm gonna run
around too yeah
what is this one
there's another one here to the left it
looks like a cathedral
um
we've got
um steak through heart i guess we can
call it i don't know um
i don't know man
there's stuff everywhere
yeah
there's nothing over there
it's praising witness over there
i mean there's a lot of symbols around
the arena but there's not that much
the two groups should stick together
until that taken's killed then you go
back to your thing you see what simple
it is and then he the other person runs
to that symbol
where does the taking come from
uh
outer edges of the map
yeah over by your friends
right behind where they're
spawning okay he spawns over here
i don't know if there's more spawn so we
haven't gotten that far there's also
is there another one there like i don't
know
i don't know if that's gonna open up to
the right there
almost done boys almost done
you're good
i'm trying to memorize not working
but i think that's the i think
it's been really cool so far though i
think that's that's the way we come back
uh
all right are everyone good
yeah some somebody said hold on a great
thing um somebody said on the stream
that changed i heard you didn't read it
okay
all right so let's go ahead and start
this
all right let me get in position
got the jump
bar incognito i'm gonna help you until
the first symbol pops up
okay now where's the symbol popping for
us because i'm not seeing um right here
so you see these three
yeah oh that's where the symbol pops
once it starts okay pops right there and
then the second and it goes down okay
guys okay i'm starting that's what i
want to do all right let's go
all right there's one
i don't have assembly yet
i don't have one either it doesn't pop
up into that taking kill
i think they're taking just um spawn
what are those explosions all right
yeah right
the hell is some explosion like we did
we missed something
but there's
yeah the only ones that can shoot it are
the uh i got it
or whatever
our thing's not even here yet soon
yeah sin i need your help
where is the interest of that circle
thing
the first seminar is right here but it's
not saying anything
i don't know maybe they maybe other
people have to do those first
no symbols that pop
our taking still isn't i bet you you i
bet you we didn't initiate it whatever
we did we didn't initiate this sequence
we got to figure what's initiating the
taking
there's something we're missing
something we missed that we did the
first couple of times
maybe
maybe you have to kill
maybe like it's spawn rated where like a
taken will spawn on one side and then
you can't they won't spawn anywhere else
until that one's killed so like it'll
spawn on one of our sides and when that
one's killed it goes to another side
because like we we kept it clear it's
literally just time sensitive
it doesn't matter how much damage that
bell takes it's time sensitive
right here this one but there's like no
entrance see if it's on top of it maybe
you have to fly it's on this side too
i i don't think i think those are just
showing the symbols i don't necessarily
think that you those have anything to do
with the raid like you know how like
they always like showing stuff
throughout the whole raid
because those aren't glowing or anything
i don't see how those would be
indicators of anything so rocket let me
put rockets
all right got it let me get over the
position all right we're gonna
we'll see we'll figure it out we're
getting we're getting there we initiated
it i think we got the encounter we just
got to learn how that one part what
we're missing is
yeah we just mentioned like one mechanic
but we definitely got the economic sense
of it
man why are they so strong now
an obelisk is under attack somebody's
under attack
i'll be right there to help you congress
let's take these guys away
okay yeah
the abated adherent are the only enemies
that can damage the obelisk
okay so you guys know the red bars
the elevators
yeah they don't shoot it i want to know
where our taking
that one time was over here but it's not
over here
go go ask mommy bother mommy
[Music]
i don't know where to go to
whatever
check
there's nothing open over by the circle
there's a circle
i had a taken in the back here really
yeah you have to kill that's why
i killed it
i killed it i killed it
yeah i think we have to kill those
takens like find where you're taking
spawns and ours is in the back yeah i
think because see what's interesting is
like my r spawned at one time but it's
not spawning anymore i feel like it's
random and if the person that it spawns
doesn't kill it none of them spawn
okay
so look for your taking there should be
three taken somewhere on this map
but i don't think they spawn at the same
time i think they i think they spawn
individually
so like like here's responding yeah so
it's like not and another one is keeping
this
keep an eye out for it all right i'm
starting it
oh [ __ ] all right uh yeah you started we
wouldn't even
well i mean we ain't trying to do it
we're just trying to find out about the
the taken thing right now
so look for that taken
okay
i gotta take it over by me kill it
he's pretty beefy
yeah it might be
yeah both of you need to attack the
taken because they they're strong
[ __ ] i'm defending the obvious i'm
coming
oh you killed him okay all right look at
look for look for yours will see if it's
spawn
uh he has not yet
it might he got him there yeah that
now
this guy over here got him oh [ __ ] thank
you all right ours is going to spawn
over here soon
i think unless they move him
so maybe it's time to where we have to
kill the free taking quickly and then
yeah the next step happens and then
that's all right we got ballroom i'm
gonna do this
i got circle and dagger through heart i
know where the dagger
there's is one back there
all right i'm coming
he's uh suppressed
should i go to the symbol that where i
know it is and see what i can do with it
yeah go let's try give it a shot give it
a shot oh it's too late i do like that
okay all right we got it though like
something's with those taken
seats hold up
hold on let me hear frost let me have
frost
so i just noticed that you know um what
i was talking about with the explosions
or whatever how the obelisk they make
that loud boom if they do that three
times i think we wiped because all three
were filled with orange and then we
wiped
yeah yeah yeah
so i think that's what's wiping us i
don't know how yeah
but they're
i don't know
i just noticed that i think i noticed
something on the obelisk itself
what you noticed maybe
maybe
when it opened up there was like a
something on the side i don't know i
wasn't for sure i it was when i ran past
yours
to pick you up
but i i'm gonna take a look a bigger
look this time all right you guys ready
you want to stay
yeah you want me to stay
do you want to stay um
i didn't start it i don't know who
started
can add it and look for that um
the uh taken guy
because it's only the yellow bars just
make sure we kill those dudes
i think they always spawn on this side
too
i haven't seen one yellow bar i don't
know
i haven't i have not seen the thinking
yet
okay
that's not spawning over by us yet
i'm looking though since he spawns up
here i'll keep an eye out
yeah i just want to see how one look
okay i'll i'll tell you if i see one
yeah if you see it just tell me then
i'll come here i just i need to see what
it is just in case we get
discombobulated and i have to do it
right okay
do we have a symbol yet no
no no
not one take okay take it isn't spawning
over there oh it should have been
probably at will's corner
i do not see it taken anywhere actually
i'm gonna go look
people look taken is not over on the
left side it's not
yet
it's not not on our side either
our obelisk is filling up though yeah
it's the it's almost done okay so it's
oh my god what's up look at this cognito
what's up it's filling up with a licked
up
yes i'm feeling it at the end once it
hits the end
it's a wipe we're about to wipe yeah
oh yeah yeah
you're right okay so there's got to be
some thing with the if you look the
first thing i'm pretty sure is
the the everest defeated i don't that's
the yellow bars right
the orange guys with the shoes yeah the
abated adherents are the ones you can
shoot the
whatever well
they're the ones with the shields
um scoring or whatever but i haven't
seen redwater shoe
we haven't seen a taken
since that one time we saw it taken i
don't know
what's going on okay look at this i
don't know what this could mean
do you think this is a mechanic
no i don't know
i think that's just lighting because
it's in every room but i don't know
it's it's up on the roof too it's up
there as well so
yeah yeah you're right okay you guys
ready i don't know exactly
okay
when we get our first symbol can y'all
look at your pillar real quick just
circle your pillar to find out um
there's something
okay yeah i should have recorded it when
i [ __ ] saw it on wilhelm's pillar
okay you guys ready the actual defending
like on the oh the circle okay
it looks like the plaques actually when
we go in the room and then it's the
plaques
that we see
where i shot it and then it turned forte
are you ready maybe we gotta shoot those
flats
let me wait no scream i think no screams
circle around it because i think it's
only on maybe like one or two sides or
something
okay if there is anything i'll shoot it
if there's not anything i'll i'll just
yell that out maybe it's like when two
symbols get there because i know it's
timed and they probably made it to where
it's gonna be like a really tight window
but i don't know
the symbols popping up i think we have
to go into those rooms
and do something there i don't know
i do think it has to do with the rooms
but i think we got to hit the pillar
first
okay
so maybe it's just like a defend and pay
attention to the obelisk and shoot the
symbols maybe and then run to the room
that's what opens the door
after the timer's done
yeah so maybe the first phase is a timed
kind of puzzle
and then the second phase is going into
the different corresponding rooms on
your uh on your uh pillar
what do you think the taken have to do
with it
uh i don't know i think maybe that stops
the timer on the obelisk itself because
i know if the
adherent whatever the shielded guys that
they shoot the obelisk are you ready
four times quicker
okay
all right i'm starting it
i think we're close we just gotta we're
missing a key mechanic
i just hate the fact they got shield
yeah it's rising it's definitely time
mechanic
i think driving
whoa hold up hold up
okay i'm looking on my thing right now
um
i don't see anything just yet but i do
have the circle symbol up top
there's nothing around it at all
okay
all right so i'm coming back i was just
looking around no i don't i don't mind
we're exploring we're learning we're
learning yeah
it goes up
it goes up every so often yeah
i'm gonna go around soon after i get you
up hold up
yeah it's filling up really quickly so i
think maybe the take and stop that from
filling up
should i shoot the thing in the middle
that we shot to start the thing like
this shoot it let's see just see let's
tell the experiment
what does it do
there's nothing on the pillar right now
nobody got a symbol with a pillar nope
i'm looking on it right now this guy's
shooting at mine though i'm gonna have
to
it's not like it matters i don't think
more
there's nothing on here
the only thing i have is whoa i got
locked in
yeah
i'm locked in this room
really
all right so
all right
we're not getting taken anymore
those emblems that show up on your or
your uh like the crosstalk
yeah is it
it basically directs the person to where
they need to go for the first one
and then you go all the way down till
you get to the bottom boy
okay so if you see okay but if you see
so much says
it's over here
so that means the person that's whoever
if you say circle that means that that
somebody needs to go to the circle but
there's nothing opening on it yeah
there's not a that's that circle right
there and there's no opening there's a
circle there
look
this door opened this door open when i
walked through it it shut wait which
door let me
[Music]
let's start it look around for these
doors
let me get over there
everybody ready
okay we'll start up we're getting closer
we got it
oh whatever you get call it out look one
of the doors opened uh on on uh on cog
side
well all the doors are open right now we
just need to they open no it's all open
no not all these doors are open
oh okay yeah so holy holy guy or
whatever on the right side is open in
the back yeah i see that
yeah we got it over here
okay i don't have a symbol yet i don't
have a symbol yes wait no you know
um
there's two symbols in this room
all right
i don't get it felt like
what are you doing i do not have a
symbol on mine yet
what did we do to initiate that taken
coming out it's like we were doing it in
the beginning like we haven't done it
since
i don't see it taken on this side
so i don't know yeah i haven't seen one
either we haven't seen it since so
something that we were doing initially
was actually part of the mechanic
that we're not doing now
okay
because we are not even initiating the
taking
anymore
sinister have you been going up to that
one spot to grab that thing out of that
is that um
important do you think i don't know
on the topic shooting the first one
on the left
yeah
maybe that's kind of because it doesn't
even start the encounter
right i know but
hmm
i'm wondering what that is
these doors
wait is there another one on the right
side
no i wish
no not all right
maybe that's like a
puzzle thing i don't know
right
okay so then you bring it back to your
obelisk or your pillar and you know it
gives you
it gives you a once you kill the glyph
keeper it gives you another glyph
for you to tell the people on the
outside
okay all right hold up let's start it
and you show us what you're talking
about
all right i'm starting it now show us
what you mean by that i don't know what
you mean by that
but where's forte there he is
when you see it forte tell us we'll all
run to you [ __ ]
somebody wasn't playing
scream on the
i was looking for i was trying to look
around
we had the
opportunity can someone go get him
i'll go get him oh [ __ ] yeah you got to
get him
i got
him
don't have to worry about it
buddy
see this door opened again
and it lights up when you're in there
well it lights up regardless but it's
nothing inside that room because that
door isn't active
it's gonna like it's gonna take a lot of
trial and error and experimentation
i still don't have a symbol so we're
doing so there's a symbol over here on
let's
theirs
man i'm already dead while you hit me
with your shield man
this is yeah i don't want to look up
somebody else's stream
no
we don't need to go that far
you don't want to be world first
no
[Laughter]
all right
look i'm not against that but
i let let's keep going lately
we tried for like for like we we just
learned something since like let's get
the secret like
see what's interesting is these
what's interesting
what's interesting is these these doors
are opening
what's these doors are opening i just
don't maybe there's there's an a like
whatever your symbol is hold let's okay
you said you guys is a circle forte yeah
ours is always let's cheat the ring
let's just jump over well there's a
circle too definitely the next part of
the ring oh the next part of the raid is
definitely over there let's go
just curious nothing in here none of
these like the ones in the middle they
don't open i think that might be after
all we got to do is jump across
all right all right well this is what
we're going to do this time what look in
all of your doors let's find this
already at
what are you considering the doors so i
know what you're talking about let me go
where are you
these doors
like right now this is the side being
sends on right
now right now this store is closed but
it opened when the when the encounter
started
we understand that but you're not
getting anything out of it though yeah
but i feel like there's going to be
something in one of the doors maybe not
all of them yeah they're opening on
every single
they're opening on every correspondent i
feel like one of them is going to have
something in it when the taken spawn
where i noticed you went in here did it
just spawn in here
yes there's always going to be swearing
was it like right around
it was like right around here it was
right here yes oh okay what is this hold
up there's a diagram up here
look in the middle there's a diagram
look up
is that significant i don't know
um
like in the other room with a bunch of
symbols there was a guy holding that and
his
right hand all right let's go ahead and
start it and look in these rooms let's
let's eliminate that
all right i'm starting it now it doesn't
matter if we die let's just look in
these rooms yeah the door open look i
just saw it look at it everyone go open
yeah everyone go in that room and see if
there's something in it
okay i'll stay here okay
sorry i wasn't defending i'm just
looking yeah
and just see what it is
okay there's two symbols in the back
here but there's nothing there's the two
compasses one star one's light
oh wait there's something on the wall to
the left here too it's the same thing
that was in there these have the same
two symbols in this room
oh
never mind
is there anything open down here
door's not open down there
the thing didn't even fill up but we
died i think it's because we're going in
the wrong rooms
maybe maybe
you think we maybe have to all move as a
unit towards the giant
i think you got to go in the correct
room yeah corresponding to the
corresponding we got to figure out what
these garfield keeper defeats are like
forte you said you saw one
no i just said
no i didn't see one i just said that's
what they're inside the room that you go
into the corresponding room that you
have to go into there's a good keeper in
there all right let's let's do what we
used to do
and
just that like check your area heavy for
that taken
watch out for us
is there something
is there are these on each
side this straight right here it look
yeah it looks like you have nothing to
put something there
i don't know
and they got the same symbol here
i mean the same setup here there's
nothing there's a door
okay i don't know nothing let's just
start it outside of the box let's just
start we just have to yeah
we're gonna have to keep it what we're
gonna have to do is like check your area
hardcore for that taken like because i
feel like that taken is relevant
clearly
but it's he's being inconsistent
any doors open i don't see a few
i'm gonna look around sand try to
okay that one's open to the right again
but when i went in there there's a thing
here you can shoot that open this door
in the back
yeah
oh take it i'll take it
okay i threw a vortex oh
the right here's this triangle there's a
triangle over here
you gotta be quick that he's taken
okay maybe they're just gonna go in a
circle okay we killed two taken on our
side there should be more taken popping
up yeah
so whatever you shot spawned the taken i
think yeah yeah it was over here
um
the nose that opened the door that we
got into the room it looks similar to
the one that starts the encounter yeah
we gotta probably look for those
where was yours
up on top where the big uh like
sphinx thing is
by its foot i'll show you
yeah we saw in the back we saw that map
uh senpai we did see that matt
all right show me where this is
i don't know if it'll be there every
time no they're not
well i knew that because we've killed
them before and nothing popped up like
that
right i wasn't paying attention
there it's actually it's still here
hold on get up there
yeah me attic and uh yeah there's one
here
so you should cut that open this door in
the back and then when i went in there
there was one of those symbols on the
back walls yeah there was a plaque on
the back and you could shoot that and it
activated something those same glasses
and then it turns back
um
maybe there has to be somebody in here
the whole time telling you which room to
go into
i don't know that's a good idea maybe
you have to fill in every room you know
maybe the take-in was showing up because
people were just getting lucky going to
the right rooms and that's why we got
far that one time
yeah we got two just on our side on the
left yeah we don't know the first time
i've seen take it on our side i mean
maybe the taken will keep maybe the
taking will keep spawning unless you do
something
specifically
it feels like they're taking spawn
because we we initiated something
correctly all right go ahead and start
it let me see if this if this
changes start it
okay someone shoot the thing okay
says it's a circle still
still says circle
it's still not changed
wait circle okay i got circle on my toe
i'm shooting it nothing's happening
there's nothing on the obelisk
all right so
maybe it's your side oh these are
do they glow on our side closure
obviously once i get a second symbol
that i know that has a door i'm gonna go
to it
[Applause]
oh
you know you shoot the thing in the
middle it's changing the door way
okay
look i'm shooting the thing in the
middle and it's oh
left on the bottom okay i'm going i'm
going to go go
okay yes the door's open doors open
okay i'm running into a big big room um
there's a bunch of symbols and something
just spawned
okay yes
all right progress
i shot that thing and it i thought it
wiped this because that's what i shot
that thing and immediately wiped this
before so i just kind of really
yeah okay whatever just have a white
mechanic
[Music]
remember remember when i told you i got
locked in a room
remember how i told you guys i got
locked in a room
yeah that's because someone shot that
middle thing and it locked me in there
all right this is what we do
can i use the bathroom really quick yes
okay
that's fine that's fine this is this is
what i feel like we should do
we we uh
now you said the so
we hit that button one time and it
seemed like it that's what changed the
uh
the let me start he doesn't matter he's
gone i just want to see what happens
all right now tell me if it changes
all right so right now
wait what all the left doors are open
these doors over here the brain doors
open
you see it
when you need to change sides
yeah i think that's what you have to do
oh i got locked in this room too
i see where you got locked in
all right look over here frost
your thing is glowing red
this thing here
does everyone have a red thing over
there that could glow red maybe that's
showing that you have to do your side
first
maybe
red means wrong
all right hey artifact i'm not would you
figure out
all right so let's wait for that uh that
logo and then let's let's open the door
that you need to so
i um i'll be
we have to probably designate someone
i'll open the door let's just do it one
time i just need to see one side
all right so this is
this is what we do
go ahead and
first off let's put a flag down
i'm full on everything let's do how we
normally do everything when you see your
symbol pop up my only thing is i don't
understand the symbol thing because
sometimes a circle will pop up i don't
how what happened that made that symbol
with the the someone getting yeah i
assembled chain for the first time
somebody did something yeah
to the man with the hole in his heart
yeah and then i went okay okay that's
what we do
no listen when you tell me you're like
if anything pops up on here the circle
tell me i'll shoot the middle and we'll
see if it changes maybe we have to do it
one at a time
all right so go to your spots we're
going to try this
now tell me
tell me if your sting comes up and i'll
i'll shoot it and change it
okay
symbols don't start spawning for like 20
seconds though yeah maybe a minute
so just make sure you don't die just
actually
anything popping up all right we got a
symbol
no
we got one
are the chain
no it went from the circle side
the symbol equals our side right
yes
oh i get what you're saying
hold on let me change it again let me
see what happened yes they that those
okay yeah yeah hold up hold up hold up
hold up
is everyone say circle
no it's just us why did it change again
when i close it
14 went in why'd you lock him in
i'm just looking
is he still locked out
i think it's at a cost every time you
flipped it
okay probably
we still don't have a symbol on earth we
still don't have a similar for the first
time yeah do you i've never seen or not
have a simple
you seen anything forte
it was nothing down there
well we don't have a i don't have i
don't still have an implement so yeah we
don't have nothing on ourselves so maybe
it's like
it's about to fail
maybe we have to kill that taken first
love you babe
finally take and kill the ticket wait
wait wait sin you said when you killed
the taken you got you got a a buff
didn't you like the compass something
no no i said his name was the oh
disciples maybe when you kill him you
could you're able to click that let's
try that
can find your taken when he's dead tell
everybody and we'll hit that because
something happened we we did something
when i hit that it changed it changed
people's logos
so this is triangle this is circle but
they they're both triangle circle
yeah but our our
our pillar said circle so i'm assuming
so hold on hold on um
there's two doors on each side there's
two sides so the circle and triangle
side and then there's
the
uh
this well actually this is the three
doors there's three doors
so there's the blue dude there's that
dude and there's that dude
all right
yo yo okay
so those are like
but they're still on the side sort of
like if you're
yeah left side right side if you're
confused
look at the mat look at the map and here
like it's telling us where everything is
there's something below it look yeah
this map right here so whatever is uh
the
this infinity thing that's this room
then they say the one to the left is
some kind of like blue icon and the one
to the right
which one are we on
i don't know let's go ahead
no that's it no but that's in every room
that is in every room that's simple
no every every room soon
oh look
let's start it i'm going to go in a room
and see if one glows
is there exactly six doors
yeah
there's exactly six doors okay
i think so but there might be there
might be more i don't know
okay yeah there's three on my side on
the left side yeah i just was wondering
if there's anything that indicates that
could indicate like it would say like
triangle guy with hole in the heart you
know like that kind of thing right
i just want to know how we changed it
that kind of thing
um
i
i would bet
that we have
i would bet that we have to find the
taken guy
kill the guy and then we can shoot the
thing in the middle oh the middle door
is open
we'll designate where we open up
okay
um
okay yeah lord's going down word addicts
going down
find anything down there
i'm gonna let him explore i was gonna go
in but i'm going to help cognito yeah
we got we got triangle black and black
um brown red and black triangle
we have no symbols on left side where do
you got that
it's on it's on the it's on the wall
over here next to me
where
that's it it's on the wall you don't see
it on the wall up there oh we got a
triangle okay so that's the first thing
so maybe it's triangle side
okay all right how did that how did we
get that to appear it just popped it
just popped up
huh
it just lets you know that that's the
side
do we have to stay like in proximity
like close to the monolith
[Music]
yeah i feel like we just need to get our
symbol like somehow we get our symbols
to appear and then we go where it tells
you
right i don't know
i don't know what the uh
maybe we can only shoot the middle thing
after we kill that
um
taken
thing right right
like maybe they're taking gives us like
gives
a debuff or a buff or something like
that yeah even if it doesn't pop up
maybe that's just something that oh
maybe
maybe we have to find our symbols then
we kill the taking guy then we shoot the
thing that opens the doors and we all go
to our spots
and something
else happens give it a shot
i don't know
give it a shot let's give it a shot if
anyone has yeah if anyone has ideas we
can just do it we can just do it here
continue
[Music]
go look at somebody else so we can catch
and most people don't seem like they're
very far past this i mean i've seen a
couple i'm watching a couple other
things like you don't know but you're
doing the same thing
nobody's really like there's been who is
it that you're glad dude that has all
the wrapping belts right why we don't
have it right now
well one thing i did say was if you want
me to tell you one thing i'm streaming
but it still seems like people were past
here so never mind
somebody he said he struggled he cut off
the stream
nobody's really anymore
stream is down
yeah this part's really actually kind of
complicated
all over again
there's a lot of moving pieces there's a
lot of moving pieces to it yeah
um
when all that fails playmatic
no
i will say be prepared to fight some
beefy enemies in this room why you don't
have
a thousand voices blame addict
i still don't have 1k me neither
it refuses to sell it for me
i'm over it
that gun doesn't like me i've accepted
it
a beasty gun
oh you're a sleeper i don't care yeah me
too i like i like i like sleeping i
don't like you
y'all
can't be acting like that i know you
like that i try to be friends mad times
we don't want to be friends so what we
have found out is that
there is triangle and circle side
there's three doors corresponding on
each side right side and left side
i still don't understand
how someone changed our symbols on the
totem
and then i went into the room with the
um
guy through the hole through his heart
or whatever
and then got enemies to spawn and i
guarantee you if if we had more time
there would have been a glyph keeper in
there
keeper
i don't know how to do that i wish i
knew how to do that or i don't know
hey because that was actually the
farthest we've gotten technically
everything
okay oh okay all right yeah
all right
it's rain day put your phone on silent
you guys ready
yeah i'm ready let's
oh man that's [ __ ] strats
nice
yeah
that's a good sign all right take it
nice all right cognito let's keep an eye
out just in case yeah keep an eye out
yep
i'm coming
okay um
i'll take it on our side right here take
it outside okay i'm coming i'm coming
so dark triangle somebody praising um
the disciple and darkness i got a glove
sleeper i got a good keeper yes that's
what i want to hear
okay ritual concludes okay
okay okay we did really good that time
we did really good that time do we know
why we did really good
but it's not entirely sure
was it i think maybe it was just like
look at that
look at that let's keep it clean
you like that
that's his baby
did it seem like when we were just
finding the um
the taken that was what was progressing
it because we i got no i feel soul
i feel something like change
getting killed fast because remember
they're called disciples compass so it's
like directing us to what we got to do
almost in a sense i feel the name i feel
like
you kill your taken like if everyone
kills their take it on their side that
changes what your thing looks like right
right now it's only you like you only
see the symbol of your side but when you
kill that taken on that side that then
that's what it is
when it says circle it says that there's
a taken on the circle side you go kill
that taken on the circle side then it
changes it the fact that it's the name
compass it's like it it's directing us
to where we got to go after we killed
you know what that makes so much sense
man yeah it's literally in the name the
accomplice is to help you all right
let's go tell when you see a symbol show
up tell us what side so we can all come
together and make sure we get the right
side because i had two different symbols
no
hold on i i think i i know what's going
on though
i got to see
it was both triangle that's funny so
maybe triangle it's always going to be
that side
circle
circle okay that's right side
i found the taken
did it happen look at it
uh we got the circle brain
circle break yeah there we go we got it
open up the other side swap it swap it
okay i have a triangle
all right i'm going inside rain
okay
i still have carnival here
nothing's spawning in here wait they're
spawning now
very hurry this thing's filling up
okay taken might be back here nope just
more of these things we have not seen it
taken yes
uh something spawned here it's big one
the tower the tower the tower something
that looks like the tower
we got three on this side okay yeah okay
there's an unstoppable one
outside
yeah it's fine
okay so that
okay this is what's happening
hold up this is what's happening when
you see the symbol on your side that
that says yo there's a taking in the
room he's on the circle or triangle side
when you kill that taken that belongs to
that individual one then it changed
okay try and reset it
okay wait we gotta
get you and what's unstoppable
right now yeah
hand cannon
hank i have a hand cannon on so i'll put
unstoppable
yeah we're gonna need a pulse yeah
pulsing um i think i got a grenade oh i
could put glaze back on because they
disabled glaive unstoppable
oh
yeah one way to get rid of him
right
oh it's unstoppable
yeah we need to find let me put on the
glaze
if i didn't die i could have ran and
found the next we did good
it's like a symbol with the tower on it
let me switch out is it scout rifle what
is it
more damaging
or
um hand cannon hand
all right so this is
this is how it goes all right what
let me read this okay so
let me get come over here uh will
don't start anything again
there we go go yeah i got to take a look
too all right well this is how it
happens when you have a symbol you know
like
like show up like circle something
occasionally on here now i think the
reason that it doesn't show up all the
time is because there's can only be a
certain amount of taking on the field
so if we don't kill those taken that's
on the field we've always assumed it's
on our side but that's not the case it
will say circle so that means it will be
on the circle side there is a taking on
the circle side somewhere when you kill
that taken let's say that the middle one
circle that middle one will turn into a
specific one
when you get when you go in there
one of us will see it just randomly
because i don't always see that the
the the reason i don't think you always
you don't always see is because that
there's not taking on every side there's
only a certain amount of taking on every
side of the map
so until you kill those taken then it
doesn't show up
okay
all right now let me switch to
the first thing
i feel like i should put that glaze on
too put that glitter on man i forgot if
you got unstoppable
because you're not using a pulse what i
swapped it right when i was picking up
at it like
cause when i seen the big boy come on
said oh
[Music]
i think when you kill the thing inside
the room
look at your pillar and you have to
shoot whatever they're calling out
okay so after you get the glyph keeper
that's when you would shoot it you think
there's
is always chilling
i'll tell you what though man that
unstoppable popping up i was killing the
two shielded guys i look behind me he's
right there bro pucker factor i've
never been so [ __ ]
huge
yeah i think there's more than them too
they come in
it's like a hole
yeah i've got overload grenades or
whatever avoid grenades they stop
overload just in case
we got really far that time that was
actually a pretty good run
all that unstoppable glaive is five
i've heard it's pretty powerful though
with like um
all right all right
[Music]
the other half was doing work up against
them dudes
let me stop him and then switch to my
sword and just beat the [ __ ] out of him
get the hell out of here
it's literally what i'm doing when i
hear that
someone get mr yolkso or whatever his
name is up out of here we do not want to
buy followers we do not want to buy
primes and we definitely don't want to
buy viewership
i think what you do is just you i mean
the glaze is pretty good too because you
yeah
i want you gotta do against the
abhorrence to the double horns
so does everyone understand the
encounter if you don't it's fine just
say now forever hold your peace
uh because i i'm bringing it up now i i
might get a little offended if you don't
understand you're not saying anything so
what do you do you might as well just
say it after you kill the chicken
i don't know
how it's how the way i describe you kill
the taken that's going to change the the
symbol and then you go into that room
and the way
you kill the two guys in that room the
two big guys
once you kill them there's a symbol
going to spawn in that room you need to
tell that to the guy near the biller
and he has to shoot that pillar i think
all right but we we getting somewhere
that's all that matters
we're doing good
i'm very impressed with this run
so far aesthetics
top tier raid as far as aesthetic
for me
loving the pyramid thing loving to feel
like it's like it's like they collected
races
you know what i said
that's the vibe i got from them
and i like they talking a little talk
[Music]
this is very this is kind of spirey
i'll give you that
and if you look above it has like the
outside thing yeah it's all like
yeah big and dominant but the aesthetic
is just
ridiculous yeah they got me with the
rest but so far this is definitely one
of the coolest yeah
what i've seen
as far as pure aesthetics the only one
that i would always have to give even
though people don't like that raid
is original leviathan aesthetic was
fired too like the whole opulent thing
the ship you know i'm saying but this is
this is right up there too man
i always a fan of aesthetics right
make me believe where i'm at you know
what i'm saying
yeah i like to i like where they're
going then for sure
yeah man that barge encounter was fire
yeah
i like that guy
yeah i like it i didn't understand how
we did the puzzle before this part but
we got it done but i didn't really
understand what happened yeah i don't
know what the hell yeah i did to be
honest i just was telling y'all what was
in that room and i was like i could
reset it though
that's what i'm good at yeah y'all need
to go
let me know i got you i'll tell you
what's going on all right
everyone back that's the best fries is
everyone back
i didn't hear forte yet
i'm here
okay i'm just waiting
what it is when you kill a taking that's
when one of those circles show up
like on the thing
right we didn't get that at first
see when those circle things show up
that indicates there's a taking on the
field and until you kill it it's gonna
it's still just going to say a triangle
or a circle it's telling you what side
of the map to take it's on but when you
kill it it goes from a circle to a
triangle to what room you need to go
into it also
at the time on the um obelisk as well
when you kill a taken
what circle thing are you talking about
the that's that's on the planet
oh yo they said desolate gary said three
people
three raid teams just got error coded
and reset to the beginning of the raid
that sucks
damn could you imagine you got the boss
that thing
yeah i don't think anybody's that far
yet i'll just say like i don't know
maybe
i hope
i hope it was the three people at the
top
all right you guys ready
yeah give us a chance yeah thank you
thank you
budgie out here
you're too far
that means there's there's a taken on
the circle side
i'm looking for i'm looking for him
i don't see him on this
oh now it's triangle
okay triangle all right i'm looking
i don't see
any taken on my side yet
i don't see there's taken somewhere
i see one i see him i see him i see him
nice
okay
did the symbol change
yes got a couple type of heads up on top
of here
cup on top
oh take it take it by me
i got him i got him kill him
good [ __ ] damn he's still up he stood up
you got
or like somebody holding a barbell
okay
you gotta shoot those on this i think
you shoot those it's like glyphs that
show up on the side of the um
on the side of the monolith you gotta
shoot those corresponding to what you
call in there i think
note to self do not glaive the taken
he did not like that i should just use
my sword like i've been doing yeah i'm
gonna put on party overlay so that i can
see if you're calling it out cognito
okay
yeah put on party over there for
all right so this is what i recommend
i i recommend
i don't know let's let's try to do this
a couple times and see that where we go
yeah we're kind of getting the drift of
it we're getting the gift of it
are we ready
yeah i'm ready
yeah i'm ready i'm ready scream you good
scream since i'm looking at the um hear
me okay i'm looking at it
the plates after you know they're taken
to the door
uh
let's see
get away from the statue ball police
museum triangle triangle
okay he's on sir i go side
i'll go look for him
okay it's backed by you guys she's not
up here by us
listen over there
i didn't see him on the triangle side
okay i'm looking everybody else might be
underneath he might be underneath look
for that taken
look for that taken
he is not underneath
yeah there is people no there's a taken
over there with you
yeah in a room no right here yeah adam's
heading towards it now i don't see him
it's right here
he's to the right
okay
so yeah we need to get those spawns down
was that another triangle side yeah they
spawn a difference in the difference
different spots yeah i've never
i've never seen this
cuphead
is that where's that door
all right all right so hold up hold up
let's let's start it a couple of times
only worry about where the taking are
spawning because they're spawning in
different places we need a location
that's yeah yeah that's gonna be awesome
now look i'll i'll show you did you see
where that other one was spawned or do i
need to show you i need to you need to
show me where that was why i don't know
where the hell that was because i'm used
it was to the right of where we were on
the other side of that a lot of rules
all right you got to show me yes
just look at your radar your radar will
tell you if it's something in the area
where normally you wouldn't be
yeah because normally he would spawn up
here to the left and in the back he was
right i've only seen him in the back he
was right here oh no
he was up here in the front right yes in
the front right of the building
oh he was
[Music]
what we need to do is just go ahead and
start we're going to start it and we're
just going to look where these things
are
yeah
okay
i just got celestial nighthawk for no
reason yeah me too i got like a
sophomore porterfall exotic for no
reason but i'm like all right i'm gonna
argue with you
i guess forte wasn't participation
awards yeah
is
it's on triangle side okay yeah he's in
the back over here i got him
guardian
all right it changed it's it's looks
like the room
okay i'm gonna just look at my obelisk
real quick there's nothing on mine so
there's another one on triangle
yeah i'm just dying
okay
so now we know that depending on if it's
triangle or circle that's 100 where the
taken are spotted
they're just they probably have like
five or six spawns on that spot yeah
yeah i know where three of them are
there'll be one in the bottom one on the
right and one on the left
so when that there's no way
when that circle thing comes
up oh yeah you gotta
yeah it's a report with a certain thing
so pretty much like
just be wary on what side you're on
because
you can't come over here and kill the
people on circle you we're gonna have to
do that for you but you have to tell us
they're on circle side
okay so maybe um
for triangle side
um cognito do you want to
look for the taken or do you want me to
um it doesn't matter i mean you can look
for it i'll i'll just i feel like you
the the best way to do it is designate
you guys to like certain taken spots
like you're always looking at those
spots yeah because i'm all these are the
spots i'm looking at i'm always looking
behind here
because he a couple of times i've caught
him behind here he wouldn't come out and
i'm like oh what you doing man all right
so i'm always looking here
all right let's let's start it so we can
double check where all these are
that's the biggest thing we just got to
know where he's taking our spawning
triangle triangle side
okay
all right i'm gonna look
look look look
he's not bad
i'm looking in the corner
okay
yep okay sorry it was backwards
all right
dude arms up arms up i know it
just go get it i got these go get it
we have uh
what is that big circle
circle circle side
okay so that's right side
oh let's take it let's take it back here
yep on your side
all
right
triangle all right
i need help
oh man the disciple confidence
yeah that's not even my god i just found
a new spawn point somebody got to come
back here because he i've never got a
witch queen symbol on their pillar like
nobody's even looking
it's arrived dude we've had people die
to me oh no no no no come over here come
over here it's changing it's changing
sid look look look at the actual
platform it's got stuff on it
oh yeah
when you do the room it's putting it on
it
okay
so do we need to fill all of how many
pillars yeah we filled it out
no no we only filled three there was
there was a lot of other empty spots on
it
how many rooms do people do
one room together we're still gonna have
a problem you know there's there's a
blind spot where taking some space
over there i'll i'll look for that
i know where it is i didn't i didn't
know they spawned there i looked you're
doing it yeah i'll tell you there is a
blind spot that they're spawning and no
one's over there i had to leave my post
to go to the other side of the back over
here
where they at yeah i see it again it's
going to be responsible i'll get it i'll
get it for the ticket i would i would
have everybody run like uh rocket
launchers for this because you could
shoot one one galley kills them at a
distance
right here
the
the limit does it pretty
all much let me change out
the lament does it well
yeah but i need my heaviest foot
or oh i mean my kinetic for the thing
gives
i can change to a rocket just so you
have to run as close yeah yeah because
that's what i'm running too close and
then the damn disciples killing me so
yeah let me switch to the rocket
as much as i like the sword i can't risk
[Music]
and the first team has completed i'm
kidding
i don't think i think this one's going
to be really large
look if you look at it
they're on every side there's there's
platforms i've said that like a hundred
times no no i'm just saying i'm saying
what
at the end they they were glowing like i
think it's the rooms that we do we're
glowing here yeah
no i'm talking about on here i feel like
here's where it tells us what side and
over here tells us what side we've done
yeah
the bottom sets
when i did the middle i came back and
the bottom had a circle like it was
complete and then we supposed to look at
the um this killer and then do that next
where are all
[Music]
is it going to be every single group has
somebody running while everybody else
yeah we've been doing this
okay all right all right because we're
not getting the same symbol are you guys
ready
yeah i'm ready i'm ready
i think they had the same symbol
guys might have
okay triangle triangle
if there's circle tell us
all right take us dead
um triangle with um
it's front right on your guys's side
sinister
um the guy with the cup on top of his
head
step on top going
okay i get it
triangle there's still something over
there alive on triangles yeah i see it
taken on me
okay you got it for us
uh i don't even know it's a white on top
green in the middle right on the bottom
[Music]
well i was fighting unstoppable i
couldn't leave her he was gonna kill me
okay
we didn't kill the taken
just start the next one
yeah it's the identifying of the tank
i didn't see the symbol on my pillar for
which side it was on
so that means all pillars need to look
for it and then
whoever shoots the symbol it resets
everybody
yeah i wish i knew how to
sin do you think man do you think both
people should go into the room
i had to stop myself i'm gonna say the
mexican flag
do you think hold up hold up listen
do you think both people should go into
the room because i feel like there's too
much for one person to do
i died because the scream jumped on me
okay well let's start it because that
time we got fun i was i was reading it
and it screamed jumped are you guys
ready
yeah yeah i'm ready
yes
okay circle circle circle okay
circle
ah he's front right oh he's over there i
see him rock it rock it i'm shooting
rocket
automatic
all right yeah i know where it is
yep downstairs
oh [ __ ]
oh dagger through circle okay yeah yeah
reset
and it's still circle up top on mine so
it's the tower the tower the symbol is
the tower middle
middle
the tower
all right
it's in black
middle yeah
good
so on the obelisk i saw a bunch of
different symbols started to pop up
there was a spot in the middle do you
have to shoot them in a circle yes
you have to shoot it
okay because just like we were shooting
a
lot
and i think that might have been fault
my fault while it why it ended because
the obelisk was not full yet but i shot
the op or the inkblot because i heard
you saying block and it just ended yeah
don't do it
okay yeah i was thinking about bottom so
yeah that's wrong okay okay okay okay so
that's okay it wasn't on my obelisk then
it would have been on a different one
somebody else's so we gotta call out the
two symbols everybody has to look at the
obvious and then it has to be
top bottom or middle and then pull out
the symbol
all right okay so yeah when when he's
calling out
i don't know he's trying to keep calm's
clean i guess
yeah let's let's get this part together
and
and then we'll figure out what the next
part is
i feel like i'm always dismissed when i
feel like that's the right way
you can't have mag
chef should have gotta
speak up too and defer on other answers
also
part of learning
all right where's the taking out anyone
looking at their circle circle side
looking for him i'm looking for him
oh
all right it's dead
okay we're looking hole in the heart to
your left frosty
yep i'm going
it's
i'm looking for it looking for it don't
see him don't see him it's over here
there he is
he's nova bomb he's done
okay um
middle
all right we're good we decided to do
that faster that's all we're good
okay yeah man i need to put something on
for those guys in there man they were
actually pretty
pretty
yes
we can change up to um cognito will you
be able to take out the unstoppables
on our side if i put on a grenade
launcher to deal with the guys in the
whatever
um yeah i can stun the unstoppable if i
stay with the lathe
okay
because they have solar shields and i
had nothing on that oh there's solar i
got clouds pretty much gotcha the only
thing is do you have anything
unstoppable if the unstoppable comes out
but i'm not there okay hold on a second
let me see that's the key
that's the key
that's my main concern
is there any like abilities that can do
that there is solar melee
try to one man solo this [ __ ] ring go
ahead try it
[Music]
what i've been doing is
um i sit next to the door and the moment
that uh
unstoppable comes out i'm
i mail it with the uh with the the blade
just switch to the limit and it kills it
in like three or four hits
right i just don't want to take off my
osteo striga man because it oh no the
crowd control yeah
i don't want to take off my scepter
really good with crowd control
once i got their solar shields done
which took a minute but once i did it it
just deleted on my i could actually kind
of walk away and get my health back
while the poison did its damage but
i don't know
um
if anything with a pickle i can just
switch back to my pally and go back and
forth between explosive personality if i
have to go into a room and palindrome
but i'll keep my personality what the
hell is that sound
forte eating everything in the room i'm
not eating
all oh back at it let me get the banner
all right i'm starting everyone ready
oh yeah i'm ready
send forte
i'm ready
[Music]
i hate those opponents with the shield
man
i can't stand the asses
okay
i see why they disabled uh triangle
arms up
at it it's on you i'm going to arms up
praise the cycle
i mean uh
our veil
stupid freaking okay circle circle
somebody gets here you guys gonna be on
circle side okay
it's good kind of hard for me to get
anything i see him i see him i'll get
him
hole in the heart i'm going
i died in there forte you know where to
go triangle where where where where oh i
see it okay disciple arms up
i got that i got the guy yeah the symbol
on mine is uh
but it's not opening i think we have to
kill the taken first i got triangles
switch it
how did i get stuck back here oh it
stopped
inkblot middle uh
okay so maybe we have to get those two
first symbols before i go into mine on
the left side
okay
i feel like the best thing to do at this
point
is let's
two people all like since we have three
people roaming have three people do it
like they'll do uh the first one that
pops up they'll go do that one then
they'll go do the other one because i
feel like one person that are either
dying or they're taking too long
okay yeah so i feel like three people
could do one
when we call it out yeah i feel like
three people can do it way quicker than
just one per three people can do every
one of them quicker than one person
doing one individually quicker
that's right but
what about the obelisk though like
you're gonna are you gonna be leaving
the obelisk yeah
no yeah there'll just be one on each
side like there's still one person on
each side so frosty you're a runner
for taser running i'm a runner
oh no if it's on right side i'll run
over to right side and help you guys and
if it's on left side you guys run over
here and help me yes
okay perfect that's a lot better i
actually feel more comfortable with that
all right let's start this yeah some
dudes are beefy in there it took me a
minute to take them down even with a
nova bomb
yeah yeah
for sure
okay so if it's over inside just call
that out so that i can start
circle
circle circle
is that up here he's on the weird attic
hold on there's a lot of ads in them
just get him just
i'm going to i gotta
don't yeah do not hold on to your
supergirl let them look all right first
call out
it's on one of the other sides it's not
on our side
i'm right behind you
okay
okay oh [ __ ]
yeah there's
yeah all right
oh god
okay
all right so yeah i forgot to be
cognizant of the screams
yeah man it was really tiny in the other
room it was a little more okay hey one
of the
runners no i mean it's a wrap like we've
lost too many tokens
um that would take half the tokens just
to get them up um
somewhat something behind frosty and
they can one of them
can one of the runners trade with me i
would feel way more comfortable as a
runner than i would as a as guarding
these pillars
you're a titan so i trust you
you want to run you you just run [ __ ] it
yeah you're probably more feasible to
guard than me well at least for me
because i'm a hunter
i mean
you don't have to ask anybody else we
could just swap all right that's fine
hold right let me just switch one part
of my fragment since i'm gonna complete
defense the only reason i volunteered
myself is because i already identified
where all the um
all the markers on
all right one second would you change it
all right so forte you're over there
with sinister then
right side
i'm with will
will where is your taken spawn
there's three uh it's either right here
rarely
or
um back there
him back here like one or two times
but
i'm gonna start left and go and go
do the rotations
all right go ahead and start who's
running who's running i'm running uh
sinister i am
i can't start it anymore someone else is
going to start
it initiate
is this the rig
okay cool
give me the raid
this bride just left the party open
yeah it probably should do
uh circle side
circle
or something
check the back over here
[Music]
nope
yeah i don't see him up front so he's
probably in the back
he's got to be by you addict
i i'm looked i i don't see he showed me
where all them spawn
he's that over here
well maybe he's back here
i think he is back here yep he's back
here
cool cool cool cool cool cool
things fill it up
okay um
uh dagger through heart dagger through
hearts yeah i got too hard this is the
only other spot he'll spawn occasionally
oh it's done anyway
that was our fault because uh
i thought he said it spawns in the
middle it could spawn anywhere in that
area it's like in the back there so
we're technically
we're on circle right we're on circle
check your radar
i think the front and back like that
front session could be either one it
could be left or right because it's in
the front
so you need to check that
you need to check this side no matter
what like i said just run up there and
check your radar if you don't see it on
your radar you know you ain't there yeah
that's how i've been once you told me
that that's how i've been checking it
that's what i've been looking right now
situational radius radar checking my
screaming direction i'll go over there
just a piece pvp comes into handy every
once in a while
your pvp instinct's kicking in
yeah
i'm in the wrong spot
guy comes in
i don't have a symbol on ours
not yet circle
circle circle
yeah it's over here i see it on radar
he killed me
i must have been weak when i went jumped
up there because he one shot me
um he did circle again he's dead
okay now uh
oh i see dagger through the heart
okay so that's right side again i'll go
in there i'll go all right you you going
you're going like a block
all right i'm coming to help forte
somebody went down
me
all right i have
a stoppable body circles three circles
in the three circles at the top
and then two umbrellas middle we have a
possible
yeah i'm telling you that lament does
work man you hit him with that glaze
what what i realized is one of the codes
that dropped oh
the area that you're going into right
that automatically resets but the two
symbols are for the other people the
other pillars
so one pillar has one call out and the
other pillow has another call out
okay
this rocket ain't it man
i hit him with that glaive and i kill
him with that lament long before he goes
you can run it that's good for y'all but
for me i can't
it's up to you
yeah my character is more built to
defend i'll give it one more shot let me
try this machine if not then i'll switch
the limit the next one yeah because what
i do is i just press right bumper when
i'm just killing people just right
bumper second just give me one and then
when it comes out you take it out
so i'm taking out the taking the
unstoppable all the ads all with the
limit and i still have plenty of ammo
so [ __ ] with the void you just throw
your grenade your um
um suppressive grenade and it blows
everything up
and if you got the riff with the with
the little turret the little friendly
guy that weakens
when you the first thing you shoot at
it's going to go towards that and weaken
everything around it so if you're
defending you just might want to rock
void
let me try one more time with stasis
only because
i can crowd control them before they
even come out
yeah
okay but i understand you slowing them
i'm just
blowing up all right which i'll give him
one more time i'll switch to y'all
drinks yeah
it also pulls people in now as well yeah
i i throw this around what i'll do is
i'll throw a stasis uh uh uh i'll throw
a suppressive grenade at the unstoppable
if i can't get to him quick enough
right
all right
all right
and then we can start all right i hit it
where's will
i'm here oh
yeah man osteosarcos
what side is it on a circle circle
our side
oh you're checking all right yep i got
to take it
i'll defend
i think it's dead
standing by uh brain it's to the left
where frosty is
okay all right
all right i'm going i'm opening
all right i'm right behind you frosty
yep i'm gonna just walk into the room
and let them you know spawn instead of
going to the back
careful with the screams
there's another one in the back here
guys
oh i died looking at it you took too
long
i'm like staring at it
all right i'm gonna help with this
unstoppable and then i'm gonna head out
yeah
the weight just turn around i'll shoot
pyramid type
how many bullets you need to put into
that
you just gotta [ __ ] at once
oh my god stop spawning me into a fire
he threw it after it
that's how it goes yeah i'm switching it
has to glow it can't you have to shoot
it one time to glow
yeah because i gotta do a little bit
that that what you're doing
i'm switching the void
my dumb ass put all void weapons into my
[ __ ] slots man
give me one second switching now
let's be a void it's going to have to be
to play
i mean this explosive personality is
okay
we're getting it though we're getting it
like i'm telling you guys did you see
how quick
those ads went in there down frost
yeah that lament is destroying those
things
mm-hmm i'm about to switch right through
that grab andre right out the vault
shout out to flame definitely didn't
miss this stuff good luck lads no doubt
don socaro says i hope he gonna get free
carries after this no
okay cool i'm
[Music]
limit we should good to go
let's do that
better
hold on i'm not open little light
actually is this the animal manager
who's
oh man i wonder who's broadcasting on
youtube is it addict iron what's podcast
youtube
forward slash
great
i'll just
you say austria was doing good for you
um flying how did you like osceola i
love how that's what i've been using
yeah
i can avoid weapons with the rest with
the voice sword
yeah the void sword does pretty good
it's just like that lament man it hits
like a truck
really literally rock wrecks them up but
are you switching a void uh subclass
yeah
i gotta avoid sword
yeah
all right let me switch to the void
volatile trip
that y'all rocking
okay
thou shall rock blood blood
yeah you have to light them up like said
was like shooting it like
oh well lighting and unlighting and
lighting and unlike
i'm not sure like where is it lighting
up that's why i'm shooting it crazy
they really showing off their water
graphics
look at how we do water
come here frosty
jump at the water and you'll see how it
affects your screen
oh yeah
oh
like warps your whole gun and everything
yeah i like it it's pretty cool
orbs
sorry guys
you're good oh no you're fine aj
what after he said that uh
um you look at my armory
extended warranty
oh god
i hate that joke
imagine if they're like real people and
they're just trying to do their job and
every single time they
um
the moment you if you take out a room
that's on one particular side that's
when you're going to see the uh the over
champion
ah they gave me a turn back
um
there is a ceiling
yeah i don't really care how long this
one takes it's actually really cool it's
really fun actually yeah
actually a fun encounter it's intense
i'm sure once contest mode is done and
people are you know reverted back to
like 13 80 12. like
it'll be good
mm-hmm i do want that 24-hour emblem
but so far it's not looking too bright
it's only been a couple hours man two
hours and 45 minutes it's not bad
all right i'm ready to touch the thing
right do i get the right surprise
all right we'll help you guys in the
next area
he clicks dude
he's under the water right now
yeah i thought he was behind this great
or something i got him i was gonna come
here i got my void sword with uh this
drink but lament will be next
the switch sword
wait one second
yeah i might put that bringer on if i'm
being honest i just don't want to take
off my osseo striker but if i'm yeah
i'm taking it
yeah are we starting what's going
i just wanted to see where this i can't
go any further though it's just a wall
just waiting on fourteen i'm i'm done i
wonder if we're gonna be able to run on
the dead worm
yeah that's bringing it into the boss
encounter
great
crazy
can we see that worm how big that worm
is
yeah it's nuts man and he still goes
around to the other side over there too
and then his head goes down and then up
that would be crap
which one did um was it
are you back four times yeah oryx killed
akka i think
so that might be him
no this is moving this one's alive
he's just it's alive
it's moving it's breathing it's like a
breathing effect
i thought that was just the clouds oh
okay i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying
okay
huh
i thought someone spawned their sparrow
but forgot to have those under the map
guardians
one of the sponsors back outside
nope we're gonna have to light
what happens because we'll
are you sure
i guess i'm tested
i just got stuck on the invisible
barrier
oh
oh
we're having bad pain
carrying
[Music]
all right you guys ready
yeah
i
this
is
it's the one
it's the one let me grab that thing
all right
got it super is ready
all right i'm starting it three okay two
one
i cannot wait to see the raid boss with
that big ass [ __ ] worm
right
uh
and you won't have symbols on there let
us know where they're taking her
oh take it take it back here take it
back here triangle
okay so it just turned okay
got him
yeah we're going for him right now
he's dead
uh
right there next to you forte right here
triangle with the with the light coming
out of it right here right
here okay i'm coming forward today
triangle let's take it it's taking them
in this corner
yup found them
playing around
oh [ __ ]
hands hands with uh
pyramid hands
upside down down here alone
oh man you're gonna die
come in
and what spot top middle or bottom
we gotta be that we gotta do that way
quicker
mm-hmm
we did not receive a call out when you
went in there
forte
communications yo maybe there you go
you're all right no no no i shipped i
wish i shipped a xbox damn it travis
he just
[ __ ]
spoiled son
oh
why he messaged you in ld ring no he
just spoiled something about the raid
oh who cares
do you want me to tell you i mean
what did you beat it there there's a new
mob their father
oh nice all right cool cool say no more
what's up
what
a new mob
oh
that's right
yeah i was talking to enrique about i
shifted my xbox a couple weeks ago and
um
he hadn't got it yet
right it did like just like a week and a
half ago so i called the ups tracking
center could have said it was in north
carolina but when i called them they
said that the uh
that the ship distribution center a lot
of the people called kobe so they closed
the facility
so that's why it was still sitting there
so they said they were going to uh they
said they were in the process of getting
people to go to the facility to pick up
all the packages because you know it's a
there's a lot of packages there
and uh they were gonna um ship them out
all right
that's the case here yeah that's cute
for a story let's start
i thought that had something to do with
the rain like there's gonna be an ending
or something like circle yeah there is a
circle
circle i'm over here with you
jackie he's back here
you gotta okay i'm on it i'm on it
you got him
he's dead
person with the whole hole in them
okay so that's something that's to the
left yeah that's towards frost i'm going
with you i'm going with you take it is
over here take it over here okay we
gotta kill the taken first you got him
gotta kill no i'm not over there yet
every second throw a grenade on it oh
wait we got a switch we gotta switch it
i'm coming with you i'm coming with you
take it down
okay i'm in doors open
i'm coming
down
i'm covering
okay
any call-ups
all right it is
taken
the taken symbol like the i don't know
it's like a black thing with
with like a miss
he has stuff in his hand each hand you
gotta say top middle bottom
okay
the witness middle
the uh
the the taken thing in the middle and uh
unstoppable on me
something unstoppable over here i killed
the taken though damn these stupid
[ __ ] ads
yeah the ads are crazy
you just keep getting in my way of the
guy trying to shoot
i got the unstoppable
oh
[ __ ] i'm down
get me 14. those little guys ain't doing
nothing i can't get you i already picked
the wheel
i can come get you
we're still missing one
i'm gonna look for the symbol that i
called out
that's the raid symbol in his left hand
he's holding it like a stick i called it
out but i mean
dude
there's like one down here too just so
you guys know this one
see this one no we were talking about
the pillars yeah and there was
all the taken wasn't killed either
because all my pill one of our pillars
was still slipping
yeah yeah so when the runners go in and
they kill the two um
glyph keepers or whatever they're called
another symbol
another taken spawns and then they get
two symbols that they call out whichever
side like say if it's um the one that we
just did triangle side with the hole
through is harder whatever
the symbols will be on the spires on the
right side
all right i'm starting it
okay
sorry for us continue staying no you're
good you're good you're good don't even
worry about it
you just don't worry about it well we're
really repeating the same game i feel
like we we we we need to
to do this skin more consistent
because i can't interrupt people when
they're in the middle of a thought
though that's the only thing let them
finish their thought then start
okay i'm sorry but otherwise they're
gonna yeah they're gonna feel like
they're not being
their
all right go look i'm going to listen
over here
back up circle
no he's got a triangle
yeah he's in the back what the [ __ ] is
killer
i got you come down got him he's dead
the only thing about not having stasis
whatever
okay um
it's um praying guys
all right i got it i'm going
okay i'm gonna go over to you 14 and
help you
actually you one more daddy there's
another one circle i think
i got the one i got the one on my side
yeah i got him okay
guy with a hole in his heart okay um guy
with a hole in this heart and there's a
console left side
oryx middle
oh
the scarabs over there
oryx middle yeah i'm gonna wait for
someone to come over the left side with
me to go in to do damage though i have a
disciple holding the rates come get me
so happy um
chips great triangle [ __ ] stoppables
down and stop those down oh just white
just white
yeah that might be a they'll be they're
they're always gonna be like two guys
who need to kind of
like i'm wondering if it's better to
have two groups of three rather than
three groups and two okay okay okay
yeah
i was thinking that one [ __ ] thing on
that side how about this
and then you let me just bounce this off
you guys we have
only two people because if you notice
when you go into these rooms there's two
of them i think they
they plan on you doing too
because there's two fire people so i
think we should have two designated
floaters and we have someone on every
platform we have one third person
helping whoever needs help
in
how do you guys feel about that
because i don't think what
me and forte are clear in the room just
fine don't you agree forte i don't think
we need a third person right okay so i
don't need to so you want me to float
between left
float between whoever needs help
especially
the only time you're really going to do
something is if so if someone needs help
with like getting buying on ads you
really need to help people with the with
the over charge like them like
if someone calls it you need to go help
them frosty
actually your best spot is to hang out
by this because then you can also
control the doors you can see what's
going on with cog
i think he needs to hang out in the
middle because there's literally a
pathway yeah because he could swap the
doors as well and then just run yeah
that that's your job you guys can tell
me to swap from left to right just call
it out say swap i'll swap it and then
cognito if you need help or yeah
obviously if you need help or whoever's
on right i think this is gonna be better
consistently and for same let's see
sorry are you finishing
i'm going to say just say you know right
left cog is left obviously i'm right and
will is uh in the back so just say right
left back yeah okay yeah
let's do it
let's do it come on
i have unstoppable stuff as well so
okay i finally oh yeah i got my stop
more
so just keep uh
keep me updated for town where we're
going
okay
i'm gonna help you talking to
disturbance yeah
thank you
you're welcome i'm gonna help uh me and
forte would just run around and help
people that need it because we're not
going to be at any platform
i see to take it
nice that's nice because it's an early
taking how did i die it might well it's
fine it's fine just get up
happening here
circle again
okay do you guys need the door open on
circle side or no
all right
not yet
all right there's no symbols um front
left so all right wait uh the thing uh
the
the
oh man the like the red circle thing in
the middle was something going through
it
we'll call it like
knife
knife in the heart knife in the heart
i'm down just stay there sin i'm going
there sin stay there
is the door open or no
yeah it's open
i'm down i got a third symbol now it's
the um
the pinwheel
that means it's complete that means it's
complete look at your pillar
pay attention to your capillary and uh
your ads
all right symbol is
the
god damn what do we call this [ __ ] i got
the three eyes i got the three circular
eyes i got the purple red orange and
blue uh squiggly thing i i don't know
there's a taken somewhere on left side
is it on top championship it's in the
middle i mean it's in the middle
they're both in the middle all right so
tell us the next one
i do not have a rest for will
sorry i already got him once
i'm down it's around thank you
something about osteos they're not
the three symbols that appear on your
totem uh what do they correspond when we
tell you and if it matches what we're
telling you you shoot it so for instance
we say oryx middle and you have oryx in
the middle you shoot it
okay
anywhere in the middle
as long as it's in the middle
all right it doesn't matter if it's
top don't shoot it
okay
but if it's in anywhere in the middle on
any side
we got to take it on triangles oh yeah
we're about to fight with you yeah it's
all right
yeah taken's been on triangle for quite
a bit man i went to go look for it
because i think what it is
is i
i think what it is is
the three on each side they're all lit
up after the whole encounter and we're
only doing three at a time let me use
the bathroom real quick
this is a fun encounter though
oh you went to the tower i got so many
prime metagrams on me this is ridiculous
i feel like me and you need to stay in
the middle and help everybody
and while we wait for doors to open
yes they were your original group and
then
[Music]
yeah i got a bunch of them too
hello
hello
i'm loving this afternoon because
it is just killing groups
yeah so i don't think me just standing
in the middle right there is any good
i'm gonna stay on left with um cognito
and then when you guys need to change if
the door's not open let me know i'll
turn around and i'll shoot it to open it
okay
i mean i can still float but
nothing just end
look like a butterfly sting like a bee
the reason i said that me and forte
should probably float in the middle is
because it's hard for us to come
together and run to each side but if
we're in the middle helping people we'll
be able to get to each side he's quicker
if that makes sense
because i'll be on like the left and
it'll be our right one and it takes us a
couple seconds to go all the way to the
right but if we're in the middle helping
each side we can just go straight to
whatever side we need to go to
all right is every oh yes
oh i got i just got assists of
subsistence and frizzy to drop from an
engram
for what weapon
uh
from the weaver
okay
two seconds
i know we haven't made it very far but
i'm definitely not disappointed
yeah me too i'm happy
well we're only one encounter behind
everybody that datto with them is at the
neck at the counter after this and glad
them just got past it
basically them just got past this
just got past this just now
don't go so we're only like yeah one
encounter behind what are we kind of
behind
it
yeah that's all
and i'm i'm definitely a little
going through an adjustment period with
5.0 over here until i figure it out
and be vocal when you have an
unstoppable it like like frost will come
over there and help you it the least he
can do is at least like disable it
yeah i was doing that last time man yeah
he did that
but sometimes he's in on duty with
looking for stuff so i got i have to
have like the glaive or some other stuff
and i'm debating
any more i'm not running into oh okay
and um
so you can take off your stuff you can
just you can just
can't really
oh you can't riley yeah you've got
that's all right
it's beef
remember forte stay close to the middle
so we can get to the side we need to
we're ready for 25.
b2 b2 too warlocks are going through it
right now
to take it up though
the titan rolls right now yeah what
weapon you use the screen so i know what
you're going through so circle it's all
circular i was using a glaive
is a difference
all right he's down this is like devours
never proclaiming all right holding the
heart holding the heart
pulling the heart pulling the heart
outside right
right right
holding the heart and oh no hold yeah
you're right you're right oh there's a
take it over here take it over here
all right i'm going all right addict's
already down there forte if you want to
go down with him no i'm going
bacon's down
oh i'm getting rekt
okay unstoppables up top here
yeah just just white just white
yeah right
well you said through the heart i was
thinking the triangle dude yeah yeah i
just think it's knife through the heart
person
i was at the other one
i should probably kill myself eh
yeah let me wipe out
and i'll what you call it um
scream
yeah do you have anything else for
unstoppable besides glaze
uh yeah that's what you're using as
you're okay
hey sinister don't you love studying
something and it doesn't stun
you saw that right you're watching me
he just looked at me and slammed the
ground like you didn't stun me i don't
know what you're talking about
[Music]
it made the noise and it was like nope
[ __ ] you
yeah because what you could do screen
i don't know if you want to well i'll
try it i'm actually going to try it now
and see if it works i would switch well
i suggest it i'm going to switch yep
how do you switch the unstoppable pulse
from a distance
i'm switching a stable point you really
don't have to aim the glaze just point
it in the direction of the no i do i'm
just talking about like i don't know i
just feel like for devour for whatever
for locks are there it's taking a minute
to proc it's harder for us to stay alive
for some reason
like normally like i would i'm gonna do
shots
like we'll figure it out it does feel
like they nerfed oh no man
what's the grenade that gives you
suppressor from you consuming what is
that
there is that
no they used to be able to consume a
grenade to get devour
you got to have them both separately now
if you do the
the consumer grenade that does not proc
devour devour is feed the void it's its
own separate thing trust me it's that's
the adjustment for me you gotta can't
consume the grenade or if you put both
of those you gotta have devour and
consume the grenade and then you gotta
take off childhood the old gods it's
about not an hour and a half and i don't
want i don't want if i was too important
you have to have it
because you need to proc that health
regen off of every void kill you put
down your rift which out of the old gods
and then you um throw out your melee and
then um what exactly
the first thing you shoot at the first
thing you shoot up the the little ball
flies out to them
yeah not only that but with your melee
if you get a bunch of kills it'll proc
devour and then there's a aspect or
something that or i think that's how
it's fragmented so question
whatever kill you get it just resets
when what's the question
is like when we do get the middle
top and bottom on all three are they all
the same one
or they're different on every one
like friends if the middle one's holding
the heart is all three of them holding
heart
that's middle
when you kill the the guys inside and
you do the call out there's three
bubbles and one of the bubbles is
actually a symbol
when you kill those
those strong ass dudes inside one of the
areas yeah i know that i know that
that's not what i'm debating i'm
debating on how many of these rooms do
we have to go through
just three or three because
it's three three and three so nine
nine possibilities
and one on each three sides
so it looks like we gotta just
do it three times
there's three times
yeah
three whole successions we've only been
able to complete one
we don't know we started the second one
well yeah it started but we didn't
complete it once once we kill all three
of those uh unstoppables i think that's
when the second one starts that's when
you the next taken needs to get
the [ __ ] out of there okay you guys
ready
yeah i'm ready language sorry you're
good
well you're not moving okay there we go
scaring me there man scaring me
right oh front right okay yeah i see
okay i got you
he's dead
below
the door's not open oh switch switch
is it taken over here
all right i clicked the door to change
the door
[ __ ] dying i'm an anova bomb
i'm a nova yeah he's down lord i think
you're in the wrong room man oh my god
right side someone said holding the
heart
no i said it's staggering
[Music]
that's holding the chest
dagger in the heart all right i have
they're both down i have uh tear drop
tear drop in mid snake i have a surface
yellow uh surfing in the middle
then i got the
like the picture of the earth picture of
the earth
okay
nothing like that is on our um open up
the door open up the door open up the
door so i can get out
got you thank you
yep unstoppable's
dead okay remember it's teardrop it's
green and red i don't know where that
symbol is take it take it take it
where it what's what is it triangle
triangle
teardrop
it's green and red
green and red
middle
anybody
all right we got the hands out with the
triangle in the middle
yep yeah i see it i see it open the door
switch
switch okay
switched
right out huh
yeah
okay
or no
i'm leaving i don't think so well not
right now i think that's what caused the
fail because it wasn't full up on my
side be careful was it for a long time
we getting somewhere though like we're
really getting somewhere
we was in the second rotation that time
sword is lit
that's really sword
all right you guys ready
wrapping the banner
tell me what everyone's got it
i got it i'm ready right in position
sorry about anything
oh you're good
[Music]
all right i'm looking
all right he's not oh he's not over here
next to me and see it
see over there
yeah i got him yeah yeah got him
okay brain brain
go to brown it's on the left side front
all right
i'm switching doors open doors open
all right
um they're still taken on the right side
as well
circle
yeah yep circle yeah
um
compass it's uh rainbow compass that is
my last symbol on my pillar did we get
that last um
is it taken is it taking y'all taken
middle both middle ah i died to burn
okay what are those
run timmy frosty rust in front run to
the right
come get me
i do not have a roast i got him i got
him cognito okay
i don't i don't know the symbol or they
might not be on marvin i don't see
what's happening
okay well i have an inkblot middle here
but i'm shooting prayer i'm not doing
anything
you just gotta shoot it once
that's what addiction circle okay
right side
you got another one a circle taking
circles
he's going for it he's going for it
okay really good baby
i don't know where that symbol is but
that's
dagger dagger
heart in the dagger okay
there's a taken somewhere there was a
ticket somewhere right no the officers
filled up this full yeah
all right so when people are making call
outs after they go into the doors i i
don't know how we can do it but we need
to keep comms clear because i had no
clue
of where he is
i mean i got the inkblot but i don't
even know if it did anything because i
shot it like 20 times and then shot it i
i still don't still trying to figure out
how it does i think i have to shoot it
to be honest with you guys i think
people are going to have to go in these
rooms by themselves and clear it
because i feel like we're not doing it
fast enough because we don't like every
i think this is how it goes i think
i
i'm supposed to look at here see okay we
going to this i go into it i say what it
is out here and the person out here does
it but the problem is is me and forte
are doing stuff so we don't no one knows
what to click because it's not the right
platform
oh uh hold on a second okay can i just
bring something in real quick i don't
know if it's going to be relevant so you
know how that's at the start actually
never mind it doesn't even make sense
man i was going to say maybe we only
have to protect one obelisk
you know the one where the symbols
initially pop up at and yeah maybe that
one is that the only one that's filling
up it might be true no i think they're
all filling up they're all filling up
okay they're all
foreign faster that's why we're
defending it
yeah right yeah
so i mean look thinking maybe if there
was just one obelisk that we had to
defend then we could branch out from
there and do it a little easier but it
doesn't really make sense i think we're
just let's do it again this time but
we'll do one pillar at a time forte you
know what i'm saying like the first one
that gets it we do that pillar into that
pill because i think every time we do it
it re resets some of it so i think we'll
be able to get all three of them if it
keeps resetting but we keep going from
one pillar to another we're going from
left to right let's the first one that
has a symbol we do that one first the
only people that talk is me forte and
the person that's doing that pillar
okay
all right let's go
where is where's will
over here
okay cool
dead
okay
symbol's gone okay it's um praying
man praying um all right i'm going
so we do that side from here on oh my
god i got overran
so early
okay it's my fault i'll take it i'm
taking it take it over there
and praying hand taking chips and
praying in
oh i'm down
no like me and you both do it's just we
only do this pillar now
we're all dead
oh we're all there
man
okay
i i think the thing that's getting us
the most caught up is um
we got the call outs for the doors fine
but it's when you go in there and you
get the kills that the call outs on the
obelisk itself that's where
you need a little a little work
i don't i've never seen them anywhere
else but middle have you ever seen them
anywhere else but middle forte have you
ever seen like top in there or bottom
well you know
it's it's different maybe maybe you're
right it could be they're only
yeah so maybe you just shoot it if you
see it that's all you just shoot it if
you see it or maybe you don't do nothing
with that that's just showing you what's
lighting up outside
yeah you remember what's what um
it was top middle and bottom and then it
didn't matter on normal mode which one
in the order you shoot it
maybe it's like that maybe on master
mode
it matters the order but maybe here it
doesn't all right let's try it again
because we did pretty good
come on
all right yeah we keep getting to the
unstoppables and then it's oh yeah
yeah
dude this seems a little chaotic for me
you're good so how about me when you
guys are done
all right man
okay you want less chaotic
yep
okay
he's down
uh door door with the green uh green uh
doorway
i don't even know where that is yeah if
i see it i see it
is the door open or do you need a switch
it's open it's open
okay
taking that sky with the shield man they
don't die
yeah the shield guys are the pitch sword
for them
that's what i know if you shoot them in
there it's not this yeah it should have
been this room is another one they could
have made these symbols a lot
that's working for me i'll tell you
something i keep dying in my well that's
what's annoying yeah the well ain't
working bro i'm telling you right now
what what what's your loadout what are
you using i mean oh my god
it's everyone
yeah i would say sword sword sword
holder sword all day i'm telling you
right now
i'm dying i'm dying i'm not dying from
the edge i'm dying from like burn damage
but the heads like that cause you're
you're staying in the rift right
they'll kill you in the rift like the
referee i've noticed trust me the way we
used to play normally play as a warlock
with the what riff it ain't working you
can kill them so quick with that sword
with this sword just move around and go
hunt them with the sword all right
so from now on i'll run to you and res
you i just won't have a rez token for
cockpit oh no just someone else i was
there
go help him because anybody could be
better
yes
just so we can keep it going
and not fail so fast yeah now i feel so
fast i got you
i got you just let me know if you need
to res maybe remind me okay you guys
ready [ __ ] you know
now you're good
the only thing i'll need for you for us
is everything if the um
[Music]
it works
because i use the glaive and the sword
yeah it's way better
because i have a guardroll glaive so i
get my health every time i kill one of
them
triangle triangle
all right i think they should take it
out for us i think he's gonna go get us
out front
yeah i got him dude don't worry about it
bacon's down
cool
sinister do you need help with your ads
no
okay let me know if you need help
we'll help him all right it's the one
that we did last time forte that was
wrong
sorry
he threw that burn
all right it's still triangles so
they're still taken on triangle
i'll go right you go live
oh my god taking [ __ ]
i don't have neither it's not right now
okay there's praying man on my obelisk
right now praying man on my obelisk
right now
i have circle
triangles
okay so
i'm praying then
people just gonna man like the biggest
issue
like if you gotta pop your super to live
then do it
because i think that we keep losing like
a corner or something because someone
dies
you know what i got my super to take out
a taken dude because he dodged me hold
up hold up hold up hold up hold up
what's up
we
we're not activating the glyph you know
how you activate the glitch i think you
shoot it but i don't know
nope come here what what you doing hold
on let me go to 14.
so
remember this room over here that we
have to go into
that's up here that nobody goes into at
all
the symbol
yes in this room
these two symbols always show up at the
where where is it at when you're done i
think that's right recently they pop up
after we started yeah
yeah there's a those symbols where where
are those symbols out of here there's it
was a symbol where's the symbol with the
is all the circle in the rainbow circle
yeah
where is those symbols at
they're inside
is it inside this one
i i personally feel like
i think that just says complete when you
get the rainbow circle no but we're not
we're not completing it because we're
not activating that glyph
um
we have not once been glyph activated
yeah we have not activated the glyph yet
so
that bottom one turned into that rainbow
circle
what do we have to do when we get to
that point do we have to go
to that glyph and shoot it inside that
door
i like start it up start it up and see
if you can go in that room and if that
gear yeah okay it doesn't damage or not
uh i personally feel like this door
like these because this they because
this thing this kind of room was
like farther back i think they indicate
something like you get all them together
and you do something with them like in
the raid i don't think this has anything
to do with the encounters
well about to see
because because there's one that's um at
the beginning remember so like to me
right there shows that like we can't go
back to that room so i don't feel like
they're part of it you know what i'm
saying
what loadout
yeah well that's just it devourers never
practice
okay and what weapons are you using you
said the same which weapons are those
sword
triangles
anyway don't worry about it taking no
i'm saying i'm gonna tell you a trick
i'm gonna tell you that's what i'll ask
you if you have a voice
man
you can proc devour
right after the kill
to keep it going if you if you initiated
the um
the devour drain
you don't have other half i thought you
was using guillotine
for flying guillotine the old one
do you want me to switch with them you
go on the rings well
yeah maybe because we got we got to keep
will alive too
don't worry we got to keep it i'll say
that okay
okay because i know what you mean with
that void damage i know what you mean
i'm just proc trying to proc the vowel
as much as possible use the voice or
just run around the voiceover some
reason
chaos accelerant isn't working either
yeah
oh okay that's what i tell you so what
you do go to you want to switch
you want the pillow i'm gonna try all
right so you need it
no you're in your void
all right so you got the one that you
want is chaos accelerant
and then if you're not using child of
the old gods take childhood old god off
and put feed the voice so you want feed
the void and and what you call it chaos
accelerate at the top two aspects
yeah it's not working that's what i'm
saying for some reason it won't let me
overcharge no matter how it doesn't let
me
hold down let me charge it no
are you using um the what you call it
are you using the uh controvers hold
exotic the arms
uh nope
put that on
why would i why shouldn't i be able to
do that just for the aspect
paired with it
you should but that's how i got it to
work
right because i know what you i know
what you're trying to do if that's not
working then use controversial which is
literally built for it could be a glitch
just put on controversy
all right everyone ready
yeah yeah all right
all right somebody said no let's wait
okay he's out of this stuff no i think
all right you good
mm-hmm
all right
there's a wall for you
triangle
triangle okay i'm looking
i do not see him in the front here he's
a mid he's a med
i'm gonna go try and get him
okay he's dead
the cup with two hands
circle what is it triangle with two
hands
yeah they're cut with two hands
that's over here on the back side
is the door open
oh yeah door's open
okay
okay so the taken spawns regardless
right
i i think it does i think trust yeah so
when you see your stuff frosty that's
all you're gonna do if they say circle
you run to the right side and you look
for the taken if you hear a triangle run
to the left side
search that whole [ __ ]
okay
like i said i'm here whatever you guys
want me to do i'll do
good yeah you're good bro
you're on your own now no i'm good i'm
better now i'm better i'm much better
now scream what i'm doing so you know is
when the first mobs kind of spawn out
i'm throwing a grenade or the melee to
just proc the vowel and i'm just killing
them with the sword and i'm keeping the
vawa proc do you have the the aspect
that keeps that left the vowel lasts
like 12 13 seconds
that's what you want
that's the one um you want the voice
yeah i think it's that i think it's that
hold on oh no i don't know what it's
called
you want well which ones are you using i
will tell you right now all right so i'm
using echo
of explosion
echo of undermining the weeknd
echo here it is you would echo of
persistence
void applied to you it increased because
what's going to happen is instead of
that
i think we're using the same thing i
think okay same thing equal persistence
yeah once you proc that device going to
be like 12 seconds instead of like eight
or seven or whatever so this way just
keep killing with a void sword
because the sword's gonna get them out
of there quick and then you're gonna
proc it back up to 12 and you're gonna
keep healing keep healing keep healing
see if there's any weight resist i can
put on
yeah any orange guy
sword
i don't even play around with him
are you guys ready yeah i'm ready and
then glaive
that one yellow foreign it's that one
yellow ball that throws that one
that one
if you run down on him with sword
with the ball proc you're gonna be lit
yeah the biggest thing is uh we
then i die
[Laughter]
frost no don't get him frost let me get
him don't get him the biggest problem is
devourer is not okay
because he's taken on the right side
using
[Music]
issues
we just figured out the technical issues
yeah so what like the male any any of
the mobs i usually throw the melee ball
or the grenade to suck them in and then
you proc it for the dudes with the
shields don't waste the grenade just
sword them because they're ridiculous
i'm gonna switch to a sniper to shoot
the uh taking guys from a decent
distance if i'm far away so that i don't
have to waste time running to them
okay
yeah
because that's impressive
that's probably why what you call it
wasn't rocket for you squeeze because
you had the suppressor grenade
yeah you guys ready
yeah that's probably what it was that's
that's yeah that's what it was
starting it
all right let's rap
and now i have the power
yeah you go
yeah once we get divided
devour
resist volatile rounds
circle
do you all see the taking guy anywhere
i'll see you
he's over here
okay so he's still gonna be on circle i
believe i think it's two times on circle
he's on triangle now
he's on triangle okay i see him
yeah so me doing this doesn't really
make sense man because by the time i get
there you guys have oh
killed him ross come back
so that's
front right
um anybody see him triangle
well i think i hit tycho take it yeah if
he's in the background he's in the back
oh [ __ ]
hands praying and i didn't have my sword
oh [ __ ] it up i'm [ __ ] up this is on
me now
i'm [ __ ] way down on this side i'm
[ __ ] up
yep we got it
they could have named these these they
could have
drew these pictures a little bit easier
to communicate with other people i got
to say like squiggly lines
well no that's part of the that's part
of it that's why they do that they do it
on purpose wiggly lines of colors like
man praying a triangle man praying
that's how they do
brain's there
child is praying
it's the pillar ones the ones you don't
see all the time
the heart in the hole okay
nope that's dagger through heart
the heart i i i just say to them only so
hold through chest is left it's over
there on the right and dagger through
heart is is right yeah
okay you guys ready all the other ones
are pretty out in the open i'm just
gonna try and stay on the left side as
much as i can sin if you go down i'll go
over to you but everyone's taking out
the taken before i even get there so
there's just no bag doing that yeah i'm
trying to do extra kind of costing me
here and there
you guys ready
yeah i'm ready
why do rapes have to be so [ __ ] beefy
dude
oh yeah and now they do
circle
wow i thought i had
come get me well it's dead
damn dude jesus come back
either
you got arrested
brain
all right so that's that's front left
front left
and the door isn't open it is now
i don't have a wrist token for wilhelm i
think i have one i'll go i'll go get him
i'll go get him
i was already on my way
oh sorry i'll go back
all right i'm taking up your spot for
the second
ensemble's out all right squiggly line
and tower and tower tower looks like
taken's gonna be right side
hundred eight he's
what's the next one
circle
yep i'm going for the taking right now
man
okay taking step right side
what's the symbol
wait for the square square square the
middle
gotta kill those taken quicker
it's not the take and i don't think we
still haven't activated a glyph yet
i think you have to do a whole set
before you can activate glyphs
there was one time where i was able to
shoot one and it go in and it glowed it
lit up but ever since then i still ain't
been able to do it i think you have to
do all three of them before you can do
it because if you notice
you have to activate all three pillars
and we have we've we've done that a
couple of times but we haven't done it
in the last couple years
because we have to kill those taken
quicker
it seems like when we clear a room when
me and forte clears a room it puts that
that timer down
but we have to get we pretty much have
to leave a room and go straight to
another room
all right let's go
they don't got time to handle the taking
that's the hand of the frosty to do it
okay i just got we just got to do better
staying alive me and scream
[Music]
i'm in this struggle too
this defending ain't no joke
yeah defend is real gotta be
it's no joke
front right
scream exceed the limits front right
taking zed
if i call out where the taking is and
someone can see it it would be a
pleasure if you'd help me maybe yeah
just gotta know where nobody called it
he's right here
yeah i'm going for it
go to another one
switch switch
oh we got a switch taken
i got him
you got him yeah i got him
i know i said it was rare i got pretty
hands i got pretty hands
um
hot on the head
hold on somehow on the head jesus christ
hold on head okay brain is switched
[Music]
all right got um
the red green and red uh
white
[Applause]
good [ __ ] frost i see that
switch switch switch
that was good
that was a switch
i can't switch it
no i'm already out
frost pick me up somebody got picked me
up i don't know if you can for us i got
him i got him i got 14 just worry about
those unstoppables
that unstoppable is dead
all right we're getting spooky about me
jacob's on circle son yep
okay the uh okay you're already in it
yep squiggly lines and um tower in the
tower looks like
looks like the tower
all right
say another one circle
oh this is my second brain brain
something better you're doing something
brain we got the unstoppable back here
spooky for a second
i'll get left you get right
thank you
over here
all right
ships and
uh ships in person with his arms down
where's the taking out
he's a ship
yeah ships and person with his arms down
oh yes see i activated it oh something
just happened
it rejects yourself now it says
what is that rejection reject your
offering so that okay
okay
holding chest
in the
middle oryx in the middle orrick's in
the middle yes
in the middle of that it's not a
different one i got it oh it's a
different one it's going on mine
it's really correct
shoot it mines is lower than you as well
what's going on
oh something popped up but i couldn't
see it because he died i shot works in
mid though on mine
do we have to do we have to all shoot
them at the same time on the different
ones
i don't know
i don't know it works on bottom and it
accepted it
yeah somebody's offering got rejected
that was different it's cool though we
made progress we need to know what to
now we got to figure out well let's get
back to it and then let's let's let's
experiment
i think it will be
i i want to say like it's
uh um
maybe like
wherever oryx is on your totem shoot him
all right we'll be a lot more vocal this
time just make sure you look at your
totem the totem's the thing that counts
down
because now uh
people aren't dying so we're actually
getting someone they had that warlock
[ __ ] figured out
that's why titans is the best
but you could defend i'll run around
yeah
i was defending i was defending
not like this now foreign
there's gonna be another one popping up
still on circle side
um
in the back back right diamond what
diamond what
i it's i don't know it's diamond with a
pier or uh trying oh i said i don't know
it's the green and white one right
that's right yeah
yeah yeah okay
i know did you guys end up getting the
taken or not
oh my god that's such a small room
i got screwed in that room
there uh
somewhere on the circle
we have to be there together forte like
well that one i couldn't it's not on
circle
yeah then
that wasn't the problem i can watch
front sides i can i can help you out
frosty though the problem with the taken
spawns are that it shows up on one
and then it changes to another one
you know what i think the same side or
the other side so if i it could say i
could look at the left um totem the
whole time and it could say you know
left side or triangle but they're
actually spawning on circles
you know what i think we should do i
think we should assign people just to
look out for the taken like everyone
gets like two taken that you just
periodically look and see if they're
there
that way that way
i've been like from here i can kind of
look this side and this side
and then
um
i move to the back so either one of
those i
i feel like the non-runners just picked
two spots to to look for you don't
necessarily have to kill it i mean if
you could kill it kill it but just so we
know where they're at
yeah i've been always
taken spot to take it for me is another
issue all right you guys ready i've
always hit him
wait hold up oh i just started at the
moment i you said that i struggled i'm
sorry i'm i'm still full i still got
everything
damn
damn devour like do something
[Music]
taken should be spawning
i don't see him in the front i don't see
him either
i don't see him either
circle
okay so he's on the right side he's
probably in bed
nope he's not injured
he's not up front
it's really in the back here
yeah i think i see him there yeah i see
him yeah i see him all right cool
all right he's dead he's dead he's dead
i gotta hurry up again
what's the room
square square it's the big one in the
middle
running
red square
yeah it's the it's that big one in the
middle in the well i'm not jesus christ
i'm going to it i'm going to
oh it's alright
it's definitely
yeah
it's not saving [ __ ] the cool thing is
once you go into a room and you kill the
uh two it goes down
it resets it
attic for this side of the room
um
if you want to actually like because
because you can kind of slay that whole
set left side of adds from the back side
if you want to stay back there and just
look for that one if he spawns yeah then
that's fine
out here and then you could it'll just i
think it'll be probably yeah i'll chill
there and if it pops i'll i'll get them
yeah perfect
let me grab this and then just tell me
if you need anything and i can just
always look down and help
yeah that's perfect
all right let's go
so
all right
he's not one of these sides is he back
there
no i didn't see him back then he got
you're good you're good
okay the taken is left side now
all right search for it
i'm looking uh it's in the back
it's in the back left side
protective side
yes
unstoppable squiggly line and tower
all right let's get them all and then we
have to go back through them again
triangle triangle
i got him i got him i got the
i got stoppable here too i'll get him
pray praying uh praying hands all right
i got it
that's almost dead
no the other praying hands not that one
i got another uh which phrase oh yeah
you talk about the one in the front yeah
by the front entrance
he put these scarabs in here on that
purpose
i do not see it taken anywhere um okay
uh we have rainbow or not rainbow shirt
oh [ __ ] uh
[ __ ]
yeah sorry about that that's cool it's
good it's cool that good question out
must be doing good in the second round
of unstoppables
yeah
it's the compass just without uh
all right it's back here by me
looks like i got something back here i
don't know what it is no maybe not all
right after this one forte then we're go
uh i think that's when the uh
the one that does where you have to
choose
all right now obvious waits for your
offering okay we're over here
we have uh
[ __ ] what we have this
snake
did we have the witch queen
snake and witch queen
okay rejected so look for that on your
obelisk it's not on ours it's not
right there in the middle
i got witch queen on top
snake on bottom like that
what's the top row for everybody which
uh
which queen and snake which queen which
queen and snake which queen there's
three rows
[ __ ]
shoot okay i'll keep resetting it
which all right all right all right the
moment we got to shoot okay that's the
moment right
yeah we got to shoot it when it says it
wants your offering i think we need
to get the ones that's on the middle
there's a reason there's three there
there's probably multiple times we do
this and they switch them like
wait look for the one that's on the
middle because if you look at it there's
six
and there's
no there's only three i don't know man
this is weird like
there's three sets of them there's three
sets of them you suppose maybe you only
click if it's in the middle there's one
from every room that's in the middle
supposed to i think you're supposed to
remember what the first three are all of
them together and then you're supposed
to um
and then
it just depends does it go up or down or
left like does it go up to the top or
down to the bottom
it did because there's a reason that
they give you because those first two
don't even do anything until you get to
that phase
okay
so
like when we so is anybody like taking
note of the ones that we read out the
first time
i can do that but when i when i shot the
uh which spring symbol last
yeah it was in the middle
and it didn't work
it lit up all three of them not just the
one symbol it lit up all three of them
on that one side when i shot them
so it might just be the first three that
you do call out all right we'll let what
we'll do is we'll go back to the rooms
because it it seems like they give us
plenty of time we just gotta test it
like we gotta test it yeah it feels
great and we shoot something i think we
shoot a symbol
you do
it's just like the campaign you gotta
it's like one of these yeah like the
other all right
yeah the theme of that okay you have to
shoot the ones that are not the ones
that look like the other that's why if
you look at the pillars there's three on
each row so which if every pillar has
those you want to shoot the one that's
not like the other pillar right like
because when you yeah because when you
activate it it activates all the pillars
together
all right and then one pillar will have
different symbols on different symbols
entirely or like entirely they're all
different they're all different but some
will have them like have a different
rotation of the symbols on the top row
some will have them on
look at all nine symbols
yes
let's right now let's get back there uh
because we're getting into it
consistently let's just play around
let's get to it and then just [ __ ]
around and see what it is
but it does look like it gives us time
to actually decide what when we click
whatever so let's offering things it
gives us time by the time so what second
um unstoppable comes out it definitely
gives us time okay how about this the
people that's guarding the moment that
that starts go to whatever it says okay
is there any ad spawning at that time
a lot after this after it adds all the
[ __ ] time but after the second
unstoppable it felt like there was time
and that's when you started okay guess
what symbols and then you said that the
offering was rejected then what we'll do
is the people at every pillar that are
guarding go to the pillar that is there
and then you tell us what it is and
we'll try to shoot the ones that's not
there
okay we just we got to kind of call out
what we see once we get to that period
yeah we just we got to mess around like
because clearly
you know we
we know we we're getting to that point
we just got to figure out the mechanic
to finish that
because they because if you look at it
it is weird that it's a top and bottom
and middle in there so i do think that
has something to do with it
i just think that the first one they're
making it easy on us and they're making
them all the middle
what is the thing sir
nothing not online
nothing yet
[Music]
[Music]
triangle
it's still on the triangle side
yeah look for another taken
i am
it's in the front right here i'll grab
it
i love how he says he grabs it like it's
something he picks up when he's actually
killed
upside down
where's that at
upside down it's right right here in the
mirror
change change the floor
change it yes yeah it changed it got it
and that's first time seeing that one
yeah so that wasn't the taken problem
all right so forte i think what what's
best at that beginning that we designate
ourselves was taken cause i feel like
the moment we go out we go straight back
to that taken that would designate that
way
because they they can't they can't
defend and look for the takeaway
i'm the one that's looking for the
taking on my side i always all right
then i'll i'll look at these back ones
and the uh the back side too
because i'm sitting here but i don't
maybe it's just i i keep the one that he
keeps being here doesn't spawn that
often so that's why i feel like i'm not
doing anything
yeah they definitely change up the spawn
points
yeah always
i always look though i'm always looking
for all right well on the left you can
get the one in the back and one in the
middle and i'll get the two on the front
up here
in the form of taking
it
so the one on the left where you usually
do it but then in this little uh thing
right here
this little building
that pops up at the back so you should
be able to see him
anyway
i gotta take it in front okay in the
back on the bottom or the top
he's on the top
okay
all
all
right
hands hands down
triangle with hands down
take it in the back on the
blue circular side i think i should get
him
i got him
we just got to go in there kill it so we
can reset this
yep
oh man when i'm unstoppable drop
always yell them out
yep i'm looking
all right killed mine
ritual concludes somebody missed
something no we just took too long that
was all me and forte we got because
sometimes they'll pick one that we don't
go in too much and we have to look for
it
yeah i know where it is now but it's
like i i only wanted that one one time
before
but we're starting to get the majority
of them like i know the hearts on the
left side the hole in the chest is on
the right all the time
[Music]
all right
tell me when you guys are right i think
you should i think because you're
sharing kills with uh
someone's
that's why your number's lower
i'll just nova bomb them get them out of
there
well that's going to kill them but you
got it
so
holding chests
there you guys go doors should be open
i
because he pops out i'm doing a lot of
ads here
taking care of
just
there he is oh [ __ ]
snake right right side
oh i got killed
stupid it's fine i'll get them i'll get
them i'll get them just go to the next
one stop those down
what's the next one where's the next one
on my orb
does anybody know where the next one was
pillar it's on me
oh uh
upside down um
upside down what's my
um snowfall
got it
no snow cone upside down smoking we keep
saying different call outs
call out the wrong no the snow cone is
the one that looks like it's red it's a
red triangle oh that's in the ground
yeah snow cone upside down
show me which one you're talking about
i thought that's the one that you were
talking about no
i no oh
show them what you call out is what they
say let it take i'm trying to find where
it is
okay
i know what i mean i it was it was a
wheel hills pillar
all right show me which one that is it's
not this one
that's hands
it's right behind you it's right behind
where we spawned
yes
let me see what it is i'm going out too
it's back here it's this one look yeah i
said that one earlier it's a weird spot
for that one wow we've never went to
that one before we never went there
down so cool okay yeah if you look
upside down it's just giving me through
all the symbols just in case i i don't
know
hold on let me see what else should i
call him
this is praying
wait where's our head we call
you want to call this one two man
praying this this is frame
two guys praying there's a dude behind
him too all right so we got that yeah we
call this
what's the next one that one's dagger
and heart
hold on let me see
where y'all call let me see what is that
right
oh dagger heart okay i got that all
right then what's the next one
so i know the names
what is
okay
and that's all and then there's the
whole uh holding the chest oh
and then this one's just right hands
what's what's right here is
okay got it cool all right let's start
this
okay at least i know we're snow cones
upside down
yeah we've never done it we've never did
snow cone before not one time
that's probably what it is our
call outs are a little messed
killed killed the taken
you killed him addict yes i got him
red square red square red square that's
the back
i'm shooting the thing
okay it's open
i can't believe i'm using a glaze and a
sword
let me
do them all and then we'll come back
switch
no never mind never mind don't switch
don't switch
i thought they're both on the left side
yeah
what's the next one
uh red hands right hands right hands
all right i'm all the way there
the topic was dead
i'm working mine on the right
of course did you kill already bubbles i
don't even see him
no they have ours hasn't been popped
okay
uh that was my fault accidentally
i'm getting mud by this fire dude i
stopped those out here give me a second
i'll just leave him
you got him cognito
yeah
just believe the [ __ ] one more we need
to do one more
all right my ensemble's down
okay our bullet or
our tower is done we have the um rainbow
compass running okay
i did i did
wonderful now we getting it man
i'll get right you get left
good [ __ ] for us all right
what's up sam what's up i'm getting
weird
okay i'm gonna say i had time all right
let's stay here
oh damn get me get me get me get me
all right go back i'll go to the other
one
we have to go to go to your uh things
reject the offering
somebody shoot it somebody knows
something hands no one shot it
it was both hands
all right
i got
i got ships middle and uh snake the red
snake
shoot it
score middle
score in the middle shooting scoring
middle i
just move around it oh okay so you just
but which should we just focus on do we
have to focus on all three like all
three rows yes one one road one row i
think the middle row pardon me
all right so doing the roll well i mean
how how what i want to know is like
how can we call that out without over
talking one another
letting each other know
so i think
i think what we need to do is
when we get that when we go into the
third one
you guys need to go to because like when
we go into that third one what you need
to do is
me and him will split i don't know
because we need we got to get to the to
the things quicker than we're getting
what i'm curious about is is there one
symbol
on each like one symbol like in the
middle section
or once just one symbol in general where
if it's not all in the same place for
all three we can meet that'll
immediately tell us that that's the one
you know like i feel like there's
something like that where one symbol
will there's one symbol that if it's not
like like
for example or i know what you're saying
if oryx middle isn't on all three in the
middle like it'll probably i bet it'll
be on two in the middle and there'll be
one that isn't
so right
he's right i think what it is
you guys out there will read to me and
him can you guys hear me
you guys out there will read to me and
him what's in the middle what three's in
the middle and we'll tell you which
one's not in that room
so for instance if there's oryx and red
snake in in the side room you'll tell us
okay we got origin red snake in here and
you'll hit the one in the middle that's
not those three
that's not those two
mm-hmm
i'm down for trying it
just one second guys sorry no i'm gonna
take a look while you're doing it we got
to figure out a way to get to them
quicker though
take a look
[Music]
so
i think i know what it is
what
is there a chance that it could be
wherever you went
i don't know what you mean you have to
find the pattern of the totem that you
went to
but they they're always random
that's true
i think it's always going to be one of
like every totem is going to be one in
that corresponding area so like
right now let's say this this top area i
feel like it's always either going to be
brain cup
or this one over here um
holding the chest and i think if you're
in one of these
you represent this one if you're on the
one at the bottom you represent that one
if you're at the very bottom you
represent um
prayer
uh
the hands and then uh
the whole uh
square based on the pillar the pillar
one
that calls out where to go
such as random so this is how i think it
is i think that
prayer this one of the upside down cone
and square they're for this pillar so if
you're in this pillar
whatever you say is going to i think
that's what it is all right all right
all right so
are you back forte
yeah all right so this pillar here
i think this pillar it
represents uh red hands upside down
uh cone and it represents um
the uh the prayering hands and whatever
we say in whichever one of those is the
is how you're gonna represent this
pillar
so pretty much like
because i i feel like
we go we're going to one on each side i
don't feel like they're beside each
other
let's do that again let's see where they
are let's do that again is everyone
ready
get can i have a question really quick
yes um
when you guys are running in the doors
do the do the symbols when inside the
doors correspond to the ones that appear
on the totem when they start rotating
like that
see i think what i think it is is
whatever
um
whatever you see when you go in whatever
if there's three is there three um two
there's no there's two
it's good what i think it's there's two
but there's three on the bottom so it's
always the one that's not there and i
think the three pillars they every
pillar's got three
things that designate to that pillar and
whatever one people go
before we get to that point do we have
three people that go in the doors no we
have to figure that out but right now we
have to figure out
in general like we it's pointless
assigning that if we don't know how the
mechanic works once we find the mechanic
then we can assign the people that go in
every time but we got to find that
mechanic first what what i mean okay
so we have like before we even progress
to the point where the
when on the way to progressing to the
point where the pillars start rotating
or the totems start rotating
do we have we have have we been having
three people go into different doors do
we basically do we do like three
different doors or do i just do two and
it that it happens like i i don't really
know what's happening what what
what
is the defense people will go into their
doors like sinister will look in his
middle go into that one you'll look into
your middle go into that one and kyle go
go look at his middle and go into that
one and then whoa out here shoot them
but we got to figure out that mechanic
in there because i i still i think it's
whatever's not there but i don't know
but we have to experiment to figure out
what mechanic it is first
what are we doing i'm back because what
i think it is is that something that the
the symbols that you see
when you go into the door
are going to be that's like your symbol
assigned and then you have to find
the one totem that all three
symbols that everybody's everybody has
gone to the doors sees that has it on
all three on one so do you think we all
have different symbols
i think you all have different symbols
but me and forte we always have the same
symbol we go in there we always have the
same symbol
yeah we always going together
maybe i think what it is is because i
think they're all in the middle for
because there's in there there's there's
three levels but they're always in the
middle i think they do that to make it
easier on us the first go around but i
think there's multiple of these and it's
going to switch it up for the second and
third or fourth time and i think what
it's going to go is like
or let's say in the middle there's an
oryx there uh there's we say two and you
sure to shoot the one that is not the
one we say
what were you gonna say sin
nothing i'm not saying nothing no please
don't do that come on what what what
what's your name
what are you thinking yeah we should be
doing curious yeah i'm curious you got
to get everybody i'm a defender that's
it
nah give me give me what you think stop
it
nothing all we can do is run it just run
it okay you know that's what you believe
just keep running okay i just want to
make sure make sure that you wasn't
thinking about something
are
everyone back good everyone's back
i'm back
who were missing
who are we missing
i'm back
i'm good
and obelisk is under attack
all right i got to take it
i love what you found another one pops
up yeah i love it dude it's great i got
your back
all right tickets down
uh brain
brain you gotta switch it
yeah
couch you guys
thank you
i was to take it over here too
he's gonna get him i'll get him don't
worry about it he's dead he's dead
okay i got um
upside down cone or whatever you guys
called it it's all the way in the back
upside down cone okay
brain is done
thinking in the back uh
what did you see
that's my question
uh brain was
snake and
uh scorn emblem
i don't have that on my pillow yeah i
don't think none of them are going to
spawn until all three of the uh rooms
have been cleared
what's another one we need another
upside down cone
step upside down
oh my god i'm pierce heart you got that
one over there
i'm gonna get the here's hard one
no i don't
you died yeah there's just the i can't
handle everything in here by myself
when it's tight corridors it's a lot
easier but when it's like a really
closed in room
they kill me very easily
that's a small room i haven't been down
there well it's not that it's small it's
huge but there's so much room for them
just to shoot over i can't get to the
other one
you gotta get your numbers up
you say get your numbers i was dead
ninety percent of the time
i had an unstoppable wilder
guy was slapping me in the back of the
head
are you guys ready let's go
yeah we're ready
starting at three it's contest mode two
i think
yep
i think leaving people alone to defend
isn't a smart idea but then
having all the other [ __ ] to do it's
kind of difficult to leave them
which is why i keep trying to run back
and forth and i get caught up and then
the other person on the other side dies
and i'm like all right is that my fault
or what's up
no like everyone's doing what they're
supposed to just sometimes you just
circle
sometimes you just have bad luck
like
yeah i don't know i don't feel like i'm
contributing yeah you know what i got to
realize no you go for it i gotta leave
that fire dude every time
yeah
i just gotta stop taking it
come on this is just white we've had too
many people die
come
real
all a learning experience sooner or
later we'll all have it down to a
science
yeah man as long as my numbers is tough
oh my god
as long as i got the top doubles i'm
doing my thing that's what
but first you're good but i think
to be honest with the floating seem to
be helpful but you feel like you're not
now about i thought you were
well i mean you you are floating so
you're not sitting at a spot constantly
sometimes you're stunning the
unstoppable before i even see it so i
just got to go finish them off so i love
that
i mean if you feel like you're not doing
nothing frost you can always take a spot
sir i can take your spot if you want man
take my spot i want it
what it's like
yeah
yeah they
let me go to sleep let me go to sleep on
the top of the pyramid
[Laughter]
i like to float look at this leader's
[ __ ] boom your left side is done
yes
load it out baby that's what you do you
like hunters like the room they all like
to stay in the house oh i'm a warlock
i've been a warlock this whole time i
didn't know i just put a world like this
over all right sending a weekend grenade
to you circle all right rotating back i
got the title i got the titan i mean not
the titan i got to take it
i'm here i'm here i'm here
holding the chest
switch doors
like that little void explosion frosty
yeah i'm good over here
all right we got unstoppable on the far
left oh stuff well yeah
he is weakened shooting the rocket
now we look for the right one
get me on your way out 410
okay oh there's a there's a ticket
over here is it take it over here
all right we got the unstoppable on the
right coming to help with the taking
take it down i'm going back to my post
all right hatuken you know give you a
little thank you yeah that was all that
we like that we like all that all that
we like hold the hole in chest and what
else
pulling chest
i don't know
anybody get the other taser
switch switch
switch yes switch i did switch
all right forte this is how we're gonna
have to do it we're gonna have to stay
together constantly like because
and we're gonna have to be close to the
middle and just help shoot because we're
taking too long going left to right
because we're on the right and it's on
the way
i mean but you can what you think
i mean if we i mean the thing is okay
that's fine i mean i'm just saying we
you i could clear a room by myself and
just i mean you're using a sword that's
why it's hard for you
but
i mean yeah if you're going to use a
sword then we're going to have to have
two people
i mean i can switch
i mean i'll try the gala what are you
using for today that you're not using a
sword
uh
i'm using cartesian and uh
and um
a
solar rocket launcher i'm using hazel's
vision visions oh you're all using hazen
really okay yeah that's because they're
solar because they're solar so and i got
a ripple and i got i got impulse
amplifier and um
yeah damn
no i mean they don't want to say you
want to give they don't want to give you
eyes of tomorrow so [ __ ] oh yeah all
right you got all right go ahead and
start it
i mean it's a key i'll just try to stick
with you more um just keep running what
you're doing if it's working for you
just let's just
i'm all the way to the left because i'm
trying to get the uh taken over here so
he doesn't have to worry
well i'll i'll go with you because uh
i'm not doing anything there like ever i
i get one wait before you go the thing
is just would you don't go down there
without me just wait until i get there
you'll have time
take instead front right
all right so we can move to the middle
start moving to the middle brain brain
all right brain all right let's go i'm
switch switch
i'm switching it
i'm right behind you so go ahead go here
dickens dead
well do it
all right call another one that's not uh
oh take us right here take us up here i
gotta kill him
um brain
you guys already got break
like my rocket
kind of unstoppable over here
looking for another symbol yeah they're
not all active um
hole in the heart holding the heart it's
over there uh
where they are
already no holy chest is on the other
side yeah yeah i'm going it's right here
in this room
no that's the that's the this is holding
the chest
switch switch
it's daggering the thing
no
are you sure it was holding the chest i
thought it was i saw the heart
did you see red or did you see him i
said red
just go look i'll look
go go i'll go to this one if you said
it's red is this one over here
i gotta hurry up
too yeah they're coming out it is this
one because they're coming out of it
oh yeah they're in here too
i'm about to just tether them and kill
them
yeah
yeah so you get that call out you gotta
call i gotta be a boy hold the call
yeah that's dagger
we gotta get our call out tight
that's what threw it off i'm sorry
that's my fault you were right
what's cool
i wonder
damn baby
yes and thank you for taking up the
floatie position then you have better
weapons than me
probably a better build too
look at that yeah
don't give him credit
okay his dps is is terrible
he
is terrible
only man i know what an unbroken title
in this group
get that right
you got it
i don't gotta broke it
you want it
i'm broken it's more it's more important
though
that means you climb the mountain
brother circle
all right i'm killing it i'm on the
inside
like forte you go rez him after i rescue
you i gotta get like some void like
damage weapons here
switch switch
circle
switch thank you just said
hey are you running the chest you can
have all the different elements on here
again
no
that's the problem
need to run all three resist on us
taking this down
unstoppables out
okay um dagger through heart it's
already done yeah it's already done so i
see i told you you could do it
i knew i could do them it's just certain
rooms aren't set up that way you said
dagger through heart
yeah
oh dagger through heart
yeah yeah
i'm all down i'm just gonna go oh you
gotta open it open it
no we're here we're here
i'm down go in go in go in
we're gonna
behind me as soon as he picked me up
yeah i didn't see him when i was that's
not your fault it's just that there they
just bad one time like that's crazy he
spawned him in a minute behind me
did we get the last take in the third
taking yeah
um
i ain't got one a minute ago
bring
guys two guys pranked you got got you
guys playing you guys praying
i'm already here
all right oh the unstoppable didn't get
stunned when i shot him
they're both dead
stay there forte stay there
all right in this room i have snake i
have slippery snake and i have tower
anybody got uh
slivering steak and tower sliver and
second tower
all right slivering snake and tower
obelisk rejects
slivering snake in town
i do not online actually i have one on i
have a slippery snake on top you have
tower on bottom will
i'm down
all right
here's the next one
what you got what you guys got
hey i shot slithering snake
oh
i think i get it what is it what is it
what do you think you have to hit it
based on where that line is
what line like the line that has its
throw as it's going up
okay all right right now it's going up
so you have to match the top one the
middle one and the bottom one then the
middle one than the top one
but that should that that just rises off
the time
so you have to do the first tier the
second tier and then the third tier
start from the bottom and then
yeah but there's two on each side
it's like three on each side that's the
confusing part
i mean we could try it let's just get
back to it and try it
like think don't think of it as three
sides think of it as three pieces
all three of these right instead of
going instead of going one two take
tears
yeah cake tiers two three so there's the
bottom oh let's talk about like go
circle the bottom first like that's
right okay right so okay so three people
have to learn but then how do we know
which side we do
you you look for your symbol that's just
it like i don't know how you but there's
not three there's not three symbols on
every side
they're different
i'm going to say that there's probably
going to be two maybe that match and one
that doesn't or
and that's the pillar you gotta shoot
and that's the pillar you gotta shoot so
we start looking at the bottom right so
they're looking to the bottom and then
uh make your way up to the top and like
i would i mean we could try it it's not
gonna hurt split up into two three-man
teams so you can cover
as much ground all right you guys ready
we could try it
i don't know i was putting somebody in
time out again
hey all right so we go back hold on
okay
i don't know when y'all got that bot
that's so he's new tear dude yeah he
tried to get his dudes off
[Laughter]
he tried to get
i hope you guys get all the loots you
want
appreciate you bro you know this life
pack
stop it
okay cool i'm already speaking to your
father i appreciate you brother
nice
we gotta take it in overload here
all right
tell us another one
both dead
are you kidding me
what's up um
no we did cuphead
out of them
i got another taken dude
oh come on
if i was up i couldn't hit him
ahead of me
red box
red box
and hole in the chest i'll go for hole
in the chest you go for red box
okay
guys don't be afraid to use your super
supers
that's me
you know what i don't like about void
3.0 is the jumps are just
really the same you're going to say
jumps i know but they're just like
i don't know
because they're so
they're just so sane
other than blink like the jumps for this
subclass always sucked um
did it say just across all subclasses
looking a little like
a little different
senpai
no you're
hot girls and boys part two try to pop
his dudes off
turn them out
he try to keep us well keep us on our
toes while we reach
you guys ready
yeah i'm ready
boom
so my weakening over there
okay
taken's on uh right side
circle
[Music]
i'm going to try and spend like five
seconds in each area
all right upside down okay
it's in the original place
oh i think take it's over here yep take
it's over here
i'm just going to know i don't even care
oh you got him
open the door open the door
switch got you
all right moving on
just keep running the circle
yep
you look clear oh unstoppables out
nobody told me all right i'm coming
directly to you
oh
finally stunned
i got uh
uh it's the uh it's the the ship the
ship one
ship
switch
switch
i can't switch okay
did you switch it
yeah i was dealing with an unstoppable
american you're fine man you're fine you
don't have to explain yourself
clear that out moving on go home
yes
stop all double twos out
i got you
on my way
i think i got him but i don't know it's
real i bet he helped with this i stopped
[ __ ]
[ __ ] lightning
he did it i got him
i got an unstoppable in the back i'll
get him
i have a token
thanks
he's still there
what is killing me
square square wow
do you need the door open yes
i need a res person thank you okay
last room
oh my
god all right all right all right now
it's about to it's about to start
yeah the thing's about to start so
going to you
we need someone to go into one of the
rooms
we got to look now
all right we're forte
three symbols the three all right
[Music]
i don't see anything on rejection
all right
snake pyramid on his head
inkblot shoot inkblot yeah yours is good
you're on second tier now
we're not shooting
inkblot on mine uh but it glowed it
glowed a different color than what it
was let me let me guess we go there's
three different rounds before we get to
that point right so every round has a
symbol
those are the three symbols i'm guessing
so just whenever whatever symbols they
it is we just remember like each one
pick one you have to yeah make sure
the symbols so that you're right but
then wait
one time
some people who know what they are and
some people who they don't so like but
we should probably use two different
groups of three at that point so that we
can go around like you guys don't need
to be the ones necessarily to shoot them
i bet it just needs to they just need to
be shot
so like that's why i said we need to
remember
okay so they call out two symbols when
they get in the first room right
on the bottom tier on the bottom tier of
the cake and the bottom tier one of the
pillars one of the pillars is gonna have
both of them he has to shoot that third
one then he's done with his tier now
somebody else on the other two sides
gotta listen for the second set
and then on that second set they gotta
they're gonna call out two symbols
and then
on that second tier
they will hear the two symbols and have
it on their pillar and then they got to
shoot that third that doesn't
that doesn't comply with it
and the same thing goes with the third
the final
probably rotate around so it might not
be on the same pillar twice you just
have to basically know okay
so
for the first for the first tier there's
two there's two that we need one that
doesn't
okay one that we don't shoot the one
that we're
so the again when you the people that
are going in the room they're gonna have
a symbol in mind that they're coming out
with they're gonna have two
they have two symbols two symbols yeah
because they're killing they're killing
two red uh um two gold bars in there and
then two symbols drop out of them but i
think also just i think we i think
whenever you find the one that it is for
the tier all three people have to shoot
the three sides i think the best way to
remember that is we just rotate like i
have to do about that it might just be
shoot the one
after me and forte go through all the
rooms
the people defending go into their room
and we take the plate to shoot the ones
that they say
because i mean
does it like
like let's say because it seems like
it's always close like this one here was
triangle it was uh uh was square is
literally right i think that like like
you're up here right cog like you look
at the middle one and you go to whatever
one that middle one is and you tell us
the people out to shoot it because the
you guys are never switching from your
plates so it would be hard for like the
the floaters to go to those plates but
it would be easier for the people
defending to go to those plates
so once i see what's in the middle here
i mean see what's here is what you say
yeah i think the best way to do it is
the defenders go and call out and we
should what does the what does the
bottom one mean
when i think it means when it's done
when it's done
are they all the same yeah they're all
the same i think that just means that
we've been in those rooms and we killed
the person in those rooms okay okay
that's cool okay
but i'm still confused on which pillar
you're referencing because this one it's
the middle one it will always be the
middle one that's what room you need to
go to that depends if you guys want to
do it that way you
will you beat the cam you beat the
campaign right
yeah you know those
but then you got to run around the whole
environment and then some of the symbols
are different on different pillars and
you got to do that that's what you're
doing here
you have to go travel the thing is you
just have a team to do it with versus
you doing it yourself
so basically y'all waiting for me
whatever i see in the middle then go in
that room and then
no we can't we really can't do it
because it it rejects it the higher that
and you see it still feels and if it
feels past the bar of that one
it rejects it automatically so you have
to be like ready to go as soon as
it starts that's what i'm saying
but here's the thing the
thing that's built which is this we're
not paying attention to those symbols at
all i'm just asking the questions
so once it gets to the end phase you
know where there's no enemies and we
have to you know shoot the uh odd symbol
out you want the people who are
defending throughout the whole thing to
go into the chorus
that's closest to them to read out this
because it'll be it'll be closest to
them like me and forte could be on the
other side of the map
right right right and then somebody out
here will shoot the symbols or the
symbol that i do not call out
okay
perfect so we just have to pay attention
and shoot rooms they go into and go in
right and the one that you don't call
out i'm shooting on one on the bottom of
one of these which is there
no when you go in you're gonna call out
the symbols that are in the room that
you're closest to and then okay
people out here are going so i'm going
to call i'm going to go up in the room
and this room is most likely could be
it's going to be here
is it a specific location where the room
is all the time that i supposed to be
going into to me every time we've done
it it's always close to the pillar that
it gets
called
so it could be this is what i'm shooting
here is would you say i think yours
would be square
square brain or
yeah tell me what the possibilities are
could be i think yours would be square
brain
square
okay so i'll look at one of those three
will be open i really should be but i
don't know we'd have to look holding
chess i think's on the bottom platforms
it's not on the top so i have a question
do
do unstoppable spine on the third one
when we kill that last set no just two
just two sets there's two that's just
two unstoppables i don't know for sure
so let's just make this separate
okay when we leave a room where we leave
a room after like clearing it
whatever room we leave one person
dedicated to that to that plate needs to
know that that room
they're going to run into on the end
like they're going to run into that room
they're going to leave their plate
because you don't have to defend your
plate no more once we kill that last
person
uh in the last set you just know that if
we came to your plate you're going into
a room
the room that's closest to the room that
we're going to so like who's whose plate
is this right here this is my plate this
section over here isn't it so let's say
me and add it let's say the attic we go
into red or um so you're you're
responsible for the for red square and
for brain
ever come out of those rooms
you know on the last set you will have
to go to one of those rooms and then
when i go in that room
you're just gonna you're gonna read the
emblem that you see inside that room
just out of curiosity the moment you
kill
the people don't the
the the room resets
no what you mean they don't reset the
moment you kill the people in like brain
or something doesn't this pillar go all
the way back down and reset yeah the
rules reset but they still got
all right well let's let's
let's just figure out the mechanic and
then we'll figure out who's shooting
what and who shoots
the mechanic but we still haven't got
one activated sight like i don't know if
we have it yet because we haven't gotten
to that part of the thing i'm talking
about but they still even when we clear
a room they still have ads to deal with
all the way up into the very okay okay
well should we start deciphering them
what we'll do is we they will go into
that room we'll try it out and see how
it goes
all right
or or
who's the extra person says the extra
problem right yes yes
sid you're the extra person
you take look
at it
we have to try this we have to try this
doing this by ourselves bro we don't we
should be able to clean these rooms out
by ourselves
okay so you
let's do a run and see if we can clean
these roofs
[Music]
you take the rooms over next to wilhelm
i'll take the rooms over here next to
frost
okay
i was thinking
so if these rooms pop up we know that
these are the rooms we're dealing with
and you just stay in your room you don't
leave
no you still come out to help your
person but as soon as we are the last
damage phase you go back into the room
that you came out of all right because
we don't want them to get overwhelmed
all right we can help the thing is we
can if we stay in these areas we can
help them with add clear
we can get them taken that's in those
areas so the little bit of time that
we're in the room killing the boss of
those two um gates
they can handle the ads until we come
back out then we come back out and help
them with the um
with the uh with the unstoppables and
then we're we're good then we just keep
going keep going all right we'll try it
that's fine this is true sorry let's try
that i like that let's try that
i don't like frost over here by himself
you know hundreds got a sticker yeah
first of all oh my god oh my god
especially when they look like
[Music]
there he is he's right there
got him
oh there you go i got him
he was literally in my grenade
all right let's see what it is all right
it's
upside down snow cone
all right that's over next to sinister
oh i gotta take it over
the door that's what you did i'm
switching it
okay i gotta go take out the steak
you got him that that brain door is open
by me by the way
yeah i know
we switched the thing
oh baby
oh snobble's out
oh yeah i got
murked
remember those are stoppables
i'm not used to dealing with them so i
didn't even look for it
they come out they sneaky
oh my god
just white
yeah too many of us died you gotta be
ready for those um
yeah i was trying to deal with that mad
ass at once
i want to see something before i die
good just cutting the galley out
no no i was just looking
all right
do you know where that unstoppable
spawns be
yeah i can show you what he always wants
let me show you a spot he always comes
out
because i'll melt his ass the moment he
comes out i just didn't know where he
spawned he he just pops out out of
nowhere it'd be like no spawn time it's
like poof he's here well he he pops out
every time a room is done
mm-hmm yeah he be in his feelings you
know like i'm
right
keep going i'm assuming back here
yeah like i'm gonna show you this right
here like yeah he'd be like right here
all the time okay all right yeah he's
like i'm standing his way he comes out
and then he'll just move forward here
all right i'mma get his ass all right
you guys ready
yeah i'm ready
let's go
oh taken take it take it by you oh yeah
sure
oh you got him okay
all right what's ours
um upside down oh my god
yo if they throw that purple on your
[ __ ] rap if you don't see it
open the door swap the door
come in
got it
okay our puller's done
we need the next taken
yeah ours isn't under yet
triangle
he's on triangle take it in the back
same spot attic spot where the osama was
at
unstoppable
[Music]
that's where we're going at the end
yep
open the door yeah thank you
thank you
something went wrong
i think we waited too did you did you
we took too long to find that one that's
what it was
okay
we got it yeah those because uh
we if we don't get to take in it does it
trigger the
tell you what door it is
yeah we were one door away
and what's funny is it was both on our
side too
yeah yeah so the cool thing is
will basically be responsible for um
these two doors over here see these two
right here
cup and
this one
and then they'll be responsible for
[Music]
actually you know we'll take these three
we have to take these three because they
because they got three in the front
right there too okay
they got the three over there in the
corner so we'll take these three
which is the uh
steak through heart upside
triangle or pyramid and we'll take uh
cups okay you guys ready
yeah we're ready
okay triangle side where the taken
is i think there's a take-in in the back
attic i'm gonna have a chuck
yeah i think i know where he's at
yeah he's here i figured
better how long you see if i get him
yes we are
okay
all right the next one's ours
circle square
go to so square
we have an unstoppable in the back doors
down
square
square are you out square
i'm going i'm going yeah i know i open
the door
i tried waiting for him to get out of
the room so that i could close his door
sorry about that
no you're fine man you're good
oh
unstoppable
i'm coming i'm coming to help you
what's the last room did we get in there
yet yeah i'm in here
all right
oh what
all right um
hey i i'm in here called
all right
hurry up it's about to reset we gotta
hurry kill it
what was the alcohol out
wait i am in the room right now
about to be away
one of the rooms wasn't done
yeah i didn't hear a call out for our
site
oh so yeah we no one caught out the
other room that's all i was saying i
ain't hear it either i was in the i was
i called out cuphead
yeah and square
what does the other body call out for my
side
well that's because it was that's cause
it was probably all your pillar will
didn't call it out no
um on my pillar it was square on for
taste uh and uh frosty was uh cuphead
okay
so
y'all didn't call that out
without okay yeah you're supposed to
call out your pillar how did you need to
call a pillow yeah
you're gonna need to call it out because
i was in there uh clearing the room
so i when you said you were going in the
room i thought that's what you went to
go do i was in the room clearing it out
and that they didn't know your pillar
but what that's easy to fix
what we're going to do to fix it so i
don't know just just next pylon not your
pylon your pillar this one
yeah just next time say what's in the
middle okay
are you guys ready that's all i mean
okay
yes oh [ __ ] you're good let's go you're
good no no i thought i thought i thought
i did it
these show guys are really pissing me
off dude
[Music]
he's down though oh come on a blast on
the way out wow
wow really
oh it gets me all right
we got actually it's on the way out on
the way up upside down
yep that's your semester
what
oh yeah yeah that's me i got to open the
door for you let me know
yeah open the door please
all right i got you
and i gotta take it over here let me
nova bomb him
you're doing me dirty put a taken right
outside my door man
all right looks like sam completed ours
the white uh
circle is already gonna take it we gotta
take it up top
circle oh somewhere over there
yeah i'm shooting i'm shooting
okay
am i supposed to be going
heart in the chest
pulling chest
part yeah heart and part in chest heart
in chest well no the yeah the thing in
the chest yeah the thing in the chest
heart heart heart
i got it
yeah i just ran forward today i stunned
him but i died i'm going down yeah i'm
going down low to this room
i i i stunned him i had to get back over
here to call
[ __ ] purple [ __ ] serious oh watch him
[ __ ] up yeah there we go
let's see
oh there's that now the symbol what's
this what we call it no it's it that
means it's completed that means it's
completely okay
okay
earth is the wrong one
all right i got it
all
right
all right i'm in this room um
[ __ ] we need somebody to take one take
our pillar because me and uh frost have
to take these i'm going i'm going to the
heart what am i looking for here
tell me what you want to go to
what is it what is it i blob and score
[ __ ] whatever it is upside down uh snow
cone upside down snow cone
upside down
i'm going to no no it's it's it's on my
end upside down snow cone i froze i got
open the door open the door
open the door
will you talk to me no no i'm talking to
them
okay i got
okay
i noticed something when we did it that
time
when those those symbols
are activating look i got it right
glyph's defeated
he's stupid look at that forte got it
right
all right now i noticed something with
me when i was over here doing with cog
i noticed that
when we do rooms
these
uh like let's say that you guys do a
room this whole side lights up and then
when the next room they're i think
they're done by whatever side it's on
i did know because i did shoot
the top and i think it's top to bottom
because if you look it starts at the
bottom it goes to the top and i shot
middle yeah
and i shot and it did freeze the scoring
one that i did when i shot it on this
side
because it's like i said
i had two over here so i mean i guess if
there's like uh a side that's left out
maybe they can come over and listen to
the call outs that we do when we go into
the rooms
because that was kind of confusing i
don't think that's happened yet but
well the reason it didn't happen is
because
i didn't even go into a room because
someone went to the room before i could
get in there
well that's because the your side wasn't
a room that's right yeah so you guys
didn't have a
you guys didn't have all right so you
guys ready to start
oh that might be a taken
over here
triangle is where ours is triangle yep
where is it
don't know there's nothing on ours kill
the one taken
does it say does anybody have anything
on their screen
um okay i got uh ships ships
ships
the ship one
there's a taken over there
yeah i'm shooting
the one that we call in pyramid the one
here with the light coming out
square okay
going i'm just waiting for forte to go
open the door open the door
i'm out i'm out
open the door
i am okay i got it i got it i have an
unstoppable here
yeah
i got him
what's your call forty side
nothing yet
oh my god
that dude did not want to stop
all right anybody got 4k for you got him
they wanted to get him
i got him okay
all right got mine
charge grenade wasn't it kept um
okay i was doing it just pop up now
forte
you said what
our simple ship pop up on the obelisk
now there was a takeover yes no cones no
cool down down unstoppable
oh minute
what's that reboot and twitch i see bro
you notice it does that chat thing
automatically now you don't have to like
bringing up that chat thing anymore yeah
i'm noticing it yeah you're right i
forgot about that i didn't realize that
it is doing it because i looked for it a
couple weeks ago and i couldn't find it
so i just assumed they moved it i was
going to ask you about but i've noticed
it's still going through
they did move it so it looks like you
don't even need to pull it up on the
separate window no more because i don't
know
and it's doing it so that's good
i think i think i got it figured out let
me let's do it a couple more times
i
because uh my symbol the one i did was
on this side
okay
it wasn't on the other side it was on
this side
don't go
i think they have to tell us the symbol
that is on their side and we have to hit
the one like this one for the side
that's facing this one this one for the
right side and we have to hit our symbol
on this side
shoot it
yeah because because
i mean i don't know what to say
i think that's what it is but it would
look like laid out it's
opposite
it's not even facing y'all it's facing
us both two sides are facing
the spawn
yeah ready yeah
all right let's go
hey
got the sun at the top
i got to take it right here
i'm looking for our taking i don't see
him yet
i don't see him
all right so let me see
checking radar all right take it
he ain't coming all right hole in the
chest holding the chest
i think that is over next to you
i got it i got it i'm in there i'll go
ahead and open the door
all right
we have to take it
nice
all right last one should be what y'all
calling that star oh gobbles out brain
it says taken on triangle side
which queen ships which queen ships
oh [ __ ] i'm getting late show i'm
getting glazed crazy i'll take brain
i'll take breakfast because it's all the
way inside this thing still
oh i don't have my bubble or anything
ships
upside down snow cone i'm going in
all right slivery snake squiggly
[ __ ] like a stun
and a grenade
i don't see my mark on there at all
i don't see my mark on there at all
either i think all three of them have to
be out who hasn't done this someone
hasn't done that i haven't done mine
at the moment
which one's yours
uh upside down snow cone i just went
down rising
jesus oh my god
sorry it's crazy
all right they're all there
yep
um
okay
all right so mine is which queen ships
why is it squiggly lines and
i got the second one
oh it went through
oh my
i don't see ships up there at all like
at all give me get one right
i believe so
nope maybe it's
we have an activated glyph
two of the i think we have to do all
three uh to activate it
there's not three though
but there's three layers
i know but there's not three in the
rooms
yeah but there's there's three layers so
oh yeah i get what you're saying yeah i
get what you're saying wait again
each room is a layer i think
i think the third room the last room
that you do is the top layer the middle
room is the middle layer and the first
room is the bottom layer yeah i agree i
concur
said that bad stroke
so that means we'll always be on top cod
well it depends
it just depends on if your meaning
what that means
i feel like
i feel like they're on different floors
for a reason
one's at the very bottom one's in the
middle platform and one's at the top
platform
you know i just think that's the weight
of the year
all right let's start it
i think that looks at the boss
there goes my raid boss belt very stupid
going to his house just like the other
two yo you stupid well he did get what
he did he did miss out on 2402
triangles ours
oh hell no you're not finishing me
anybody the taking yet no i'm looking i
just killed one we killed one i'm going
for the pillar to look at it
okay circle side is the next taken
all right
uh
hands up in the air praying praying
praying praying man praying praying man
or two praying man i think that's what
we're supreme that's me yeah that's me
you got it hurt go away because you
gotta hurry up and kill it real fast
how did that know i had nothing okay
what full devour full devour with a
oh yeah we still enjoying it oh yeah
still enjoy the game
gotta keep putting this guy on timeout
yeah he loose
please don't acknowledge him
yeah but experience different accounts
no i mean like ban it but just don't
acknowledge him because then he feels
like he's getting oh yeah
is there a way to
ban somebody no
yeah you don't time them out hiding
yeah hi when you see hi that's what you
do
all right you guys writing the channel
mm-hmm
like you had your time to raid glad
already took your belt
took your jacket took your belt took his
watch
i tell you sometimes that [ __ ] bird
is like bro it's ridiculous
over the top
like you can't stand still at all don't
stand still
okay
sometimes you're standing still to fight
other ads i mean you don't even realize
they threw this [ __ ] on you and it's too
late circling looking forward for my
taking my own melee is what came back
and killed me
yeah take out these guys on the right i
think i've seen it taken yep
anybody see be dead
square
open the door open the door
got you
upside down cone i'm going in
all right
three symbols
you might have to deal with us
yeah uh circle yeah circle side is where
the next taken is so
somewhere on our side guys
yeah i'm looking oh i think i think i
know where he is yep he's over here in
the corner i got him okay come on i'm
getting yo i got that stubble i got mad
drama
all right i got him building up jesus
earth okay brain brain brain
brain that's a god that's about you um
it's
i already did one what is it brain
brain what i'll do i'll do it if you
already did without do it if you did
i'll do it
so you ain't gonna do two
look carl come over here real quick
hold on there's a lot of drama right now
here just get behind the show oh my god
all right it's good
my controller just died oh [ __ ]
that sucks
yeah man i didn't even get a prompt or
anything
that's cool
i hate
did i kill this
i think we rejected somebody [ __ ]
yeah well we got a man
yeah sorry guys
maybe you can uh finish it before
if we all have one what if we just shoot
it yeah like what if we just got around
one and shot one just get around what
i'm doing i'm just probably gonna do it
you definitely gotta shoot it because it
lights up like you're doing so
yeah get around
kirby
at the same time and then uh
man with the star over his head
my my symbols disappeared
yeah i don't know
this offer [ __ ] is what's [ __ ] up
something just happened yeah something
happened it's still going
yeah
i think we got one right by accident
actually let's see
why this dudes
what happened
oh no glyph activated
you gotta do a whole the whole thing
yeah like a round is like
[Music]
he went to town and it's a second ago
i don't know
troop symbolize is materialized
everywhere your eyes are always closed
you not see what's right in front of you
those who feel
please
uh
shoot everything
shoot it all
do it the titan way shoot everything
all right
so about to read this so let's go
go ahead you go enemies enemies spawn
from around the room of room size and
attack three obelisks in the middle
don't let uh don't let them don't shoot
the obelisk yourself shooting them fills
them up faster when the ambulance feels
you wipe they also feel naturally
there's a total near each ambulance with
three hexagons on and shooting the
the crux above the obelisk turns it
orange so is there
above it
above the obvious oh yeah up here above
this obviously
wait hold on what you said what you're
looking at what about what happened
they also feel there is a totem near
each ambulance with three hexagons yes
one yes
those three yeah what about that
shooting the crux above the obelisk
turns it orange allowing you to see the
glyphs on the total
so shooting the joint above the obelisk
allows you to see yeah
let's see
see shooting the crux above the obvious
turns it orange allowing you to see the
glyphs on the totem
killing one ad reveals the first glimp
the second glyph is revealed after
killing the script the discreet wave the
third
of symbol appears once somebody enters
the glyph room
go ahead
are we just gonna so we're we're we're
reading we're we're at that point right
like this is yeah
i think maybe
yeah
let me let me just let me just look it
up like we figured out quite a bit i'm
gonna tell you we figured out a lot so
it looks like what we was messing up
because i just looked it up
is one
we don't shoot all the relics one relic
has all of them and the rest don't
i see
it says
killing all the glyph keepers gives the
chat the uh the obelisk awaits your
offering the glyphs appear on the
obelisk one obelisk has the glyphs from
all three correct uh glyph keepers not
necessarily on the same side shoot
those three glyphs on the obelisk only
there is
no specific order but you have to be
fast
yeah that's what i was thinking
all the glyphs all six glyphs aren't
going to be on the ovulation you just
have to get three of them
so they're basically it's like a 50 so
there's like they're giving you six of
them but you only really need three and
three are going to show up on the
obelisk those three
are the ones that you shoot on one
obelisk to complete for all of them
okay
so we only necessarily have to worry
about one obelisk not shooting three
things on each obelisk
right yeah just one opponent okay okay
so perfect that you know what now that
now that we've read it it seems so
simple
one of those things where you look back
in like a year like how did they you
know take so long to do this and
yeah we were like thinking it was way
more more complex than it what it was it
seems
yeah
like when yeah that's what i like about
day one rates though everything is like
it's actually so simple but it's
are there three symbols are there three
symbols in each room that you guys go
into or two just two two
two so how do the two correspond to
um because that's where you're getting
the symbols from right that's the one
thing that i
uh i'm just kind of curious about
because i think they're going are they
going into the rooms
well you need to like one totem
essentially will have the symbols
that correspond to
correctly i guess
right
who else read that
who was this reading the thing i think
that was potatoes reading or attic i
forgot
the thing that i read was find one
obelisk with all three
there are three glyphs they correspond
to glyphs on one of the three obelisks
you have to shoot all three repeatedly
at the same time
that's what i read
there okay
so there are three glyphs they
correspond to glyphs on one obelisk
one of the three but the three glyphs
are the thing that i'm confused about
we're i'm not sure where you find those
three glyphs
three glyphs they correspond to three
glyphs on one obelisk you have to shoot
all three repeatedly at the same time
that's how accuse it
it's how it goes is we have to
communicate with each other look at
every relic and find out which relic has
all of the emblems and shoot and then we
come over and shoot all of the emblems
on that one relic
okay and i think they have to be all in
the same on the same block or something
along those lines
oh on here
it looks like what because i'm looking
at glass team dude it looks like it was
just random it's just you have to all
you have to communicate and find out
which one is on what because some of
them have one or two but only one of
them has all uh
six
okay oh so all six of them are gonna be
on one yes on just one four six okay
all right so let's do this let's look at
the [ __ ] three rooms with two things
yeah yeah let's just get this [ __ ] out
one second
hold on one second you know what's crazy
i never even one time thought about
looking at just one relic like not one
time did i think about will be on one
relic yes it's all six
i'll say
that's a lot to remember it's a lot to
remember no we would just the people
that go in there and count it just get
it and we'll go from one side to another
and you'll look like chances are if you
read three or four and there's three or
four on there because there's only nine
spots so chances are if you're getting
three or four to five then that's the
right one but we will have to go
like you know one at a time
it's also like shifting around but but
it gives us enough time don't shoot any
just call them out before we do it like
i'll look at my like the good thing is
if you look at yours and you don't see
both of yours then chant then that is
not it you have to go to another one
there has to be one the moment you go to
yours and there's not one of yours on
that pillar then it has to be the other
two
yeah it's one of the other eliminations
because remember [ __ ] i told you i was
like it doesn't have mine on here like
none of mine's all right
so so this is the question so this is
what we do
we keep we do what we just did because i
think that works better with the way
that we got the rules broken up yeah so
when we so when we go in the room and
kill the the
the gatekeepers in that room
we call out what our emblem is and our
person that is defending the plate just
remembers and you remember one and they
remember well i go in and i just
everybody has one
i go in and i just remember it and what
i what you need what the first thing you
need to do is come out and see if both
of yours is on your pillar because if
both yours aren't in your pillow it's
gonna be one of the other twos
no but but you could still see them all
not until you get to the last phase you
can't see them all you can only see as
as you know they're all there oh no
you're talking about the three the whole
three rooms yeah you have to take out
all three rooms to see all night
i could shoot the top to see all the
gloves
well let's let's try let's try i think
we got it this time like well obviously
we got it we know we just cheated but it
is what it is let's go
man people are people are paving the way
for all oh my god
i like that thank you glass team for
paving the way play testers are told
glad what to do
i will say
some probably a little loose but but
bungie's usually pretty strict when it
comes to stuff like that
i will i will say that there are
probably incidences we don't know about
where some people have learned some kind
of raid mechanic but i don't think like
the whole range or anything like that
they're just going to take them out
they're just like oh maybe you think
he's back here with me
they always be running man i need to use
the sleeper i felt like i was doing
better with the sleeper
the gal horn they just moved before i
hit
them take it take it back here
got him
oh i'm stopping god damn i just deal
with the kick in the stomach popped up
right
you got him forte says there's a taking
on circle side
i gotta get out of here
yeah just just just just chill uh we got
it me and him got it
he's done he's good
for whatever reason
well at least we know what to do
uh we had it we just was this is that
one key thing about just one pillar
we were making it harder than what it
was
yeah to be honest
to be honest with you i never would have
i didn't even consider just looking at
one relic i'm a bureau if you i even
consider it at all
all right all right let's go
okay it's so much better to go behind
them when they spawn
yep
oh take it take it take it all right all
right i got you
oh you
he moved
yeah
only the pack rounds got him
all right uh
uh the taking [ __ ] whatever you guys
call that
oh
yep that's yeah the pyramid
i got it
all right keep films clear
what's the next one
all right no clue this room's clear
i'm dead
i'm coming out how to get him somebody
got him
i got him okay
uh where's the next one
um
i'll take it
yeah there's a taken on
uh yeah let's just take it over there
oh
[Music]
there you go okay the symbol is
um
red hands red hands red hands
a sinister oh switch the door please
open the door
all right got you that's the third one
isn't it
there's one more yes the last door
the first time
i didn't get a door so who got two doors
cheating has energized me like a bunny
because i know what to do
cheating it's not cheating
you still got the whole day i'm ready
for it we we was we was definitely
looking at the cliff notes though unless
we were here
dude i never would have thought to look
at one relative like not one thing i
never considered looking at just one
relic
i just figured it'd be like the one
that's not there or yeah like
they they they threw that was a wrench
like that was crazy
they put three relics and only one's
relevant
what's up what's up buddy what's up
buddy what's up buddy
over here
he already took it down
okay um upside down cone upside down
upside down upside down cone ours is on
the triangle side
let me know if the door needs to open
i wonder if i just closed it i think i
did no he's in there
i know but i closed it on him so i'm
going to open it back up
cuphead
i'm going
don't close that door yet i'm going to
get another taker i'm coming though i
got it i should be able to get it
should be down earth tower
oh it's topples out you know definitely
need help now
open my door go ahead i got it over here
for us
open your door yo unstoppable i'm coming
i'm coming i'm coming
okay coming back to you for today
what's the uh what's the last door
i'm looking hold on getting in position
it's not my side i'll prank uh
next to me open change switch the door i
gotta go back in
i got two of them
someone has to open the door for him
i'm dead what is
it yeah somebody got him
i'm going in
i don't know if i have enough rockets to
do it
don't worry about getting me right away
you [ __ ]
it's this side this side this has my
size there's the only one that had all
mine
i'm done i'm dead
all right somebody go pick him up i got
him i got him
which queen [ __ ] i can go get him i can
go get him
i got him i got him
[ __ ] focus funny thing which queen
you guys shoot your eyes
we name something
[Music]
earth
and what
damn it
damn i had them all but two i had them
all but too damn
i'm sorry they gave me two rooms i had
this one
trust me it was so wild for me son i
don't know how i was
it was crazy
that's why you should just told me
saying that i would've just ran instead
of going in there i would have went over
there
i was in there
you get two rooms on your side just let
one let the other team that didn't get
one note so they can go in the room for
you
oh man we we had this we had two just
two we have a clean run it's a wrap
clean run it's a wrap
yeah i think you're gonna do it three
times though oh well that's fine that's
fine
one for this phase then there's i think
there's like three faces to this
are you guys ready
yeah
i switch back to the sleeper it's just
so much easier using the sleeper
yeah i noticed cali you're getting
frustrated with it's because it like the
the dude would move at the last minute
and they would just be like half a shot
on but the sleeper goes straight to his
eyes damn it damn it
you killed everything sin and it took my
devourer away
i got nothing from that
okay circle side circle
i'm on them i'm on them already
okay all right i'll read out the symbol
once it kills it
you get it
get off the call dagger through heart
dagger through heart dagger
that's me right here
okay i'll open the door for you it's
already open
you're in the wrong one forte it's on
the other side of it oh right here i'm
sorry
the take is not over here
huh i knocked him off the stage
what did you say called
no i was telling let's call it that gala
horn in it
all right hold on triangle triangle
pulling chest okay
it's got to be somewhere over here
we need triangle i don't know where that
taken is
he's on the triangle side it's on your
left side
i went over there twice i didn't see him
all right you see him
we definitely missed the ticket because
i don't see him he's probably either i
got a sport
there's no like i don't know i don't see
him
okay so he might not be there just yet
no he's over here he's over here
oh no this guy him that's not honest
he's not back here in the back either
i i'm looking like he is on the
and i've never seen him all right all
right disappearing
yeah we missed him
no one saw him or he didn't spawn i
looked all the spots he could be
i'm sure that there's some
glitch that happens on occasion there is
something because we all looked i felt
we all know
okay
i'm starting
what's up
i hear it taken yeah he's here
you know what i'm playing with you bro
all right i don't know what he was on
but we got him
yeah i wasn't playing no
downward hands he flipped the door
downward hands
you need the door open yes
okay uh taken's on circle side
all right i think i'm looking for him
now
here
yep i got him he's over here
all right so i got a pink block inkblot
and
two umbrellas okay dagger through heart
all right that's me
triangle oh [ __ ]
change the doors i had an unstoppable
just like appear in front of me yeah i'm
glad that happened
thank you got another uh taken here i
got him
he's down that's good
cup
i'm going keep the door open i'm almost
there
all right
i got her stumbles out
and
someone help cog i'm not in there with
him all right i'll get i'll be able to i
should be able to do it
got him
that was real
that was
i killed him but he got me
all right frosty got him oh you want me
to get him you got attic oh no frost
all right what's going to be shooting
what am i supposed to be shooting
taking i called inkblot and two
umbrellas take
see if you see taken king if you don't
see taking king it's not it
nope don't see taking okay next one next
one next one
great the the green blue and white
whatever colors those are that's my next
one
right here right here
okay go for it i think it's this one yes
okay yeah this one
taken king
which is up there at the top we need
more uh people shooting theirs
wait a minute where's earth
that's it no no we messed up
it's fine it's fine just calm down
calm down fine take your
there's taken king
right here right there
okay
you gotta admit we get
i think the only people that should be
well yeah no i'm saying would you say
the only people should be shooting is a
certain certain amount of people yes
probably is the people that
that know what
yeah
i only shot mine i didn't shoot other
people
i'm not shooting [ __ ]
i was scared to shoot i was scared
at this point it ain't going because
okay you guys ready
i'm curious we left like one of these
guys alive like that bigger champion
dude i wonder if they keep respawning
yeah they still
they still spawn
yeah okay taking
this over here by me
yeah sir
got him
yep
got him
all right someone should have uh
that means it's over here somewhere with
us called
yeah don't see it
i'm gonna die if i don't know usually i
can hear him
i think he's back here
yep he's back there
got him nice i got him
all right i got
i got a
squiggly heart i'll be a flower shade
and a picture of the cuphead
cuphead
i didn't hear what i had to go into what
was the pull up
where's the triangle
triangle we have one more taken that's
up
oh [ __ ] yeah
what
nice okay cool oh i'm coming back uh-huh
i like it that's one chip
oh i'm down
i'm going for that someone's got to help
call it
[ __ ] nowhere
i got taken king and uh
shooting the obelisk like crazy [ __ ]
can't get the
cranker ships in this one
okay i just killed the
unstoppable
dumb dead yeah they sh they shoot
anomalous like crazy
okay offering time
offering time
we never got the last room called we
never got the last snakes
snakes and prayers snakes in prayer
the two arm dude
staking prayer on me stinking prayer on
me leave that guy alive
he's going to throw that purple stuff
on the bottom
snake
snake
you gotta do it quick man
wilhelm you got to get your kills up
you're stupid
he's at 48.
most kills
if we keep hitting our heads against it
man we're going to get it hold on don't
start it yet
literally
my food is really
one minute
and i want to interrupt in the middle of
the run
wait a minute
jacob take it take that four or five
my things my problems are crazy make
sure one moment he's in there though
who's who brought us in
you saw it you saw where they were
saying people can't uh
people can't join mid-game and that
that's they ain't gonna get the i don't
even know it's not like we're gonna do
it anyway but
in that update it said that
what is that
it said that like people can't just join
like i'm just i mean i guess they said
it like more like team i guess they i
already went to the town
i guess they're staying in there i think
though
you can probably
i don't need to go
just one person gotta stay
unless that person gets everything and
that would be really bad yeah let me
promote to leader okay
um
i i don't
this will not really interrupt anything
but i just wanted to
um
try
maybe while he's eating his food can we
just try something really quick i just
wanted to see if like keeping one enemy
alive area it doesn't i saw them
spawning anyway
because i mean we don't we don't kill
them all and they're still spawning
thank
i can't tell i'm just like clearing them
out so quick
you mind if i try one so we're waiting
for it well
i just gotta have something
besides me
this must do this
i was like how much are we
not nothing in the movie
microdynamics helium
yeah
signature two
hmm yeah
not worth it
it seems like the yellow bars keep
spawning but the
other ones don't
it's not really worth it
i'm streaming still
jesus
your relationship
you should be spending so much
so
so
um
you want to show me how you got out the
map
over here
okay
pretty big hole
oh that hole
i didn't even see that
heat rise up to the top
all right can i go to the tower real
quick since we're still leaving yep
who's the leader
solar
all right let's check this leader first
thing since later
um
all right i'll be right back
we could wipe when he gets back
i'm going to go get a raid banner
i won't let me touch
dang it
i just gotta wait for my grade then
maybe i could fly with these rings
did you use a sword
no just you rising
push up against the wall
it's not letting you
kind of have to get a little momentum
when you hit the wall
and usually like dark
name to the right side
so there's pods in the
pantry
it's a game momentum
there you go
well done
no there's a ceiling
yep
there's some other places i didn't
really explore yet
okay
let's see
put the pot in there
and like four drops of the
tomorrow
okay
no floor there
all right
[Music]
did you well you live in new york
nevermind
[Music]
don't worry about it we're just
exploring the outside of the raid
oh yeah
you do scream stuff
screen got you a project
try this way
up there but then i went down underneath
here
well i got away from my
yeah i'm waiting for my comeback
try to go left
that like a
secret door
i was gonna say i went this way
nowhere to go over there
okay try this
are you going to
there's some line geometry over here i'm
hoping to land on
it's not real
i said i hate this one they stole my
food like what dog dad stealing your
food
that's crazy
you made it somewhere sure yeah
a couple of places
oh i see over there
all right i gotta wait for my grenade
[Music]
forte do you have the other half
i do have it
which one do you prefer the fallen
guillen team
because i got the same roll on
my other half
and i'm like but i kind of like the
homeschool whirlwind blade
frame
yeah one way you spin as opposed to that
dash
i agree
let me trust them
i see what i need to do it's it's a dash
then the glide
it's what video games are made for
how else would you get it to level four
and mario
kind of jump outside the box
barrier there
okay
go up or around
bungie's gonna be like we need to plug
up that hole
let's get these prawns
jesus my postmaster was full like crazy
uh this over here
but this doesn't really lead anywhere
it's not anywhere i can see
okay
pretty ornate
geometry
still got more problems jesus
can't say they don't bless you in the
rain
fish
guardian down
all right so i found
you can go here
yeah and then come up here
yeah and then you go up there dash up
there
yep but then we can go that way maybe
and make a right
slide cancel under this
oh no it's not letting you
no i was
i'm just waiting for my grenade
clamber
i i found another spot
let me see
oh okay i'm up here
well actually i think you could just
jump up from there where you were i'm
just gonna go from the stairs
[Laughter]
there's water on this side
stairs on that side
wait that was the first area that let me
jump up
more running space
for training
yeah i'm here
i asked you you think
a blinding grenade would work on the
unstoppable or not
probably
[Music]
they should they do work i know it works
they block this way out that's for sure
i wish if i had the stun joint
i think i'd be more effective with the
heck
have you all ever eaten that surges
before
yeah i'm almost
ready what'd you say for what'd you say
for us
anybody every at uh an italian place
called sergey's
no wait where's that i think it's just
located at new york
where you from frost
upstate new york man i live like oh
you're upstairs in canada yeah you're
upstate okay
oh i live you're probably not that far
from the street
i live near canton but you guys know
where you can get in this can't do you
know where poughkeepsie is
[Music]
yeah they're there
are you like western like how close are
you to buffalo are you like that side
are you more close
i'm like messina
um
canton i'm like an hour and a half away
from um
watertown
oh i know what it sounds how many hours
north are you from new york city
um
i know it's like four from albany um
i'm joined in
i think maybe like six
seven are you up near lake placid like
that area
i'm by tupper lake i mean tougher lakes
an hour away
i'm in [ __ ] nowhere dude
from the stairs yeah
no i'm on the other side i gotta go all
the way around i'm almost done with the
smoke guys and i'm back up to that
little ledge
i'm just flying back into them now
oh he wouldn't clamber
let's just kill myself
[Music]
you tell them
she's having a ball he's playing
fortnite yes
i found it easy to make it from that one
jump on that upper ledge next to the
stairs
even the easiest to get up here
i was gonna try and just skid up that
one you might be able to get that too
come on grenade
any day now
not enough height
just under right
yep
water ledge
[Music]
look someone come uh
anybody if anybody's sitting by like
they're raped i don't think they could
get over here come towards
i think they can come over here look
come towards uh cuphead
here
yeah i see you right under me
oh hey what's up
no [ __ ]
wow
that's crazy
i can't slide under there come on let me
emote
oh
like the one that is like the chair that
goes backwards
that like the normal chair like the
little just pop out and it sits and you
kind of slouch
what's it called okay hold on let me
look i got it
um
i think it's called pop chair emote
chair pop yeah i got pure pop yeah
just back up right into it and then just
try to get on the lowest lowest ledge
there you go back up into it crouching
there you go
you send the throne one put me way in
there man i'll try that one
the pop chair just has another thing
that has a glitch with that although i
think it works with that one
i think since we're just gonna be
waiting or whatever i'm gonna look up a
video
myself just so that i i mean
we're at that point anyway we're at that
point
yeah i'm ready
oh [ __ ]
you know i think we have to wipe
anywhere
okay are we all just jumping up real
quick oh yeah it's a new one it's a new
one
yeah
can you meet your mic frost while you're
watching it
well i mean i'm not watching it yet
someone's wrong yeah that's not
someone's watching something
hey club what you get from wendy's
i got me that um
bacon eater
bacon need a combo
you have a seriously issue on reviving
me soon
you said what
i'm pretty sure that was sin that
revived me because that's he does [ __ ]
no that wasn't me i was i was under the
map that was somebody else
stop blaming me
what you need to worry about is
webcamchat.com
hi girls and videos
get back
there it is
okay this is because adam's computer has
a virus
all the [ __ ] he'd be watching
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it is here
i'm gonna try sleeper this time just
i was doing good once i just want to see
see what it do what would you do
oh i was using a rocket launcher but i'm
probably gonna go back to the rocket but
i get more shots with the sleeper
they got some tron stuff in the in the
store
wait man so esoteric oh man you don't
know how to explain this [ __ ]
what do you do what do you what do you
do okay so you know when um the triangle
pops up and then you have to kill the
taken or the circle or whatever and then
you kill the taken and then the symbol
pumps up
what did you do
[Music]
stupid
you put the wings on us right there
okay
crush
i don't know it seems like attic
understands already
what to do
okay
whatever
right
what it is is um
we got to make sure the the call out
people are at that obvious like we got
to do it fast
so it's like i said like when you go
back to your obelisk if you don't see
your two on that list then go to the
next one
okay
and most of the time someone's going to
say yo all your shit's here it's over
here just like
here's here
i need a pen and paper that's what i do
are you ready
are you guys ready
yeah i love it that's good that's gonna
be really serious i love it
take pictures
i'm testing out this grenade launcher to
see if they're blind work
i gotta write my [ __ ] down
oh it do work
on these guys
how did you get by
all right where's the taken spawner
i am checking far left right now i feel
like ours is always loud over here i got
him
yeah someone should at least have the
circle or triangle
that fire dude he can't even do anything
for the thing right
now
a triangle side
all right cuphead
there's a take it over there you're
gonna get them okay cool
first call out
uh that's you forte i believe yep i got
it
okay second call out is um pyramid ship
that's right in front of me if someone
wants to take it is that forte
cod we wait on your call out ours is on
circle
there's a taken over there somewhere
double checking going far left we'll see
it's not on our side it's on their side
sir okay yeah
it's by you frosty you got an
unstoppable over here yeah i'm going
with an unstoppable and a taken and all
of them
yeah i'm coming i got your back
got him
blondie grenade launches lit
he's definitely not up here so he's
probably behind the unsolvable yeah
right here
and what is the call wow
all right it's hard
heart yeah
stabbed in heart yeah damn all right
i'll go to that forte
oh yeah
you already had one here
nobody went into the pyramid ship in
front of me either
i'll go to it i'll go to it
i'll go to it i'll go to the pyramid
[ __ ]
all three of these are on this side
jesus
christ went down at the same moment
and they just put a thing on me
it's a wrap
okay switch it switch them back
i think i think we need we need to
assign like one two and three because
like sometimes you we won't do one
because i think sinister's doing or
forte's doing it like
because that's why i never went to the
ship is because i thought forte was
doing it
yeah forte went in the cuphead and then
pyramid i should have went to the cup
was the dagger through the house yeah
but nobody was going so i would but you
you didn't give a chance i i just
assumed it was it was up for like a good
10 15 seconds
it was it was took down
it was took down and frost said that's
forte right and you you was already
running for it
oh sorry
because i figured we were doing cuphead
um pyramid chips and dagger through
heart you were doing um you're doing the
other three square
but sometimes it's not the other three
and i feel like we have like a lot of
like miscommunication when it's they're
not all at one area like well that's
what that means
that means you're carrying four at that
point then that's why
the only time that you should take one
that i don't have on my side is if i
already have one like sin did but if
we're already if we're already flipping
like that why don't we just do i do the
first you do the second and send us the
third
well what if the first is closer to you
and not to me exactly yeah
but once if there's two at the bottom
and none at the top
like i said just did he ran over he took
it
okay
we did this what's that that's all about
the communication we just got to
communicate it
i heard forte went into cuphead so i
went over there to daggerheart
let's go
we got it
mm-hmm
these delayed spawns on these yellow
part enemies aren't really uh
you know
yeah
a little bit much
all right first take in i see him by you
yeah rocket he's by uh
your daddy
there you go
how many shots are going to sleep with
10.
okay okay
all right
hear me [ __ ] got it
they're saying triangle side on my
yep he spawned again over there
i got them
all right i got them both unsolvable
triangle are still mine's still not open
yeah there's still one on the left side
are taken
yeah wait oh he's right there he fought
him yeah
somebody's go there and help him
i'm running out now
over here
there's one more stuff
yeah but they're shooting that pillar
i'm going to go
it's crazy about me right now
reload this rocket
how did i die
because when they throw the purple [ __ ]
instant kills
tower backward f all right
i had earth snake
all right i see tower on mine
okay
i got snake
and i got earth it's mine is backwards
there
it's uh
logo yes
i got tower upside down umbrella witch
queen tower oryx
freeze flowers he needs to do his first
here's my
where is everybody space oh my god
i shot mine twice
you have to simultaneously shoot it not
like separately each from one side
just like pick the just pick the one
like just pick the one it is don't worry
about shooting your cymbals just get to
a side and then just shoot it all at the
same time
but you can't you can't do that because
it only it unlocks it and levels it
doesn't unlock it all at once
some hunger game [ __ ] going on man
you're right there we just got to get
that part out i think once you decide i
think it's just once you decide which
one it is like and it has all the
symbols that you need but it rotates it
the moment you don't do it it rotates it
again is you don't need to shoot the
symbol you just need to know that it is
the totem
so it's simpler again it's not like you
need to shoot if we knew it was there
right right so
then just i think all we needed to do
there was just simultaneously shoot it
from the three sides that's it
like on the level that it is so if it
gets to level three like you did on that
level
on all three sides
okay circle side circle side okay
it might be in the back i see him
get ready for room call out
all right he's dead
first room is uh red square
right square okay i'm going up the room
[Music]
a circle on my totem
i think i got one
all right so that means ready for call
uh
no it still says circle
another one probably over here i think
there's one more i think another one i
think another one popped up over here
[Music]
okay it's ready now
all right
hole in chest
that's over next to you attic
whole interest i already did one all
right i'll get i got it i got it mine's
oryx and taking essence yeah my mind
it's not on this one
it's here it's this side this side forte
side
what's on fourteen side the the pill is
on there it's the only one that had mine
or both of mine
yeah but does it have everybody else's
stuff it doesn't matter it's long i can
see mine
if mine's both on there it's it's that's
the only one that has both of them
[Music]
all right i got two umbrellas
and
flowers
that died what's the last where's the
next one that i don't know there's an
unstoppable on that side
where's the last one that we get the
last one we gotta go in
yeah the heart one because i guess sin
didn't get it done i i don't know
no you don't want to call it out the
last one
we no we called them all out
no you didn't you only called i went
through one you went through one and
then
oh well i i mean carl called ours out
that's the one that said that's the one
that sin took that's what i'm saying
like i was saying we called ours out it
wasn't us
she knows what signing it is i don't
yeah so the one on sinister's plate
didn't get caught out
that's because i was inside of uh no
well i'm saying will didn't call it out
that's what i'm saying
oh he had what is happening
oh no just give me something
this pillar
i thought we were on i actually thought
we were past that part
no
gotta you gotta if you don't hear you if
you don't call out your pillar you know
you ain't done yet because everybody's
gotta call out a pillar
it's meant for everybody to have to call
at least one side now come on shout out
okay where's the taken
circle okay is up here i got him
okay
take it
there's a taken yeah oh okay
sorry
i hear him back here
he's hiding oh my god he's really hot
all right now what does it say cod
all right hold on i'm stoppable i'm
dealing with a stop right now
oh [ __ ]
yeah i'm going
[Music]
somebody got to open the door
it's not ours
it's on circle side it says
the taking is
can anybody come help me with the taking
guy
circle side
yes it's in the back over here
i can't see it
the what's the one ella like the sun
with the arms everybody taking things up
oh
and the [ __ ] it stopped
i'm cutting across now
you gotta open the door open the door
i'm trying sorry
okay
there you go
i'm starting back and forth man yo what
is [ __ ] funny
here get back
[ __ ] randomly spawning people
wouldn't throw [ __ ] on you got a chance
this is ridiculous
all right i have flower
flower flowering tower
i'm coming out
my eyes isn't on this
yeah it's probably on mine i see mine on
mine there's two online
what are you
why are you snake
where's the ass
is that a reset
yes
yeah
yeah you gotta do it quickly
this is the last one whose is it
i've already shot mine
you have to do it again i think
okay i'm shooting it
yeah every time that it resets it
it starts a new person
no it just wipes what you've already
shot i'm pretty sure
because it rejects your offer and then
you have to redo your symbols
don't you have to do them all at the
same time too
no
time period you have to do it
obviously with all three and shoot them
but
the thing is well
it does it by sections
right you can't shoot that topic i'm
just reading to you what i what i'm just
reading what um
i don't know if i mean maybe you make
more
sense to you guys there are three glyphs
they correspond to
this on one of the obvious
you have to shoot all three repeatedly
at the same time
all three repeatedly at the same three
guardians on each side
of the same totem
pick your glyph count down one two three
shoot repeat
but why is if both of mine's not on the
same side
i don't think it matters you don't have
to shoot any particular one we just have
to know which one we just have to know
the totem
oh
okay we don't have to shoot
our totem we don't have to shoot your
specific uh
things i don't think
come just say i cook you some now
basically it's once again easier than i
think
okay it's on circle side it's over here
yeah he's over here he's over here
and for us it says
okay um the first one is brain
brain
i got it i open it
yeah i killed that taking my circle
yes that's how we got symbol i just want
to make sure yep
so now the tank and symbol will spawn on
the different totems
those know where the next take is to
take them is yeah i didn't see it yet me
neither
i don't know he's unstoppable over here
whoa
[Music]
yeah i already did it
one's still active on our circle yes yes
he got circles
yeah
there's a box so the second one is the
text
box whatever red box
yeah i already did it i already did a
square someone
all right so our call out will be
it's over uh try uh pyramid pyramid
okay
unstoppable
i think i saved it
anyway
red square
no i said i squared i said i can't go in
red square i didn't rinse i thought
you went into
look the only people that don't have
kills is sin so can i run
yeah sure
yeah
what am i looking for in there soon is
it just like you kill the two and then
then it spawns you gotta kill the two
big boys
they're gonna be a lot of screams
jumping at you
very good
just tell me when to go
circle side there's a baby
there's one circle if i see him
where is the other side
okay taken's curve
[Music]
red square
red square okay i'm going
open the door
just said
yeah i get that triangle from the camera
after you kill the ticket
all right red square seems to be done
okay it's on circle side it's on circle
side oh upside down um snow phone
yeah back here
yeah go back there
in there
oh sure how much you call it
okay i got to take it the guy's done
unstoppable back here yeah don't worry
about him i'll take care of him i got
the call out i got the call out here in
a second
a brain brain brain
two umbrella shifts i got bro i got
what is this thing
[Music]
there's two on this one
who are yours is
[Music]
i'm going to get frosty
man
we need you at the pillar
two unbroken ships did something it
reset it
two umbrella ships um
an obliged
two umbrella ships
all
we gotta do it faster
do they meaning
do they all have to be on one section
like yeah right you have to match no it
just has to be in one pillar like one
whole pillar it doesn't matter what
section
it doesn't matter which section so it
doesn't matter if it's top and bottom
okay you sure
it's not like the door you go into like
accounts for one of the
um
tiers
the two on one on your tier
you know no all i saw was
glad and then shooting all of their
points on one
uh obvious
right but what i mean is like say i i i
have my two symbols and there's one on
the top tier and there's one on the
bottom tier
are you sure we don't need it to be like
all on the middle tier so like i would
have like my two symbols would take up
two of the three symbols on the middle
tier you're the first person no it
doesn't have to be very simple contest
mode
contest mode has been extended for 24
more hours so they're doing it for the
first two days
also did they not beat it nobody knows
what it is there's a lot of people
having network issues so they extended
it another day oh wow that's crazy yeah
contest mode has been extended for an
additional 24 hours and will now end
monday march 7 10 a.m wow
this will get those experience network
connection issues in the vow of the
of discipline great chance to obtain the
clever emblem
got it so people but did anyone beat it
yet i'm surprised not yet nobody's beat
it yet okay all right guys you guys
ready
yeah
so we're sure that's not the way it
works right like each room accounts for
a tier the two symbols account i'm just
i don't know what you mean by tear like
okay so here tier of cake
yeah like so on the obelisk there's like
the bottom three symbols that go around
then there's the middle three then
there's the top
okay so what i'm thinking is that you
look
for your two symbols on one of the tiers
depending on what room you go into so
but you're the first room if you go into
the first room then that means you're
you're the bottom so your two symbols
will be will be somewhere on this
section right here on the bottom tier
and then if you're the second room you
go into your two symbols should try to
should be in the middle and then the
last door the two symbols should be on
the top and like so that's you so you
look at the pillar so basically you look
for a pillar that has
your two symbols on the top
then i look for a pillar that has my two
symbols on the mid and then the guy on
the bottom and if it's the right pillar
they will all be on them in that section
but when when you mess up they are
randomly change them all again
well don't that's what i said you don't
mess up but my point is is if it was
that way
then when they randomly changed them
they would just change them in a
different order they wouldn't change
them like one goes on this side like i
don't i don't i think i think they do
i think they do just rotate around
no they don't i've seen multiple times
they might get flipped on in in the
entire side i'll have like it on the
bottom one time and then the next time
you get shipped around the top of the
next thing
hey the less i gotta do the better
yeah that's what i'm saying i'm rooting
for you guys
good luck i'm bored
all right where's the taking on it
should be on one of the
not showing online yet
oh i just heard it click
i got one over here
mine's on this
triangle you got that taken on the
triangle
uh no it's on on this side it's over
here somewhere
we're still missing okay it's a praying
man praying man
all right praying man
that's to the left just to your left
yeah framing yep right here
on our right all right
i hate is it taken i hear him
i'm down yeah he's on triangle
oh he's got these side guys
what is this like
oh cup of soup looks like a cup of soup
what is this thing
uh
i don't
weird man i know it's so confusing to
discuss
that's part of the shock the challenge
of the raid
is someone gonna pick up sin
yeah yeah i ran out of my token so let
me get them
what's what's the third one
um
red hands red hands
bowling chests
hole in chest is it red hands or hole in
chest
right now red hands okay
i'm going right hands i'll get hold of
chest i'll get hold of jess oh that's
too late too late
yeah i went over there died
telling you man we should just do it one
two three that way there's never a
confusion on what's doing what
what you mean one two three
one of us we do it in an order because i
i feel like we're getting it confused we
don't know who's doing what i i didn't
know who was going in red like i feel
like if we do one two three we'll always
be able to know who's going to what
well go ahead it don't matter to me
nobody said we nobody said nobody was
wrong i'm just i didn't say that
no just this however you want to do it
doesn't matter me
what's
so what's one two three that means
the the people who go in we do it in a
certain order instead of just what's
closer to who
okay so it would just like go like me
wilm or forte or forte me and well
i'll just go first i'll go first every
time i'll go second i'll go first i
don't know what the hell you call that
like symbol i saw in there i'm still
trying to figure out what you call
that s
it was like an s but like you see like
that's what it should be just squares
just give us colors
what is this what is this
are you guys ready
no
the leviathan raids where it was circle
triangle square yeah but on the days we
were just a little cup wolf
guy
god body challenge i'm praying man
challenge praying relax heart
on the left side in the winter all right
i'm ready
i'll go through the first door whatever
one it is downward hands
hive hands
all right i'm starting
how did i not get developed like come on
game
trying
where is he triangle side
i'm going to check now
and the first taken is dead
all right first one is [ __ ] uh is the
pyramid forte pyramid
all right he's right next to me
all right circle side isn't taken
let's find them
it's over by me i'm just gonna
see what i'm getting done with
okay the symbol is
dead
okay well apparently they're taken
didn't die
where do i have to go
not yet
i'm two
fourteen what's the symbol on that
uh blob and um
uh whole inches
pulling chest okay
i got it
oh my god
oh man i'm
tilting it down
i don't mind doing it it's just that was
a series of unfortunate events
yeah well they just randomly spawned
them all on you
oh yeah oh no i knew where he was it's
just he wouldn't stun
well sometimes that happens
often like i shoot him three times and
he doesn't doesn't get stunned so i
don't know that's the best
that happened
all right there's still a
rainbow
i'm still down
just white there's too many people dead
just white i got him
gonna wipe us anywhere
[Music]
let me see here
i'm gonna put on stylish executioner
hey
wait hold on before we start i just want
to yeah it wouldn't have just
just beat it oh they just oh dad it was
for us first i don't know yet we'll find
out
i think they are worse first
oh that's for him that's big
wait what does it say dude let me see
oh they'd be second place oh my god
somebody just beat it five minutes ago
damn
yo he is forever second who was it
unknown
i'm trying to see if they said who beat
it
yeah that'll just beat it
the bungee team
[Laughter]
just do it
[Music]
ah
[Music]
all right you guys ready
i just beat it candy crush
is it bedtime yet
the bungee tweed or something
[Music]
out of the game area
that's it
disqualified
what is it taking back here
yeah it's i'm trying to say yeah
[Music]
i heard something over here yeah it's
definitely i'll get them
all right room's clear another taken
over here all right uh
hands i'm going for them right now
right hands
red hands is near us yeah turn it turn
it
switch
shot it
this is the latest run so far
oh [ __ ] stomp noble's out
and he won't stun
oh my god we got another unstoppable
over here
if you have this down he's down hey yo
trust me i do use it
i shot a rocket at you
my side yeah
he said this is a good run we're not
[ __ ] into them
all right i don't see any on our side
circle
circle taken circle
so i'm looking for him
i see him
i hit a wall
if he's over by me
i killed myself
all right it's it's on this side it's on
this side everyone come to me
wait wait we haven't done uh knife and
heart
knife and heart life in heart where is
that it's right here it's right here on
the right on the right
open up the door open up the door
door open
the door
oh man
i'm going in [ __ ] it it is open
look at the revives
that's a web anyway
it awaits our offering but i think it
just took too long to go into that last
one
man i had enough time to go and check
all three pillars before no one went to
the red room that we got to do better
do people lie about
no they don't lie about it it's just
they gotta check to make sure there was
no exploits anybody didn't crazy because
they're gonna grab a energy drink
bungee's not watching every stream
individually
two seconds just gonna yeah
[Music]
oh my god
i'm starting to wear down
mm-hmm
we've been going like seven hours
straight
i'm back
all right everyone here
okay
where are you there
yep all right we're starting it
did you rally
yes
well enemy's starting to float up
oh well
all right where's the taking guy look
located at looking to probably things
we're in the triangle part
that's where ours is turned
out
somebody got 14
yeah i got one
how
all right that one's down triangle
it's uh
the spaceship thing
whatever it's called uh you guys like
premiere with your lifetime circle too
yeah is that is that one or two
fourteen have you done one
no i have not yet
what is it it's a pyramid
yes oh my god
yeah it's crazy
i don't have a rest token
i'll get him
there's a taken on circle side
okay red square red square red square
i'm going
open the door okay there we go
should be open
it's open now
you're on the lookout for overload
hold her chest
that's on the left side he's taking
actions
all through chest
is anyone going there anybody said
sinister
not me i'm not a woman
thank you very much
do we have time
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah once you kill them it should
reset
it's this one the one sends on it's the
only one that took both minor air
okay y'all got this
with the ghost above them
and with the ghost above them yeah okay
it looks like it looks like a s with
like a black red
snake taking us
taking us at the top
we just shoot them all that's what
i don't think mine's on here shoot them
all
i don't think mine's not good
yeah
oh it is
gotta find it quicker
i did find it it wasn't me
you said who was saying that there
wasn't one there he said it at the end
that he found it yeah but when you said
you found it it was it already turned
red
oh
don't do i have to shoot it specifically
me
i mean you're the only one that knows it
you know that knows what they are i i
said what it was
or snake snake well see the thing is you
can i show you what the symbol is just
so you can tell me what you guys are
calling it i don't know it's the ghost
that one i found the snake yeah it's a
snake the weird white snake
no
what is it would you look at this show
you it won't
it won't pop on without you killing the
things i don't think
i'm just just trying to lose weight
so we have the correct quality
but i can't find it here that's the
thing i can't find it on the wall it
only sho it only shows on the pillar
yeah that's so confusing like i don't
know
it's like it's like
it's a red s
the kind of yeah like a red and white
that's we've been calling it snake right
ass i just call that snake
okay all right
i hope that's what it is
i hope it's a snake
it's a sneaky
[Music]
all right where's he taking that
let's see
it's not on our goals
okay
[Music]
first call out is brains
brains okay that's you
[Music]
okay triangle side is where the taken is
triangle side is where the taken is so
on your side
i killed him
okay
man praying man praying man praying
more like praising but yeah wow
want me to go because i'm right here
no i'm i'm i'm already there
open the door
will you get him up before it's if you
pick me up i can still i can still kill
him in there
we need to like really get on them taken
i caught the tank is the issue for me i
see every time i see them call them out
when they're on my side yeah i mean
they're
they're only on the right side of us or
in front of us or like on the back of
that building like we're getting them
pretty much the moment
behind that building like three times
well i mean just because you just
because you was gonna kill him don't
mean that we weren't about to kill him
yeah usually if i don't see him in the
middle or
bother with it i just call out where it
is
[Music]
hope for the best i guess
you guys ready
[ __ ] i [ __ ] up
triangle
i think he's back here
he's back here
oh you
keep shifting
cup
cup
the cup head okay
triangle side
another taken triangle side
to take it out with the cup
right pyramid pyramid
okay i'm going i'm going to go
there's a taken behind there too for
today
i stuff him with a rocket
stoppable
no i'm locked okay go
i have to open it again hold on
i'm coming cause i'm coming
yeah it's crazy
this is nuts
oh my god
i killed two unstoppables in like
or no it's not this one what is it not
this one okay
it's holding like uh yep i'll see you
about guy with the fire jake he's here
it's this is like a leaf in one hand and
something else yeah the other and the
other no this isn't it i don't have
scorn so the scoring symbol is not there
scoring symbols over here it's up there
it's on top on the left
oh it's on top
top level
but
odd one out or the two that you have
we're shooting the two that we have
okay
would it be the three odd ones out like
shoot them simultaneously or am i just
that's what i thought
yeah that's what i'm doing yeah that's
what i thought too
so what would you just have to shoot one
symbol each
simultaneously or close shoot the three
that we don't have
instead of this instead of the
six that we do have shoot the three that
we don't and all of us have to shoot
those at the same just no just three
people at the same time okay and one one
will probably be on each side i'm gonna
bit
i mean my thing is though is literally
everyone
is doing it that way and we want to do a
completely different way like
everybody's doing it
yeah i've seen people shoot two at a
time when they go up there
let me look at something let me look at
someone i was just making it just look
double check because we we've got the
encounter we're just failing that part
yeah everybody
is god go take it
everybody at this point
we definitely have the encounters beat
we're just whatever we're doing
sequencing right yeah
we can't beat it
you
we just got to clean up the symbol
thing to finish the encounter that's a
little good
all right so let me see here
right
[Music]
otherwise
is
it's on our side
that's what it looks like i just looked
at it again they call it out too and
then they shot that loving witness
each person shoots too
i'm just seeing the perspective of the
person that's doing it
and he shoots two different symbols
okay
and then we're on different sides too
um
oh i know what we're [ __ ] up on
they're putting mad rounds into these
they're not just shooting at once
they're shooting it like a whole clip
into them they got a health bar
so esoteric and his team he had the um
purple or the pink flower or whatever it
is
and
they all around it
and
esoteric shoots his pink flower
yeah so they all just shot one on each
side they shot one symbol on each side
and then it said it accepted their
offering and then they repeated i don't
know how they get that one symbol but he
only shot the pink flower well they're
probably
there's six of them they're probably all
shooting just one
no it was just three of them that went
into the rooms
went into the rooms
yeah that when you go into the room with
the corresponding whatever like hold on
then
i'll try and explain it the best way
that i can he had pink flower he was
looking forward on a thing
at the end
okay yeah so esoteric shoots the pink
flowers
yep they've all shot one on each side at
the same time
it was just one symbol it wasn't two or
three
of them like they it looks like they're
i've seen guys only killing one guy in
the room and just taking whatever simple
forms for that one that one
not the other okay so that's probably
where the one symbol came from then
because there was still another um solar
guy in there shooting at
and while he got the pink flower one
right so why are they doing that
i don't know but it worked for them at
the bottom it says
an obelisk occupy or accept your
offering
hello hello so maybe you only have to
take out one solar dude
and then take that one symbol and then
find the obelisk with your symbol and
their symbol on it and then you guys
shoot that one symbol at the same time
i'm back repeat all like what you said
i i don't know
why they have two down there then
i don't know maybe it's just whichever
one you can kill first get the symbol
run out
okay just so long
okay he's about to go into his room
okay i get it um so when your obelisk
fills up with the three symbols so you
have
the side where the taken is you have the
door you have to go into and at the
bottom there's either a um rainbow
compass or there's a plane compass
whichever one is at the bottom of your
obelisk you kill that guy
and then you take that symbol and find
it on an obelisk and then shoot
all
right
they're only shooting one he's only
killing one
one of the things so everybody looks
like they're only killing one
and they're ju and it doesn't matter
where they are on the obelisk just three
of them have to be on there and they're
just shooting those three
yeah
though is at the bottom of your obelisk
before you go into the room there will
either be a rainbow compass or a compass
that's just white and black
and whichever side
one of the enemies are you just have to
kill the enemy on the side where your
obelisk is and then you know take that
symbol
you know what i mean
no i'm confused or no
yo you're saying on the bottom of your
thing
yeah yeah so there's the side where the
taking is it's either going to be a
circle or a triangle then there's going
to be a door that you need to go into
and then add the third on the bottom of
this i don't know if you guys can see me
on the map oh you got to take the empty
yes
from the side
so if you walk into those rooms every
room has those emblems one on the left
wall one on the right wall right kill
like so say if you have a triangle up
here and then it's the ship right there
and then it's a rainbow compass on the
bottom when you go into this room
you're gonna get on the side where the
rainbow compass is kill that guy take
that symbol
and then when it's finally time to you
know shoot this yeah yeah each of you
are gonna find your symbol
one person shoots their symbol and then
one person will have a symbol over here
and then a symbol over here and you all
shoot them at the same time and they
can't all be on the same side right
no it's something on all three different
sides at least one on each side yes and
then you repeat that it looks like three
times
okay it looks like three times you have
to repeat i don't know something had to
be instead of someone because i think
someone said that that just says it's
pleated i knew i had that that had
something to do with it i knew me
i thought it was when it completed once
you kill the taken
it tells you where to go
it says compass yeah what's your school
yeah but that company that's basically
the compass that let you know what side
in that room so it's like it tells you
what room to do it in but what side you
need to kill
so for me defending though i still do my
normal call-outs with the normal yeah
okay that's so much that's so much
clearer dude i'm happy i watched the
video okay
me
i wasn't ready i didn't know where you
saw it
okay triangle side
there's a taken over here
yeah
all right gonna be cuffed this cup and
what side do i have to heal
it should say it at the bottom
it doesn't it doesn't tell me yeah
you gotta wait until you kill them you
might have to go i think you have to go
in there and then somebody has to look
for you no i have to kill the taken
first uh
what side that is
all right i got the rainbow side
open the door
oh [ __ ] don't stop those up let me get
up
doors open what side is it on
i just killed the taken on the side so i
don't know uh brain brain
okay the brain door is open already
who's going to brain me i'm going
i i need to know what's which side
what side does he need to kill
i don't know it'll be the very bottom
one called
oh rainbow will rainbow will bring
mine's arms down
red flowers on our pillar
flowers okay
i'm looking for arms down
arms down
is all of them on this
we need a third oh shoot
earth is here it's on this side yeah i
got it ready go let's go get ready
guys you gotta count it man
yeah you're gonna do it at the same time
all right earth is on this side
i'm looking for it all right three two
one shoot it
yeah there we go
[Music]
him nothing on the radar all right
i'm coming
all right he's dead
all right i'm going to read out the
symbol here in a second i think there's
one in the back there sitting somewhere
i'm symbolized with your heart dagger
through heart all right i'm going in
open the door open the door
i'm trying
you're fine man he's in the back we're
causing i got him
all right i got my eyes
your [ __ ] all right watch your obliques
guys what's the next one
yep uh we're getting there we're getting
there open the door oh the door's open
all right upside down uh snow cone snow
cone
i'm going for it you're going for it
yeah
oh no will you go for that you're
already there okay need help unstoppable
[Music]
yeah we can do just darker light
yeah rainbow
another one called
second unstoppable
face guys i have no heavy
i have no heavy
what
triangle
works his face where's everybody else's
i got tower online okay a tower
mine is not on this one
taken by me take it by me good [ __ ]
oryx's face is on this one what's
everybody else's
all right
i got the one that looks like the tower
oh my god it looks like a tower thank
you dude
all right i'm going to arms
whenever you get a chance call tell me
what that bottom was
all right well
shucking check in
the hands
on the thing no the bottom one down but
what's below what's before the ball is
the the black
sudden looking thing okay dark dark
black and white black and white black
and white something here
is on that one
on this one
yeah i see i have worked his face
mine's scoring
okay there we go look for it look for it
you guys got this
i got my eyes on this one
okay that's gotta be it then scoring
mine's on this one all right
count three two
one
rejects rejects
rotate rotate find it
okay three two one go
nice good [ __ ] good [ __ ] yo when i'm
getting overrun i need help
don't use a weapon with explosive rounds
on it it might register other ones
kind of like the um
wish oh that's probably what happened
that's probably what happened
there
yeah it's just like the witch thing and
um yeah
good call
got no heavy bro they have been cheating
all right i got you for attack fine i
got you jesus i'm trying to give me four
on the side all right
i'm gonna get
here come back here cog
hold on
try to get big
all right back here to my shield
cool
come on game you stupid controller this
guy is like i see him i see you
little help he wouldn't do the stupid
finisher
oh i hate it
forte you're right you're right i'm
sorry i was just trying to get it yo yo
there's a take it over here just take it
over here just take it over here
i need you to finish him off take him
out go get him
okay i got it
sorry forte
yo
yeah it was yeah
it was left we might just want to just
go to whatever we're closest to i mean
does it really matter what are we going
now that we know how it works and we
only have to get like one how about you
just go
to your pillar the one that you're
scheduled at that way there's no
like questions which one you go to like
i could cover all three on this side of
the map
and you guys can cover all three
three yeah let me excuse me
and if you just happen not to have one
one person from another pillar just
comes over and gets it if you get two
right like i have snow cone and praise
guy
put this way in front of me priority
goes to the like priority go to the
person that is on that one already if
another one pops up
then it goes to the next person in line
all right if i say two pop up in one
section then the next person gets down
okay you guys ready
yeah yeah i'm ready
yeah let's get this [ __ ] you know what
let's go
okay circle side
all right
i think i see he's up here
i got him up here
okay i got the enemies
all right take us down okay the symbol
is
pulling chest hole in chest that's you
attic
oh we have to find the taken
all right open it to get what side he
goes to
open it
you see it i can't really i don't see
one over here i'm opening it and i'm
opening it
okay and you're going to want to go to
black or dark side dark side
saying i'm so sorry
stupid
red square red square down [ __ ]
red square i'll take that one because
that's the first one
[ __ ] spoil the thing right when i'm
killing the taking they're [ __ ]
unstoppable
oh they're fighting each other red
square is i don't know they gotta
get in there
i'm in there i'm in here
i shot him three times and he didn't get
stuck
and it taken to take it as a white can
take it still off by my body i see it
right now
weird i got my eyes
i got mine too
i don't i haven't had a call out yet oh
i don't got a coin
oh
carl do you have one to get me
i could pick you up i shouldn't yeah i
have one i can get them
all right i don't know there's current
midship
they have it's pyramid yeah
yeah pyramid ship
uh whoever who's taking will come get
this one over here
all right i have it unstoppable over
here so yeah we do too we do too
i'm pretty sure everyone has one
everyone yeah they might fight for the
light
all right is the door open yeah it's
i don't think so
open the door for him
use your super when you get into the
night kill it quick yeah i don't have a
super but i have a galley what is it
hold on uh it is i'm down it's
uh
uh dark sun
yeah i think that might be a wipe anyway
i think we yeah barely have any wrist
tokens left
yeah getting messy with the token
i think all right it awaits our offering
let's just do it real quick mines is on
this one right here i got the umbrellas
my mind's on this one
[Music]
not yet
i'm looking for mines again i got mine i
got my
three two one two one go
got it got it
back to position okay
we can't die
i think we should wipe just i just
wanted to make sure that we had it just
white because
these are always the ones that succeed
oh that's true
yeah yeah just wipe off
though pull it out
oh
like
oh xbox air is having phil spencer on
next week
oh wow that's huge
oh [ __ ] shout out to obm
that's huge
all right we got this guys
[ __ ]
zero deaths zero deaths
i'm calling out for help i need it
i'm not lying
i can't believe it took eight hours to
figure this out
it's early it's only nine o'clock oh my
god
this is pretty early
relatively speaking
at least try to get as far as we
possibly can
oh my god
there'll be a squishy as a warlock
if you defend i want to see you handle
my job
okay i love trying to decide let's talk
about the triangle side
over here
oh
through heart
triangle side through the heart
check first taken
that means stake to heart is over here
next to me
yeah it's that me or is that you no no
it's right here
that's 14.
i already got one but i'll tell you guys
[Music]
somewhere i'll tell you what it is what
is this one what is the side
uh it is
it's dark
i got him in the back
got him
nice good galley
all right i need i need will remember
this one it's the blob one that's the
one that looks like taking blob
you think of love is it blue
oh oh my god yeah it's the green
envelope with like the little blob in
the middle of it
upside down snow cone upside down snow
cone all right attic is down and now i
am down
all right i'm coming out oh he got you
guys
and i will tell you once you get down
there
black and white
you got that red over there
i don't have it i don't have it
i got
all right it's uh snakes
i guess
steaks okay i'll get that one
it's like red and it's like yellow with
red
it's like a yellowish red color
such a weird symbol i don't even know
how you could
what it even looks like
all right this one
i'm looking at this one
so snakes right
yeah this one does not this one has it
this one has it
this one up here
on this one
yeah i almost all right get on your
sides mine is my okay i got one on this
one
is mine over here i don't see it
mize isn't on this one then it's up here
so it's this one back here in the back
back here in the back
all right y'all got one more of those
last
yeah it is a snake it is a snake it is a
[ __ ] snake
what's that kept seeing snakes the red
one i i couldn't get a good look at it
like it looks just like it just looks
like these two halves of a circle like a
red a yellow one and a black one and
then like a red background like i
couldn't tell what the hell i'm looking
at i think your mind's just trying to
see something that's not there
i'm just seeing the color of it i'm not
seeing the design in it because it's so
[ __ ] small
all right guys we got to just make it a
circle bungie
i'm gonna have to switch to a sword to
help with ads how much i have to
we're going to have to be cracked
we just need one good run wake up
everybody wake up tie your shoelaces
guys right
here we go
i'm [ __ ] cracked
you already know
you know oh he spit bars now
this is it i see the taking up here
[ __ ] cracked i'm gonna go
the upstate new york is coming out of it
okay all right so we got fire square
knife through heart
square is open
that's you attic square not square okay
just right next to this one he's got a
knife through heart
forte that's supposed to be you i got it
okay
all right
black side black side black slide okay
open the door open the door
i knew that was gonna be a [ __ ]
all right so you have
you have rainbow
oh
the boy is out
unstoppable
okay second
there you go
i got you bro no worries
well did you go to one yet no i haven't
been told
run that's why i said call out today
they're not calling out your [ __ ]
last one
where is it
i'm about to run around and check
so i said just do the one your pillars
on
all this confusion
the circle the circle y'all looking for
the taking we already did this pyramid
go to pyramid will
experiment okay
you know what yeah we could just do okay
it's it's like
i just think do whatever you're closest
to we've been doing that literally we
just messed up because of that pyramid
wasn't on my side
oh but it's not always on your side
that's right it's not like that's what i
said if you do your pill you'll never
[ __ ] up because it's your pillow like
so we just each assigned one pillar to
each individual here
the stuff that shows up
in front of us
that's what you're doing uh yeah so so
which one do you want to take then since
just do the one that you're you're
you're behind you're in front of look at
this well well there's three that we're
in front of them come here no no no no
no no come here come here yeah yeah well
whatever this shows that's you yes
oh okay
okay so let's do that what we were doing
yes no we're doing that that's what
we're doing now
yeah that's what we changed into now
yeah
just stick to that i was just going with
whatever one you told me
so i was just listening yeah i was just
listening he told me to go there no the
thing is the final one wasn't called out
and i had to go to somebody else's
pull it out
yeah so just pay attention to your
pillar and go to that simple bucket
we'll do it that way that was addict's
pillar that he could try
triangle triangle side that's where the
taking is
now that i look over there alex over
there he's over here
with the blood
what are we looking at we got uh
open the door open the door
is there a taken somewhere
you gotta find it to find a monster yes
there is a taken somewhere
what's that
i need
um you need black
[Music]
i just killed the one on circle all
right dagger through heart will
it's over by me that's only there
it's underneath
yep oh my god i'm dead i'll get him
unstoppable that's my fault man
i went into this but he didn't care
forte are you almost done over there no
yeah i just yours is rainbow will your
heart just be a little unstoppable over
there we still have a circle
i understand
the door's not open over here
the chest i'm going i'm going i'm going
okay
all right open the door open the door
switch switch green symbol which i'm
going to switch
there you go change the doors all right
is it dark or light
i don't know
it's on cock's side
i'm fighting and unstoppable
okay um i'll run over there and look
two seconds two seconds addict
i'll get him too
ah
you're light you're light you're right
rainbow
rainbow addict i'm going
got it start checking the pillars guys
mine's witch queen simple if you see it
i haven't seen it yet mine's taking us
insane
let's play symbols i see it dude
i burnt out [ __ ] fire take it you
said it's all on this one next to me all
on me follow me
okay
taking essence
all right i see mine all right
i got my eyes
i got mine all right three two one gone
okay someone needs to get his rest i
don't have that one
i got him yeah i don't have one either
i got one there's a taken over here to
the right
i think
i think he's excited
never mind it's the guy that's left
below
okay where's the taking this morning
i got one over here
okay
he's dead
okay someone should have assembled all
right cup head
pup head okay top head wheel home go to
the top head
yeah go to the back front right front
right right front right
all the way
where where over here next to us over
there still has it's taken over here
attic all right okay i'll get these ads
you're gonna okay you're gonna get it
sorry
okay
thank you
all right
hands out
okay what is it
all right other ones don't uh take his
own circle i'm about to get ready to
tell him
what symbol do i have to kill guys
black and white black and white
did y'all get the praying um yeah i'm
doing it now is it dark or light
okay
i think if i think if we're going to do
it that way a person needs to who's
running
i mean less will you know where they all
are without thinking about it
no
but before before we started let's let's
let the runners just go around one time
or let will at least run around one time
just to check all the symbols just to
make sure yeah that the call-outs was
right
not saying it's wolf's fault that we
failed yeah no not just somebody please
for future
i agree oh my neck is starting to kill
me because i mean it's [ __ ] wilhelm
scream what do you [ __ ] mean
oh
but
the longer you're in this raid the more
that ghetto will be coming at you
i actually grew up in uh the carolinas
man
i love how it's all these symbols and
then just red square
i know all this complex red
one box dude
there's one back here too
i don't know man even after five hours
on this what is that room for up there
i think
i think it's just like a secret chest or
something like that because there was
another one i think you're gonna have to
put like a sequel to that
okay
that's the one you go through that's the
room you go through when you beat this
part okay you guys ready
uh
you might have been pretty sure i think
i think
yeah i did
even after being on this for five hours
man i'm still enjoying myself
i'm ready for the next encounter i ain't
going to try
ads have gotten a little bit better over
here since i switched the sword so
but the the thing is when i leave man
that's the uh it feels like the moment i
leave they're like let's hit cog with
everything like this
yeah i got the take it over here
okay the symbol is
red square red square i'm opening that
door for you
all right i'm on my way
uh symbol is uh triangle
yeah uh so that's killing it's taking
our side maybe
there's not one over here all right i'm
going in like you know where the color
is when it pops up
yep i will
uh black dark dark dark
all right uh upside down k uh chocolate
thing whatever the [ __ ] it's called
circle side circle okay get ready to
tell me if it's darker uh like whenever
you get a chance oh i died
here
what's your question
i know which one it is just pick me up i
know which one it is though i killed
them
all right which one is it
what color is it hole in chest oh well
um
the third one is that a circle thing
like a is it is it darker or like a
rainbow
i'm going to tell you once you get in
it's resetting
and the black and white
black and white
second
and i'm dead
i got shot from across the map
guy with the fire above his head
oh [ __ ] oh it is unstoppable it is crazy
i see two of them on this one
oh my god i'm dead
i'll get him
all right mine is on
this once
they're called
oh my god
oh this stupid freaking ad
it always happens
you got a token for frosty yeah
you guys have a minute and 40 seconds at
least get that thing done and then you
can pick me up it doesn't matter i got
you i got you
it takes i think he's the one there
mine's on here mine's on this one
eyes on this one
mine's the guy with the crate above his
head
i don't know how it ends prematurely
like that because the last one is still
filling up
i don't know why it ended prematurely
there
this one should shoot the wrong thing or
something maybe that's a
i don't know maybe
so cog since i have the bubble and stuff
do you want to switch spots
for uh where i'm at for the ad control
because i have the bubble and the shield
my whole class is designed to uh get
over shows all the time
so what you want me to do then just go
in the room and uh kill the uh
uh the one that we need to so pretty
much it's like you go in the room and i
tell you like light or dark lights left
dark right
and then you kill the guy and then you
get a symbol and then you find that
symbol on the obelisk
so you who's gonna tell me which room
when he says get a symbol like a symbol
will appear on the ground like
[Music]
yeah a little like a hologram i mean i
could keep i can i can keep doing the
run it's fine i'll keep doing the wrong
okay yeah i'm like we switched it down
[ __ ] i never grabbed the only doesn't
matter
i'm busy rubbing my eyes
oh it's on triangle side to take it is
brought man i don't know there it is
yeah just white because nobody i didn't
grab the thingy oh nobody got anything
i mean i want some resist [ __ ] man
[Music]
um we need concussive damage badly
that joint is crazy but they throw that
flame drop on the ground
um
[Music]
so cool having a cool girlfriend man
she's letting me sit out here for
[ __ ] hours on end playing a video
game
across it you don't want a banner
oh let me grab that oh no i'm full dude
i died before i could even use anything
so i'm good
yeah i'm good
you good
forte you're the dps king you and
addicts just switch sides
looks good now that looks good hold on
that looks good
run it like that
all right you sure so you guys want me
to switch up my whole [ __ ] would you
guys mind wiping so that i can get a
different let's do this and then switch
it let's do this i got faith i got faith
right now i got faith right now this is
the run
you just don't know it yet
don't switch anything false let's just
go and then switch after this if we die
okay perfect i'm gonna keep what i have
on them
shoot forever oh my god triangle side
triangle side triangle side
did you guys find the takeout
i'm looking for him
watch it it's back here what about him
okay
we found the [ __ ]
don't see him
uh pyramid ship okay
get ready to tell me
yeah triangle side
another taken
taken on triangle side light i got him i
got him
oh damn i i got
murdered
can you get me
all right you going to double hands uh i
mean uh crazy groups right there me
right there will yup
going in there
someone see another taking anybody
thinking is that triggered
yeah it was about to be a white
because we missed it did it we missed it
no i just killed it
oh god just killed the taken um and it's
black and white it's snow cone snow
cones all the way in the front i'm not
gonna make it through there
yeah my assemble didn't even show up
it's all right
we have all three takens
they all came because um
i think so me and will was just killing
taking after taking along with our ads
i don't mind that at all man take them
all
no you can have them same spot
yeah the third time he was around the
corner towards um
attic and oh now it's 14 in cog side
yeah mine glitch the the symbol didn't
even pop up when i killed him
how we looking looking good
yeah just go and start it i think
what makes
that top part so hard is there's nowhere
to hide
what up here
i'm on them
he's dead
okay the symbol is brain brian okay
is that open right now no it doesn't
he's on triangle side now
take us down
all right it's at the upside circle
sorry i'm on my way to the pyramid
somebody you got to tell me what it is
oh my
[Music]
can someone give me like the light
rainbow circle thing all right cool
oh yeah
it seemed like that happened rather fast
yeah very fast
we're getting better at it it's the only
it's the like dying or whatever that
kind of throws it off a little bit but i
mean it is contest mode so how can you
hate somebody for dying
i can hate somebody for die
stop dying
[Music]
baby stop getting so close
you know that until i poke away messing
with you
okay
about the mate about to make cognitive
the best raider ever he already triangle
side triangle side
i'll get him over here
all right addict your symbol is
uh praying man
okay
he's in the back he's in the back there
go go go
it's going to be
dark
it's on circle
there's another taking no circle
i have to take care of this unstoppable
take care of him then bro
okay i needed to die
dog needled and died
okay i'm going for the team looking for
oryx okay what is it in here
mine's or black and white i'm dead
i looked and i died
all right take instead
all right just resetting all right i got
red square one i'm going in
all right i got flowers flowers are mine
if anybody sees a flower all right
let me know what it is when it pops up i
locked it as soon as i finished fighting
the unstoppables
all right bottom is the sun the black
sun thing i mean
thank you sir
thank you
flower flower flower
all right mines is the earth the world
oh yeah there it is i was looking at the
wrong door
i need the earth i'm looking for the one
with the earth on it one with the earth
on it
oh my god i don't know why he didn't get
you up the earth
i got earth from the one over here with
me what's the other symbols it's it's
it's the one down here because mine and
his is there mine wasn't on the one to
the right
okay
earth is here earth is here it's full
it's over too late
okay so the right obelisk is the one
that fills up quicker
then apparently because that one had
three mine only had two well no that's
because it was taking damage that's why
as soon as we find them like
everybody just pick it like try to if it
takes damage it takes damage it fills up
faster so fast okay yeah i got you yeah
i didn't factor that in
all right
look at that man
i leave from over there addicting over
there helping
i was getting this filling up i was
getting one of one of the things just
[ __ ] up listen i'm just [ __ ] be quiet
quiet man i'm just messing with you stop
stop don't get sensitive don't be so
scary guys
i'm over here over here carrying cognito
so you good
actually actually i know i need to carry
me i don't know what i'm talking about
look at this he over here making
everything disappear with that devourer
did you just snore
that was my snort laugh at you
chest hole in chest it's on me let me
know what it is cognito i'm going
downstairs
somebody open the door for me please
door please
on left side with you guys
oh take it back here okay
way back here in the back oh man he's
deep
all right oh he's moving so
i got mine we got to get this cut we got
to get this taken i'm coming
we are moving
all right
circle side there's a taken
i'll open the door
you have to go somewhere got you
uh we circle side is the taking we got
to find out oh my god man this [ __ ]
unstoppable does not stun at all man
yeah it'd be it's a very sometime-ish
don't worry about getting your hands uh
what side is it on circle circle side uh
i'm looking i don't see him
unstoppables out there
he's not back here
i checked
i don't see him over here
he's not over here then miles is on this
oh he's right ooh
he's gotta be on your side
i'm gonna die
don't die
he's nowhere near over here he's over
here i just see him on radar right now
i'm sure he's not under the stairs
nobody can't find him no i'm killing him
right now he's dead oh you are well
you're gonna have to look for yourself
because i have to run over here
you have to look at it
i'm looking i'm looking at it will
i'm surprised
because i had to go kill the taken
[Music]
it's the guy with the hand the the
things that his two hands thanks for the
two
hands
he's got like fire above his head
no it's like he has like a like a map in
his left hand and like a triangle in his
right hand
i'm looking on this one to see if it's
all here with mines
mines
where the hell did it go
all right one more shot one more chance
i got mine i found it i got it i got it
three
two
one go
wow
how did that not work
somebody didn't get the right song
it has to be really communicated
he thought he had it then he went to
another side i don't think he
will which one did you think was that
what with the hands like the it was like
a green background with he has like like
it looks like the guy has like flame
above his head like orange above his
head no
no it's not that one oh i thought it was
the same one
we looked at the same one and i thought
it was that one i guess no he has
something on his left side that looks
like he's holding a tree branch but it's
actually just the raid like
yeah looks like yeah
that's the one that's that's the one
that's that's the witness oh this is the
same one
the white beast
okay well i don't know it kind of looks
like it's not fire it's the witness
we saw it at the end of the
[ __ ] campaign you guys ready yeah i
know who the witness is
megamind what you mean
okay
nothing on ours yet
where's the taken at
taking is located triangle side
yeah
all right
over here
his body up there but
he's dead
all right you're going to the prayers
okay circle right here
double people double here yeah that's
the one
all right what do we got
we have rainbow
rainbow
there's a taken on circle side i just
don't know where
it's not on this side
it's on the top
nope that's unstoppable never mind all
right this is
praise man guy with the ghost above his
head
this is my guy i'm killing uh
arms
we gotta get this one done man because i
want the loot
so bad
oh heart
heart with the cross
he's on circle
take his own circle
tell me which one it is
um dark
i'll look for the taken right now since
there's nothing not on this one
mine is
oh my god
oh my god i killed the taken but so far
mine is only on frosty
someone pick me up okay go get some all
right hold on hold on chess
i got them okay i got them okay
nope sorry guys
it's nice to be first right yeah yeah i
like being first
so much pressure when you're last
[Music]
i am we wrote you guys i got like an
hour i'm not gonna get frustrated man
i'm not gonna get frustrated
that was still [ __ ] though
my eyes are starting to hurt
you guys ready
over here to support the man that don't
need support
i need support when i'm unstoppable come
out hit me on
uh circle side is where the taking is
he's over here i'll get him
he's dead
our symbol is
your heart
all right we'll
okay
all right all right well
i got to take it you are going to
brain go to brain okay
take his dude
what are we looking at in here
i don't know i'm dead
getting rest now
all right i'm going over here uh rainbow
rainbow rainbow will ah good i guess
right
i wasn't taking it over here too
oh no i got you i got this
struggle
tell me tell me the thing
dick
all right i got it
what is
swirly
okay give me a break from taking damage
yeah they own it
ours
i think mine's on this one too
yeah mine's on this one
on the same one
that's it alright yeah yeah the same one
as you okay
yo it is not sponsored checking this one
what is the other one like do we need
the third one
forte what's yours
i got oh mine's is the um like the
flower looking one looks like a flower
okay flowers here too flowers oh yeah
hurry hurry hurry hurry i'm here i'm
here
three
two two one shoot
go
yes good job good save
good save all right yeah make sure you
tell us that we can find it for you
whoever's in first or whoever's out
first spend that time like looking like
trying to make it when that unstoppable
come
you won't yell it because that's when
they start to spawn more people on my
back than crazy
all right where's the taking up
checking the uh getting ready
he's on triangle side triangle he's over
yeah he's over here
he's over here need some help on him
he's over there with you yeah recognize
you
all right we got him we got him we got
him okay
the next one is at
circle side all right so this is
i gotta go cup cup ahead
i can't see the take and anything yeah
cup over here step over here
checking if he's in the back all right
let me know what side he's on yeah he's
back here
you got him
yeah i got him
together
what side is the old car
oh man hold on
so there's the beef it's over
they killed me yeah it's crazy bro all
right
it's the sun it's the um the rainbow
white looking
like sun thing
rainbow just say white or black
white
just say white okay door
open door
my st my door's still not open
okay
someone needs to go to take it oh
i'm coming
do you know what side it was then
anybody
no
[Music]
you're pretty you you're you're fine
with uh killing all the um
well stunning the uh champion correct
because i haven't really yet yeah at all
that's fine man that's fine
the only trade off is maybe you going
for more of the taken as long as you're
not going into a building if you are
going into a room i'll i'll deal with
both because sometimes both of them pop
out but i can stun no problem
and most of the ad clear i'm good with
so
hi
let's finish the encounter
this
dude it's been rough but i've enjoyed
every cent of this i'm not gonna lie
like i i still would love to finish this
now like
yeah i'm thinking that once we finish
this we'll get like an invigorating
boost and we'll be like nah let's keep
going and then it'll be just like
earlier where we're like okay let's keep
going and then we get drained and we
look it up and then we're like oh let's
keep going nah look
just look it up yeah that's what i'm
saying to be real with you at this point
i kind of want that we just looking this
[ __ ] up i like i like clearly we just
want this stuff man there's already been
rate for worlds first there's no reason
they're you know
trying to get yeah all right perfect
let's get it
all right you guys ready
yeah
yeah
i want that emblem i want the loot i
want the exotic
okay triangle side is where the taken is
located
i got him
okay the symbol addict is um red hands
going down
right hand's going down
yep
i got another take on the back
open the window door open the door
all right chest through the hole in
chest coal and chest uh will what side
uh it's uh dark dark
someone uh take us on the uh
i mean circle right
i got the taken what's that
um
[Music]
you gotta let me know which one it is
when i get over there though okay
i'll try to they usually always fall on
crazy [ __ ] when you get over there all
right i have uh triangles right here all
right open up the door open up the door
open the door
if anybody sees those
got you all right what side if you can
see it oh
[ __ ] i can't see the side
it took a super anniversary
i can't do it
okay
it's a white yeah
to be honest with you i already forgot
my symbol at this point so
i am loving galloping i'm going to tell
you dalhorn saves my ass like 75 minutes
and it's
just
well it's like two shots to any
like uh like any unstoppable like it's
great for ad clear one shot's all the
guys inside the rooms
i'm gonna put on unstoppable pulse
i'm thinking about it
one shot and you can like snipe with it
you can hit the guys like
uh yeah
i mean i had a one shot with rampage it
was a pretty good roll but i don't know
i just like having more like
range on it
i need to go pick up ray banners mine
are gone
i feel like i feel like i'm mooching
all right you ready
yeah let's get it yes sir
all right so circle circle side i got it
circle
taken on circle side
yep
[Music]
chest all right i'm looking for this guy
okay taking guys taken care of
all right it's resetting
all right i'm going into red box
black circle something just say black or
white black all right i'll just say
black and white that's the last thing
okay
guy with the thing [ __ ] unstoppables out
and shuffles out all right i'm coming
like somebody open the door somebody
open the door my guy's the witness
anybody sees the witness
oh unstoppable unstoppable
i got him
i just finally
i do not have anything significant to
[ __ ] him up though oh my i got killed by
random black people i got you i got you
[ __ ] guys
here we go
okay this symbol is guy praying see i'm
going
gotta do this quick
of course i die open the door
i want to slam [ __ ] dark dark
sorry
i don't have a pickup my side was done
but i went to go kill a cake and came
back and then like everything was on my
face
yeah just wipe
a lot
all right the ads from outside's coming
in because half the team's dead
all right forte we got this [ __ ]
because poultry wanted too bad man
that's just
not great either
major speck on that
do champions count as majors or boss
i think
okay
i don't know that might come as a boss
one would think a boss would be like an
actual like raid boss
usually boston's have a name
okay
man that one time we got to the third
the when we found out we knew how to do
this we got to the third time on the
first attempt
yeah and ever since man it's been like
that
because that was on the ragged edge
are you guys ready for that ragged edge
slap yeah in the face
let's wake the [ __ ] up
uh sorry for swearing i forgot you guys
were streaming
appreciate it we passed back
okay it's going to be on triangle side
fake it's over here fourteen
all right
is
[Music]
what size it on
i got thick
light
ensembles out all right you're going a
pyramid ship
okay
i'm back
we're getting the taken right now
taken is done what are we looking at in
there
you win
yep
oh the fire killed me before i could get
my shield up
all right let me know what side cockney
don't feel that show
yep it was dark dark side
all right i got the ink blot thing all
right i got the eighth block
all right look for your [ __ ] how do you
have the ink blot mine's blue with a
black dot and it can't be the same thing
i don't think oh it is it's this one hey
hey to your right unstoppable like a
weird blue like this door is locked by
the way
which one are you with
is the door unlocked for you no it isn't
oh my god i'm sorry mine's the earth
okay you're you're good you're good
yeah mine's on this one
oh my god i feel it in my bones
triangle side
wow
they [ __ ]
up here
taking dead
all right going to check for you all
right downwards hands right here to our
right
right there okay okay it's going to be
on circle side addict we need to kill
the tape wherever it is
somebody open that door please
hopefully he's not here got it
okay it's open
is he on the left side of the the place
you need
yeah i think he's on the left side
all right mine's a dark circle
good
no i'm talking to him
color
this shit's up just a second just a
second uh dark dark dark
all right
i got the hole to the ground holding the
guy
somebody opened up the door somebody
opened the door open the door open the
door mine is
wait hold on i just killed it mine's
just the white green bright green and
red
with the mouth yeah yeah okay okay yeah
his is his is on the right right here
white green and red don't come here all
right ready
wait wait you gotta wait till i get
there i'm not there yet okay
they're gonna kill me
hit the wrong thing
there we go
all right ready no i'm not ready dude's
chasing me
all right three
two
one shoot
nice one more
one more good save
dude this this this music's pretty epic
i ain't gonna lie yeah please list the
call-outs and when the what you call it
comes
i need help one day
when that dude comes
big big boy come and be on
you
yellow bar this one red bar takes more
damage than these two yellow bars
take it over here on the left i'll get
him i'll get us a triangle yep
got him okay
your symbols popping up
don't worry about adds um red hands
facing down red heads
facing down okay
it's over here
let me know if you need the door open no
it's open
okay
right light or dart
dark
where's the taken located that's gonna
[ __ ] us
no not no no no second circle side
circle side
okay dark [ __ ] he's got to be in the
back wheel i'm getting it he's right
here he's fine
okay good [ __ ] i got chips
triangle
uh
all right cool
what am i looking at here all right well
you're looking at you're going towards
[ __ ] uh black
black
oh
[Music]
i have no no no no i have one i'm going
for sinister right
if somebody gotta come for forte
i can't get one
i'll get forward today
and then the praying hand if you're
taking
the praying the praying guide to the
other guys
times
i'm running oh he got four take nice
okay we got him guys let's get it
crazy
i have the eggplant
hand to the right here ships ships we
need one more help whoever needs it done
which side consider i can't see i'm not
there yet
ships mine's ships mine ships
chips
all right just dead
nice what do you need
ships
ships i have ships
taken essence you said you had taken
essence
i got which queen which queen which
queen yes i think they're all here
yes they're all here okay come on you're
ready i'm on it all right three oh no no
no no wait wait wait all right
then there's a boss face then there's a
boss
there's the goodies up there the goodies
is up here god
that was crazy
i got the submission
i almost died so many times bro it was
deliverance
submission i got submission um
help based on the number of hits
before we oh look how the gun looked yo
put on yo put on look at it
in the item screen look like
equip it and look at the thing you'll
see like it's shaking and shifting
yeah look at this
yeah oh so that that's our official
first pyramid weapon
it's a pyramid weapon
yeah i got it all right now you don't
see me
crazy i got a fusion rifle
would
[Music]
oh
you
you in pointless directions towards
pointless goals
okay come this there's a hole over here
in the wall
that might just be it i mean hey what
about that secret room in the last room
should we go in there now see if it
doesn't hurt oh yeah let's go check that
out maybe it'll maybe when we shoot the
wall it'll give us some more goodies man
my hands yeah i don't really know
your hands is crazy right yeah
dude my hand's crazy i i when you when
when the when what's his name he's like
we're done no one's gonna say
rest comes i got one don't quit looks
like bro i thought it was awesome oh no
i had a red coin
[Laughter]
you know you know you know you know else
you know what else i i panicked when one
was like shoot i was like no no no no
like
all right go back you got to do the
whole counter
you messed up so we pushed you back
somewhere so let's look for a dark soul
i bet you we do these encounters and it
tells us the uh combination to get in
the bathrooms in the combination room at
the beginning remember
so we know the first one's a dark
well no anybody remember the original
circle circle when you shoot them they
rotate
well this one's open over here pyramid
is
all right someone look it up because i
don't have the mental capacity
i don't have the mental capacity to try
it anymore
okay um
you know what you know what is funny
though when we do this like uh when we
do this by yourself it's gonna be mad
simple because like
the only issue is that we was getting
killed like that's the only issue bro
they lashed us so hard with the contest
that's really what it is to frustrate
you for getting the mechanics done
that's the i will say
i will say that until this [ __ ] is over
i want that [ __ ] emblem
i will i will say that i i am i am proud
of this of this titan build like cog i
was constantly getting like i have it to
where if i put up my my shield and kill
one person i get it and i have it to
where if i kill some of my my uh my
shield smash i get because i have a uh
don't come in here you'll have
nightmares
i want to see oh
[Music]
throne world right now
oh here we go oh wow look at this
i bet you now we're gonna check yeah
right here forte yeah cool how'd you get
through where the hell did
[Music]
man no no we we beat we beat the first
encounter we didn't beat the race first
two encounters that was the second
first scanner was the boat oh my god
been streaming for like 10 hours uh
there's a big guy here and he's looking
at me now uh what's he doing
there's a thing on the wall over here oh
what is he what is this
look at this dude oh i'm coming over
there he just looked at me and then can
you get up close to him without starting
the encounter yeah
oh what the hell he just looked at me
when i came out remember that there was
a circle yeah i got you
is that an ogre
uh it's a taken
oh
i bet you have to shoot him to start it
yeah he look like he starts it do we
have to chase him up these stairs
that would be fun yeah we need to send
them out
all right all right someone look up the
encounter you shut the door
sad bethune shut the door she's like
gotcha [ __ ]
imagine all the kids we just walked
through were just decorative
do not disturb the characters
oh there's the ray banner right here
right
yeah here's the ray banner right by me
just it started it's up here somewhere
right call me i'm gonna go up the steps
ah okay oh you gotta go to you gotta go
to the natural history museum so those
two rooms didn't mean anything they must
be for like secrets
i can't even get in
oh you they close the door you're
wearing a full running chest
oh look look this [ __ ] you
oh you gotta pick up the artifact things
again remember from the start
we kept getting pervading darkness
the yellow would probably think yeah the
yellow thing
i can't see where the [ __ ] i'm going all
right so who's gonna look it up
i need a piss who is looking this up
so let's say it's winning
somebody rock with us for 10 hours and
but it was cheering us when we passed
that part just now
let's go lord
yo you was in the big shout out to man
we're gonna have to shout you out in the
podcast tomorrow but the fact that you
was in here this morning after all
failures and finally let's get a win
going to the next stage
hey to be fair once once we looked up uh
glide in them cheat sheet a little bit
we we passed it like 45 minutes to an
hour
uh after this it says when the counter
starts have someone watch the boss keep
boss
from reaching the middle obvious have
someone stay close to the ball so you
can shoot him in the head then in the
back if the boss reaches the middle it
interacts with the obvious you wipe make
sure you keep shooting the boss he
throws out phase one at the start of the
encounter have three people
check the obelisk select one side and
remember the symbols go into the room by
shooting the crux
which will let you know let you into the
uh into the room with the symbols on
sticks
there will be six symbols to grab three
per person while two yellow bar witches
can take it for all trying to kill you
as well as pervade uh pervading darkness
buff collecting your symbols as fast as
you can when collecting these will um
you will get a buff call overflowing
knowledge called to be called to be uh
let out of the room by your teammates
run to the obvious give it a second to
send a send a message obvious is waiting
for
xxx symbol
depending on what symbol you have
or something similar just then just um
shoot a single bullet into each symbol
you will have one chance and then you
will need to go back into the dark room
to gather them if you fail the first
time
are there only three in each room oh
wait a minute
no there was a bunch of them
all right that's just
that's how you trigger so that's how you
trigger dps phase one so
that's how you trigger the phase after
you do that once the fade what's the
symbol phase is done dps phase will
begin the boss will spawn
wells around him that you will need to
stand in to dps him once a well is used
another will will spawn you will need to
get um the dps again keep rolling tick
rotating until dps phase ends
then
phase two
go up to the stairs to start the next
part of the economy rinse and repeat
what you did in phase one
so it's two phases to it
all right just second i'll be up
i'm running to the
[Music]
face we bathroom sure we get the first
one down and then we continue this seems
like it's easier to kind of get the like
totem thing going but then the boss is
pretty bv
yeah bosses beefy and then with the dps
is gonna be
one of what weapons is probably best for
look like some people swords
really indeed rockets yeah yeah let me
switch over every season
uh
my problem gives us
since it's probably the last raid
he told me looks like elysium got it
okay whoever that is is some some client
i guess
yeah talking about beat the raid
e-l-y-s-i-u-m
elysium clarinet bro this
and the legend campaign right this one
i've had on destiny is in a while he
said they they beat uh
they beat gl uh they beat that oh by
three minutes
yo boy that yo him always lose the
second place by so little
i was hoping it would have gotten worse
i would hope he would have got it died
yeah because just because in fact he
always comes so close
yeah he was 12th with deep stone
and then every other raid is like
anywhere from two to five
second to fifth
poor guy man
yeah
you still got second though you know
what man with this bro that's impressive
that's super impressive right did you
make it in the top 100
in the first one
uh bought a glass
oh thanks
okay
back-to-back champions destiny just
tweeted a minute ago
it's a little packing no i'm just
kidding
yo
it wasn't
do they have any affiliations with
people that actually have done the play
test or
made the ring
here
should i take the guy take the credit
quick huh hey gotta take it away from me
okay i'm gonna use crate a fugue 55
sniper rifle and deathbringer i think
yeah
that's what i'm gonna use
i was gonna keep on what i had but
that won't do a lot of damage let me
i'm gonna go down here and look at the
boss man he looks [ __ ] nuts
go check them out this is using that
caretaker so i guess the data mountain
[ __ ] was true
bruh
you look so cool what the [ __ ]
that is where was that room we just went
into sin
it's all the way up top
um
how do we get up there
you're actually near it it doesn't pop
up until you start it it's left right
here
are there different rooms though i think
there's more than one yeah
yeah there's these green symbols here
too i don't know what they are they're
um
what is this
okay they probably don't have any
significance other than just laying out
this part that's a piece of the worm one
of the worm gods it's a piece of them
okay
there's also an opening
here okay so you go all the way up here
yeah there's a door here
and there's a door on the left
okay so this is definitely second phase
i feel like
or it might not be
i was trying to see if there's any
relevance to the things on top of it but
no
i try shooting these really quick and
say they do something it's gonna start
the encounter these
these two you know what's weird is this
place doesn't really have a really
like an easily accessible spot you have
to like jump up on top of something and
get up here
it's not like it's typical
yeah they wanted to make it super hard
but since this is like the 10th raid in
destiny 2 everyone's just [ __ ]
cracked
i'm above my nose real quick since we're
chilling
i think i can get up there with the heat
rising
where
above
where you're not supposed to
well we don't know a tutorial video how
to glitch into the final boss room
without doing the right thing
eventually
yeah yeah
while spring anyone was spring i saw
that video
origin tree
whoa guys come gosh
based on the number of hits
before reloading
that's crazy
it's my first day one right guys so
thank you
yeah it's so good
love you baby
i love you too man
[Laughter]
i think your
all right
look at it up there i thought there was
three doors one on top
look at it look at that
it's crazy jesus christ three doors up
here
maybe this is the cheese right here all
three doors maybe this is the chain
how do we know which door has the
correct corresponding symbols to the
obelisk though because there's like
two here there's one down there there's
three up there
can we shoot all these doors since
you're not ready
can we see what's behind will come over
here
let's go look there is more doors over
here right there yeah i want to shoot
all the doors open let's go into it
ready
yeah three
two
here take it oh wow
okay we went into the one on the second
floor nothing's happening it opened for
us
you're not supposed to get up here
hold on hurry
come back
mans are still at it
when the iop carry starting they had
over a hundred thousand dollars indeed
one two left to the poor d2 first read
five years of destiny after osiris dlc
was breaking point with which queen
brought me back no doubt dog carry oh
i want to go back up there
come with us um
let me see what y'all
a lot of climbing
a lot of climbing
trying to remember where he climbed from
yeah he did it here
and then he goes this way
and then up into this corner
i will put a rift here so you guys know
where you're jumping
okay you guys go first
i'll hop up after incognito
[Music]
yeah i don't think i was supposed to be
up here yeah
[Music]
yeah
go through the doors
there's a lot of jumping puzzles in here
too yeah a bunch of places missing
plates
and then there's something up
here yeah there's nothing of
significance in here that i can see
i mean besides some plates and like the
[ __ ] that's on the enclave thing the
relic to where you make weapons there's
a bunch of that [ __ ]
but that's it
bro this rate is so [ __ ] cool
umbral suffocation it says that's how we
died umbrella
suffocation
kills knowledge knowledge stacks the
positivity
caretakers
so the first phase is 100 where we start
because we went in there and there was
um enemies but not only that there was
also symbols we just didn't know what
was on
right
so i looked up the video i got like a
general understanding it's like kind of
like the same concept that we were doing
last time but you go in these dark rooms
to find the symbols instead of uh
i was seeing that they people are
running over the symbols
yeah you run the mode
i was seeing people were using hunters
to go in there because they can go in
yeah i can go grab symbols that thing
down there the uh gold thing is that
where you're supposed to not let him
reach yeah right below here
okay
it might have been because
inactive
yeah
i'm gonna go down here to see if it
starts it or what happens oh that's
where he is okay
so maybe that's not then
when we when it starts does he move does
he go like teleport or something because
we can't let him get somewhere
yeah he's supposed to don't let him
disrupt
i don't know where that is though
it said an obelisk so an obelisk is what
we were
[ __ ] with earlier
there's one right behind us where you
spawn oh
okay i see
okay i'm looking at uh dj they're still
on the encounter we just missed we went
through for real yeah what are they
behind us now mm-hmm
what about
cactus cactus is probably gone
he does
that's the elite right there
i think we're still doing pretty good
man especially if we get it done
all i care about anyone who gets it done
in the first 24 hours man you're you're
goaded then they
they extended it though
yeah they extend the contest mode for it
because they said all right so where are
these where are these doors oh yeah
here's the doors
you
i think we just have to worry about this
door here
all right just tell me what to do and
where to stand
all right we need to wait for um
where did
where is uh the boss forte
down below
right down here
alex i guess someone has to constantly
keep their eyes on him
and that one shoot him in the head in
the back
yeah
to do damage
i don't know how to stop him though
because they're like
stop him from getting to the obelisk
where he goes up the obelisk and then
you just do damage to him at the obelisk
oh okay
shoot him on the way up and then
okay
perfect
so the symbols are going to pop up on
the obelisk go in grab those symbols i'm
here
oh we replaced you they booted
then you just say forte leave
[Music]
i said
[Music]
mom
i just want to make sure d get the raid
done
oh my god oh my god
i remember that
let me make sure my brother get the raid
done
[Laughter]
you stupid
all right we ready to go he's in here
now
all right so who's gonna watch the boss
and who's going into the room i can go
unlock the box where is the boss
below us
he's right down there
what are we watching here before well
we're going to watch him just to see
what else he's watching for yeah
most of what you're doing is going in
the rooms and then coming out here and
shooting the corresponding [ __ ] on like
this totem okay
i think i think
i'm not
totally when i'm down here watching the
ball
pick up one over the other but
that's what i'm seeing guys doing
like
[Music]
oh man
hard to know what the hell is going on
if he was going black screen the whole
time oh
esoteric
yeah this encounter is gonna be [ __ ]
nuts man these guys
it's like a dps boss
versus like a puzzle thing
uh yeah i'm using a few
astrocrashes use this or whatever said
to use it yes
you can switch back and forth
what's the intrinsic value of umbral
recharge um while you have several
stacks of pervading darkness your class
ability recharges quicker so that's like
when you go and you
get into the dark room there and then
there's distorted glyph keeper damaging
a glyph keeper with a grenade causes
your equipped auto rifles linear fusions
scout rifles and sniper rifles to deal
additional damage
that's all i got the intrinsic i don't i
don't know what you mean
yeah that's usually that's the way
i'll check that
it'll say like orange you guys ready
what's up
all right
let me just put that because we're using
rockets now
i was going to put it on but i'm going
to keep my shoes on put my my finders on
for rockets
remember when we get to dps face the
like suppress m2 or weaken him
so we do more
all weapons will do increase damage as
well but i think void is you want me to
do suppress
any grenade that you throw at him should
suppress him as long as you're using
void 3.0
they weaken though
yeah
yeah you can have there's a park there's
a train for that
hold on
we can target yeah
[Music]
that's a good question
what should i run as a hundred oh well
is mobius quiver still okay or
i should have run something else
like i can run celestial nighthawk for a
quick little
boost in damage but
oh i see how they're going to have this
remaster because it takes time for the
proverbial darkness to go away
i mean i could go in if i'll we gotta um
each each of us got to take uh a side of
the pillar
yeah
you mean
yeah what's the i'll tell you can we
take them
wait wait wait wait
i'll take this side frosty you'll take
that side i'll take this one okay so
you'll always take the right leading in
i'll take the most facing and you get
that one will
yeah okay what does that mean right
there taking this side
the left this side this
this side of the door what does that
mean i have to go do
every time we come up to this pillar
before we go in the door you're always
gonna take the left side you're gonna
take this side
every time he'll take the right where
he's standing and i'll take and then
look at your three
there's going to be three um
symbols three of three symbols and then
we go inside and we're gonna [ __ ]
grab those three symbols each yeah i
just wanted to start it to see if they
come out and shoot them one okay or no
all three all three just memorize all
three
okay and where am i going
inside into the door see this door
go find your sick symbols pick them up
and come outside and shoot all of them
okay
i see so this tells us what symbols
yeah
okay you're gonna get prevarial darkness
which is gonna darken your screen
when you're inside you get darkness put
on you so you can't be in there long
and they gotta shoot us
shoot the doors to let us out i think
maybe i don't know
chris is everybody here
you know the codex of what the hell they
need to do
are you guys ready let's get it yeah
let's just see get it kind of runs in
joining along i got my symbol okay
don't say it out loud
just remember it
they put me to joining allies
okay i got one right here
that one was mine well you just took
mine
i thought that one was mine no i had the
two frames there he goes
okay all right
i [ __ ] this up already
no no no i think it's pretty confusing
though because i mean
it's all right let's just what are you
sure that they're all in there
yes yeah
they're all in here just white
because i picked up on snow cone
um there was like a flag wonder like uh
holy [ __ ] he's huge dude
oh then he sets the big off
even if you got to write it down
remember your stuff yo he crazy wild
[ __ ]
have you have your phone up take a
picture real quick so you know what you
got to go after
uk
it's three symbols per person on your
side okay you're three symbols so you
have to pick up three symbols each when
you go in there or just yeah yes
pick up all three and then all right you
guys ready
what happened okay man i don't want my
accent
you took you [ __ ] my symbol then
is there a way to recover from that you
could shoot my symbol if you recover and
you want to recover from it i don't know
if there was that many symbols in there
though we might have to skill i only saw
them take three
yeah yeah there was only three or four
in there so
yeah each person takes three
yeah there was only three or four there
was only three or four so
that's why i thought i'll just take one
per person
but
all right let's just do three let's try
it again where we just individually take
three come out and do the same thing we
did in the first room let's just see how
that goes
okay i just thought there was just four
cycles in general in there so i'll be
the third person to go in there
are you
pyramid
square triangle attic don't mess it up
we don't need four people in there oh i
got that guy
that's not mine
and this one is mine open the door
exit
open the door so i can exit
thank you this one's mine
now
i did mine
you got to shoot them
just with mine
oh we got it we got it anomalous accept
your offer
okay all right so wait wait
somebody didn't look there
i i shot mine we're not in there
so that that left side wasn't done
that's why he was able to break it
okay so when i picked up my three
symbols and
leave did you you send you picked up
your three right okay yeah knowledge
stacks deposited okay so
we got three three
no just shoot your side
get your side knocked out and then help
with the dps
okay
perfect okay i understand now
it's a little chaotic right there this
left side this is now attic or or
wilhelm what happened there because
y'all like tried to change i wasn't in
there i wasn't in there i never went in
there
initially and then they were there right
as everybody left all right
watch this
they weren't there
are you guys ready one person should go
in
at a time
all three can do it
okay are you guys ready
okay i got one of my symbols i got all
three already i'm going out
open the door for me
okay i got my three
some things up top okay
i don't think you have to wait
okay i got mine
once all of them are done
okay
i'm opening the door for you oh wow
i got two
let me know when you get your third and
i'll open the door again
uh he's already here
okay
yep
so i noticed once sin grabs his mind pop
up and then will's pop up pops up after
so i think that's how it's done every
time because sin always gets his three
first and then i get mine so maybe what
we should do is
we'll all go in together
one person picks up at a time and then
but we all like the other two people
just clear ads until that other person
is done so we all we don't exit until
all three have everything
ended up being in there by myself
if mine popped up last i could
technically
go in this but
why don't you switch with him just swap
sides
okay well there you go
all right you guys right he's ready
one of mine's here i might be first oh
and i got i got all mine open the door
all right i'm coming
come on
i got two of mine
okay i got one of mine i have all my
i do not have all of mine
i got killed
we have to take this i think we have to
take out those wizards
first okay
yeah you see man like mine took way too
[ __ ] long just yeah i think
think they're gonna respond every time
it's a really high yellow bar
yeah mine did not spawn for about 45
seconds and i got um pervading darkness
or whatever time whatever and i
died usually come in when i'm coming out
okay
okay this way they don't have to work
they don't have to look at us you open
the door
but i was
so
yeah
or maybe if you guys don't see any of
yours then i'll go in and i'll grab mine
and then it'll just be kind of jumbled
like that but yeah
just looking for my last one yep i got
it
open it and then you come in
yep you know yours
yep
hey we got one of mine
i got you
i'm dead the witch killed
that's like the first thing we got to do
only dps
i stunned them
you stunned them yeah
it gives the people more time time so we
can okay
got it okay
you stun them again
yeah it's a whiteboard yeah try to start
stunning him stunning him yeah you gotta
stun him yeah that's feeling i feel that
scouts feel very good in this
i was doing a lot of damage
we just no matter what nobody go for
cymbals just kill the wizards and then
we go for symbols
i don't think we're gonna have enough
time dude thank you he gets up there
fast it's gonna take too long
i think we'll end up having more time
but you don't really like that that dude
is up there quick
well like
he's running at the pillar when
go ahead he's at the pillar when i'm
coming out well he's almost there you
don't have to that's why i said they
gotta start him from downstairs you
don't have to wait for the two of us to
shoot yours you can shoot yours
immediately you don't have to wait for
all three of us to be there i know but
you're telling me to kill the wizards
it's gonna
be to come out just take a shot on the
wizards get your symbols come out shoot
the things and then come back and if you
can help or something i guess i i don't
know but i just don't think like if you
have a grenade throw a grenade at them i
mean that'll take their
stuff down i can use a heavy if i have
to
i say we i say i say we send the hunters
in there since they can go infuse
huh
yeah but it only lasts for so long and
if your symbols don't pop up you're kind
of [ __ ] with the shadow throw there
too but it's a good idea maybe we can
try that real quick
the way i saw glad doing it
the way i saw
him the way i saw glad doing it that it
looked like he was just running in there
grabbing three and saying what three
they were and they would come out here
and shoot the three and then just come
out and shoot yeah but i don't know like
specifically and so terry just did
his pillar his side of the pair alert
that's why i was
yeah
yeah that works perfectly well
switch with forte you're on dps slow
slow the boss down let forte jump in
there and go invis
okay
uh forte i know your mic is muted but
you got this side no i'm here i'm muted
what i'm saying
look look over here
this is your side
those are the basic sigils you're
looking for
you have to get all three
okay oh people are upset you just run in
there and grab them
why what happened
people are demanding them to uh start uh
to cancel the day one raid and have and
redo it because of all the uh apparently
like a lot of a lot of big people a lot
of people got disconnected that's what i
heard well everybody did okay so the big
people are pissed that they didn't get
worlds first
yeah yeah but everybody everybody even
the team that won worlds first had two
hours of down time
really
yeah they had two hours they were down
like between people out the whole screen
sour man they just need to accept and
you know
get the [ __ ] over it
all right you ready
yeah i'm ready
all right i'll go in last
let me know when you're done son
oh damn
yeah i was [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
i got my three i'm done
okay
yeah
i'm trying it's not spawning nothing is
spawning for me right now
because i don't think all three are
going to spawn all the time of every so
you just kind of have to like i think
pick up some and maybe run someone look
up a video or something
that's what glab was doing that's what i
did yeah i was looking
he launched esoterics
but
i don't know what
baby esoteric is doing something else
there i think everyone has good ideas
anything that works will work
i feel like you can't stun him what if
what if we do this what if we all go in
there
there's no one to then nobody stunned
the boss out though the boss and then
those things done in the boss for what
though we can't stand with anything
yeah you can't there's a period where
you can't stun him
oh
okay when's that and plus you're gonna
come out here to the most ads you've
ever [ __ ] seen right and them the
little
beehive things at the top that die
suicide bomb on you
where can you stun the boss
in the face and in the back of the thing
that little contraption he strapped onto
his back
oh okay
i don't even look
i got my three switch
okay make sure you stop the boss it'll
give me more time
there's a window it's not like there's
only a window you can stun him cause i
was trying
right
let me know when you have shoot him in
the head looking for my last one head
and then the face you got like a little
window underneath the mask and then also
in the thing
yeah whoever just did it
i think you couldn't find the last one
yeah that's what i'm saying it's so
like random when they pop up look all i
know is when i was seeing glad do it
that dude wasn't even up here likes
really
they were doing it
let me change to um
change the ball because it being that
we're out in the open
you're coming out and shooting yours
right
uh
oh yeah all three
of it
yeah individually it says it accepts
your offering or whatever
um
we're doing it right it's just
a little bit of rng we need to get it
down
i think what glad is doing is he's doing
all three of them he's going in and out
in and
out oh so it's just one person doing it
but then he'll you'll be [ __ ] stuck
with so much prevailing darkness
well i i don't know like
there's no actual there's something out
here that takes away the purveying
darkness that's the question because
that's why i'm not glad now to see if he
he encounters somewhere where he gets
rid of it
because that would make sense you go and
get him you go back in you go back out
shoot get rid of some prevailing
darkness go back in
and maybe you know another person like i
could go back in with you since you're
like really quick at getting them no
matter you know what your
you know three are you're probably the
quickest to do it
so i could go in and help you with the
witches and we can just you know
debuff ourselves
it's just two people in and out i think
hold on
it looks like four people are doing
damage
yeah so it's just two people not three
people going in
two okay so either you and gaming can go
in or i and you can go in it doesn't
matter you guys can uh me and you i'll
come back and i'll go back in
okay
i'll go in first
okay i'll go in first don't worry about
it um open the door you go in
and then
you when you come out i'll go in
okay so tell me what side you're looking
at which side you're gonna go for
okay so we can choose two sides and then
the last person to go back i'll have to
use the left i'll have two sides yeah
the first i'll be first and last and you
only got to do one
okay so the one that you usually do
that's first where all the symbols are
do that one first i'll do the second one
which is the side that i was originally
on and then you get the side that i'm
currently on or how i'm going to the
last one
all right just give me a second i'll
come out
change my little note
all right so
the way it looks like another good
[ __ ] one the way it looks like that
all uh we have to eventually hit all of
the
the tiles on this
but uh when you took put it in two at a
time you keep taking them down until
there's only three left because the last
one glad didn't even name them because
there was only three when he got to the
pillar
yeah i know but when you're going to
pick up the things there's more than
just those three there's like four or
five that spawn at once then you just
get three so you can get back and keep
the rotation fast he only grabbed three
both times he didn't
yeah and that's what we've been doing
well first if you want to just grab a
random three set you can grab a random
three and i'll go get the last three
i'll look at whatever's last three and
running he was calling it well the two
the only two of them were doing it
could have okay so you're going first to
the right
side of the room and then just run out
left side right side whatever's there
run out
if it's four if it's one
all right let's try it then let's try it
hold on
every raid same [ __ ]
wow what happened what happened just say
so
we literally said we're gonna do what
you said like we're literally saying
that we're doing it glad said no don't
say i said anything
so what would you like us to do sid
nothing we do what we're doing that's it
we literally said we in floresti said
what we're gonna do and then it got
repeated
it's like are you [ __ ] kidding me
so you get this one i'll get this one
and then when you come out and deposit
the other one yes one okay yes perfect
we're the ones running we should be the
ones
talking about it not everybody else
i mean why you got to be a smart ass
that's what i want to know like no
you're not
you [ __ ] overcut me okay and then you
[ __ ] on whatever i say no i'm not
literally we did what you did multiple
times last friday
all i did was
all i did was tell you what i saw on
glad screen and you over here acting
like a complete [ __ ] because i said
that
here we go being an [ __ ] i'm just
telling you i'm looking at glad video
too we went over it with frosty and then
you repeated it and then changed i
literally just said what was on the
screen that's all i didn't say you was
wrong i didn't say anything was going on
i literally just repeated what glad was
doing
you're trying to contradict what you're
saying or i'm trying to change out
things up i said look it looks like
they're going in there two at a time and
you're sitting here having a big ass
attitude over you run in there you you
do the you do all the hard work go ahead
go
i'm just gonna now you run into it there
and do six six things and then that top
wouldn't do just want to play hopscotch
with me
i'm down for dinner
for the dj equipment
all right we listen to the music
this is
that shit's unnecessary man literally
i'm just trying to figure it out like
everyone else and you over here being
all extra for the [ __ ] go ahead do it
i'm out here with them keep that [ __ ]
together for your community guys don't
do that in front of the people yo
you've been watching for like 10 hours
i'm going to disappoint them they've
been sticking with y'all stick with each
other they stuck with y'all for 10 hours
to watch not to see our fight b oh you
got this time nice
somebody's done yeah yeah
i'm just going i'm just going
i got i got my first three i'm coming
out and someone opened it all right
some all right hold on got it those open
yep cool okay shoot them pigs at the top
yo cause they're going down bomb
yeah okay i got the first side i'll go
back i need somebody to stun his back
all right
wait yeah oh there you go
it's the back is the only stun
no when he turns his back
when he turns it you can stun him in the
face or in the attack
towards
i'm not going in there i already said it
i'm not going to do the hard work if i'm
going to [ __ ] get stepped on it it's
going to act like a [ __ ] child
because i was just saying everybody
right everybody no one [ __ ] said that
do what he did in the video that's it
you know what he did go do it
what's next
frustration
you know what he did go do it
yeah i'll talk to you guys later i'm out
yeah no this is [ __ ] like no i
literally just said what was i
no you said you won't go in there just
because i repeat something in a video
no one is running i never offered to go
in there not one time
you acting a little extra for no reason
no one's telling you
i'm just gonna meet my phone
it like that
it all fell apart
i'm just grabbing three and then
door's open
somebody
[Music]
all right well you wanna
[Laughter]
okay all right ready
let's go
we're powering back up y'all stay with
us man
we're getting together
brother's fight that's all it is
all right
you know what you grabbed frosty
yeah
yeah i can't mess with him
okay i'm describing these three yeah
just grab any three go ahead yeah let me
know when you need that dough
because they'll be different than the
three that i grabbed so
all right cool all right i'm grabbing
that thing still going shot three but it
didn't accept it wow it's not a random
three
it's not a random three
no
okay
they might be on different sides i think
you have to shoot the ones on different
sides just one shot okay we can draw
that yeah yeah just like they'll be all
over the place and you just gotta
find them like
like that's why maybe don't pick up more
than two if it's hard to remember three
and we'll just do it more you know like
more runs versus
bigger ones
disciples
yeah i just know that when you shoot
three at once it says accepts or
decline okay so i don't know all right
i guess just yeah pick up any three and
then just look around and
do what we can find
you want me to go first you want to go
first you can go first so instead of
memorizing what's on the thing you just
and i got
the upside down
[ __ ] let's open the door please
people flush right
red square
got the witch queen symbol triangle
yeah it three on each side yeah
yeah it did not like the offer
yeah
that didn't seem the videos that i
haven't been seeing it didn't seem to be
that but
maybe that maybe it's second phase i
don't know
but right now all i know is that you
pick up the tree
that it shows on each side going from
down to or from up to down
or from the top to bottom you shoot
them in a specific order
no you you just pick up those three you
can shoot it either from the bottom up
or you can shoot it from up to down as
long as you have those three and you
shoot those three symbols
because every time let's say if you pick
up three and then you know it's green
pyramids and then black sun
it takes away
from your
knowledge so no wonder king and saul
said they'll wait yeah i'll read it in
chat dude
come on guys
yeah he still can't be dps for some
reason but whatever
okay
is that a wife
thank you so much
he's stunned we got like
five seconds before he gets on that
pillar
all right can we revert back to what we
were doing before my dude
even with me you and will
you go on first you just need two people
well okay
it was working out pretty well man
yeah take a damage
i did the most no you did both
look at those damage numbers dude
damn it but it's so weird for the window
like when they hit him it's like i feel
like you've been used for a long time my
warlock's ready to jump in and
somebody's running
you ready for the spot
[Music]
are you doing
[ __ ]
what if the scorn was one of us
stupid
let me see if i get up here maybe i have
a better vantage point better being down
here
everybody's ready
for us with their frosting away
forte's on the other side are you
shooting him in the back right away yeah
yeah
i hit him with a weakening grenade i'm
sending him okay can he be bps
no no you gotta
you gotta study still trying to figure
out how you do it yeah that's what i'm
trying to figure out
open the door
everything came at me
i got you
just waiting for the door to be open
yeah i died
oh nobody want to go
no the darkness
can you still shoot the three that you
own or
yeah
uh go back in
went away yeah the knowledge
i can try to feel better
your guardian got stupid
i think i figured out how to do it
oh i see his back a little bit yeah how
you doing
you're just gonna get close to it when
he slams
yeah those symbols are no longer here
so
i had at the first time
[Music]
yeah we had it and then died and he
disappeared
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's what it
i don't know man
so what is it you gotta you gotta get up
closer and make them slam and then
[Music]
when i come back out here and i'm gonna
do it again
i want to see what you do
are we able to do damage when he's
stunned no
no
that's just to slow him down so you can
finish
so you guys have more time
yeah that's all it is it's up for me
outside to give you more time
all right start it
circle
all right i'm going through right here
see how we rage yeah oh there you go
yeah
there it is
okay i got my three symbols open the
door
he looks like he's raging again yeah
we're doing
there you go
so is it better to be behind him or what
there's no you like the person the
person behind yeah there we go
somebody behind him when he's shooting
at us has to be able to damage him
to slow em up
you get something's gotta get pick me up
oh yeah
somebody's always gonna make sure the
door's open too
yeah so one part got to be by the door
yeah we had a good run there well man
that's that's all we got to do
just make sure you grab the three wonder
how we can prevent him from going up the
steps though
you gotta see somebody has this
ice cream when he's turned
ice wall door so what he's facing
for the first frame youtube says
somebody
to where he spawns in use a sword to
block his attack and shoot his head
somebody in the top platform can shoot
his back and stun him
right that's what i swapped down low all
right so i'll go upstairs all right if
somebody needs to be honest
yeah
i'll go upside down
i'm up top though
so my shot easier to shoot him in the
bed yeah from here
okay open the door
doors open
coming
to the right this time or what
oh yeah
all right shoot his back yeah i'm trying
to get it off
me i think you have to shoot it from the
bottom up
got to get into there you go now you got
the back
all right i got mine
oh it's crazy
i think it's damage time
open door someone created a war might
sell right next to him shoot it
that's the king
imagine if you gotta push him off
title dps
can you imagine
[Music]
yeah let me get that uh ray bennett and
get him back actually i was able to send
him a lot
mm-hmm
i wonder what's the best thing to stun
him with i mean gallery was doing decent
when he had his back
okay
so it is shoot it from the bottom up so
it is
yeah
okay
i was shooting from the top and i was
getting yellow damage
okay i shot the middle one first and
then top and then bottom so i think that
just [ __ ] it up
alright forte i'm in position
i will be selling you sending you
healing
baby
just what they always let me know when
he smashed oh there you go
all right he's going right i need a
reposition though
okay i got my attention
okay
doors
it's open out here boy
we gotta clear this middle though these
dudes smiling
why did they reject my eyes nobody gotta
shoot him in the back all right that's
the problem is the ads on the top
are lashing
me while i'm trying to shoot him in the
back
i can't find my third
okay
all right um will you guys give me two
minutes just to kind of
familiarize myself with
the whole thing
this system right here called
not disturb the disciple
he said use the sword block then freeze
frame says person at bottoms has to yell
out stun when he can be stunned person
at top can quickly look and stun then
return focus back to the ads
all right i'm gonna watch this video
real quick and then i'm gonna
i'm sure you guys are
i'm sure everyone knows what they're
doing i'm gonna stay up with the
problems i think i'm just gonna
i'm gonna stay up top here we're gonna
ask then galley shoot him from up here
the stun
wait where are you back no no no i'm
gonna come over here come over here
i'm gonna show you something
so when we climb up to the other level
we have a angle down yeah
that's what i was i was kind of was
going on i was doing what you just do
right now but i was going to the other
side
so that we could kind of get both
vantage points worry about adds and then
you know what i'm saying
you got that right side but from up here
you could drop down whenever you feel
like
and you'll be directly over him
true but the main thing is you know we
don't know where he gonna give his
backup to so if he's if we're if we're
on this side and we had a position where
his back is not you know what i'm saying
at least with the other method both of
us have a chance i'm just i i'll i'll do
it your way the first time i don't care
i just want to see the other way if that
doesn't work
what's she doing all the way up there
i'm shooting down into his back
starting here i thought she was okay i
thought she was starting okay
i thought you started on this floor
you're going all the way are you doing
something else
that's not how you get the chance you're
getting hit by the ass that's why i'm
able to rush y'all every time
you're doing something to get really
intent
you just shoot him in the back and
you're not getting nothing just take it
all right that's it
you had abs all around you yeah
all around me but i was down see this
way when he's not stunned i'm shooting
the abs and then when he's stunned
the only thing is we got to wait it
almost like can you you can't hit him
until he hits the step stick from here
because he's you know no no i could see
him you can see him right here see he
spawns right there and then he walks
either this way or that way
if he walks the other way we just run
over there real quick all right
somebody got put the flag now [ __ ] i
have no rockets
um
[Music]
is
okay so he went in and called out what
he was grabbing the other person that
would rotate with him would stand out
and look for one
on the obelisk of the three
glad would find the other two and shoot
two while the other person shoots the
other one would go in
the other person will call out what he
had and glad shot all of his three
so i i guess you don't have to be
holding the symbols
i don't know
it doesn't look that way but
yeah that's how vladim did it but i i
don't
that's super fun i don't know
but then everyone else wasn't
really talking either it was just him
and sweat
like
communicating what symbols they would
pick up and then they'd shoot him
so
to say they'd run in and
pick up any two
tell the guy on the other side
any three
tell the guy on the outside which ones
they picked up
and then the other guy would do what
okay so when glad first went in he
picked up three
he shot two that were on the side of
where the door is you know it was facing
the door he shot two and sweat shot one
on the other side
sweat went in and he called out three
once you don't have to have the debuff
to shoot them you just have to know
which one it is and pick them up
[Music]
so while one person was in there the
other person was looking at the obelisk
and seeing where the symbols were when
he'd come out
yeah when he'd come out that's when
they'd shoot it because i think it's
like it waits
for so-and-so's offering and once it
says that that's when they would shoot
and then the other person would rotate
in
he would go in he would shoot
pick up three
come out
shoot
shoot those three
and then the other guy would shoot the
other one on the opposite side
yeah so whatever side it was if the
symbols that he didn't pick up weren't
all on the same side the other person
would shoot the one that isn't on that
side
okay and then what would that do would
that they would accept the offering from
that
it would accept the offering yeah even
though it was on an opposite side
yes
so it just sounds like it just needs to
be three it doesn't even have to be the
three on one side
does it matter what the order is
does it have to be in the order that you
pick them up
i have no clue
i just know that they
did it that way and that's that's all
it might have to be in the order so
maybe we can do it in that order as long
as there's to be a vacation or whatever
all right trying to get some water real
quick guys yep i'm taking a leak right
back
gotta get a leak
gotta get that leaky
think it's so good fortune
speaking of it time
so much better
gotta take a leap
it
[Laughter]
that would be funny
did you do like a
down
should not need
10 hour gaming sessions brought to you
by valarie game pillows the marvel game
protect those elbows get good form on
your elite controller
oh my god oh my god you ever have a
stretch that
oh
how many hours well we started at raid
time so i think we're at the 10 hour
mark no
this is i couldn't 10 and a half here
i couldn't be happier to do this with a
group with a better bunch of guys with a
group of better group of guys like you
you know minus minus by this
[Laughter]
[Music]
soon
[Music]
we must move forward through our rage
drama
let it go
the rain
have broken i think he's good i think
he's i think his girlfriend played for
him right now
[ __ ] she basically
babe
show them how much better
how good you are in destiny
they'll think it's me
there's a free eye open shirts for the
chat yeah they do this
who got the biggest chips
[Music]
oh
reality than i'm about ready to talk
[Laughter]
green grasses
the green grass
[Music]
all right hold on i got to get up to
that spot you was that sir degrees
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
oh this branch there was a limb
thank you this
is sick what this guy's saying
[Music]
all the branch branch of the trees
[Music]
are you guys are you guys ready
[Music]
two hands cuphead
oh i broke my legs oh obvious accept the
offer that's good you broke your leg
somebody get here
all right
i don't think you guys can sit up there
because
it's only just me down up here
yeah i'm dead anyway
try to try to get up there with us as a
kid that worked though yeah there's uh
there's not enough people standing
i'll let you stay up there
i'll i'll go
and what you're going to be down there
to help out and i got i got a well to
help them out with the ads when they
come out the door you know what i'm
saying these wizards in
that i have when i go in there
it's got like um what are those guys
from vault of glass the sea and kill ya
oh
because y'all been in the raid for so
long you know the warlock got invis now
or y'all already know about that yeah
yeah so you got to get our ass back for
it you got to get an aspect for that
the world like you go invisible now
there's an aspect
so you could drop kick somebody and go
and visit for like eight seconds oh yeah
every job that's crazy yeah sick
sick
warlocks can go invisible now so we
could probably have one runner i guess
and one guy watched the door couldn't
wait for rusty yeah
it goes away but if you keep going back
in and out it keeps building so you need
to give it time too
i like this this is good i like it i
like it i like it
mikey thank you nike i think he likes me
everybody ready
yep yes screen frost
let's go send you ready for us mm-hmm
open the
nice
shoot the door working on it
working on it open the door shut him in
the back
i got it
go ahead
okay black triangle
[Music]
it's not that you can't
my glitch
uh
okay
all right you guys ready
yep better than ever
i've been using the izanagi burden to
stun them
all right
that's what it was all right we got um
god with ghosts on top of his head
okay
so yeah snake and
[Music]
keep that up watch the door all right
i'm gonna get
stun between symbol which means symbol
yeah uh
reverse cup like the white and the blue
yep and the dark pyramid not the pyramid
the dark pyramid
okay so the dark turn go okay yeah dark
triangle
i'm stuck i need a door near the door
i can't shoot it okay there you go
someone was standing in my way
all right okay i got dark triangle get
gotta stun me turn towards you i think
well
helpful here i put the well yeah i put
the well in the well
i'll put it in the front
not a thing filled up
we kept
neat wells
definitely yeah
all mobilities i can't wait
for this subclass it's going to be yeah
like
yeah talk about the solar subclass when
they take all the good stuff and
separate it so you can't
crunch all this [ __ ] together
all right just give me one second guys
yeah i gotta change my loadout
listen man
you know what's gonna happen tomorrow um
cognito king gonna be like so yeah
how'd it go
oh y'all only made it two encounters in
huh
wait so this is this is the third
account this is the third
there's a jumping puzzle then the boss
and then there's two phases to the boss
okay so really one
really one
look at this guy does this thing have
checkpoints or do we have to play the
whole raid again if we do it tomorrow no
let's check we're going to check once
you 44. he's over there uh he's over
next to saint 14
in the um hangar
all right me ralph you mean this one
forty four yeah
yeah
are you talking about zur or [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm looking for uh mods like anybody
who's selling margins here you know uh
oh no
she's down there
yeah she downstairs
drifter
yeah
okay yeah i think that guy's pistol does
doesn't he he still spells bones he got
smith but yeah basically sounds boss
yeah and eddie
let's go
did
the chat he was like where are we at now
they were ahead of us but i don't know
how far they got since
he's not streaming and then
what you call it was um dj in them was
they're still on that encounter behind
us
they're still there
i have to double check with them now but
they when we went past we passed them
yeah we passed them
so uh is he watching this isn't
streaming is he
um he's playing with the big boys he's
playing with cool guy
dj's
i think they quit
they quit yeah i think they broke down
it does it man it's the rape man stuff
is tough
guys
who's he playing with
a senator no bad cool guy
true vanguard
and i believe
hey who else
couple other guys
like twitch streamers a-plus
look that that remember when he was your
first
that's what happens when your sub count
get up
absolutely salute to the sub count and
putting in the work man
you guys ready
well i'm trying to think you said you're
using um
izzy
all right ready
wait
i guess i mean if you're stunning him
with izzy
then
like you seem like you're able to start
him good at it
i work i'll focus on the ads and keeping
the well wait screen where y'all want
the well at when i put it tell me where
it would be ideal for y'all
uh probably right like
here here like okay yeah so this place
is like bam okay there we go
yeah from the stop yep okay i'll do that
all right i'm ready
cool you ready yeah oh no it's ready
you ready yeah
center are you ready
to go are you watching this
wow i'm sorry
i'll love y'all
all right all right shout out
yep
okay we got pregnant
um brain and which guy symbol
okay
right here in front i'll get the other
one
staggered
i think if we stand like with our back
towards the middle we can see the
obelisk and the symbol i just gotta
remember to get you out
right yeah it's pretty hectic out there
though so yeah i don't know
it seems like that one shot's taking him
down every time yeah i'm gonna let you
focus on this thing
izzy's after all this time is so [ __ ]
amazing
i'm glad it came back because i was like
i used to love that joint dude
i don't even like staples like that but
that was my favorite are you doing the
four shot is he are you doing that on
regular shots
i'm curious
you're doing the power shot is he on him
i think so are you doing the attic or
you're doing a regular
he's probably doing the four
all right yeah so you're hitting him
with the power okay yeah
all right i'm gonna start it
i wonder why they had two of these
things in the door okay
dagger through heart
um green and red hat just call it
mexican flag i guess
i've been low-key wanting to call with
that for a minute i ain't gonna lie
you know you can't figure it out
all right dagger
what was the first one
dagger which means right here
but now but now i can blame you guys
because i had it you have to save one
stagger
okay got it go ahead
all right let's keep comes clear
pick it up
snow cone
okay they're gonna
uh
pyramid
light coming out of the top
okay and
picking up brain
okay
i got pyramid and brain okay got you
okay
staggered i'm not afraid it's no glory
one two three go
i died you gotta be
i got you
i'm going in well if we have a well it's
outside so it's just in a bad position
sorry there's another one staggered it's
just the last three so
yeah he ain't good he ain't really
getting anywhere
i love it keep that up
okay can i be let out
yep door's open
stagger
all right which ones were they
the last three
so
i got these two get orgs in front
okay i think it's dps
the rituals complete power everybody up
to the plates
we'll pull it okay this place up here
you can do damage on the light up
where are these right here okay
i'm sitting on it ain't nothing we're
lighting up stuff nothing's lighting up
there there you go breakthrough here it
is dbs oh i should have had it right
here
that's what we need to weld right here
could someone get me up no i i didn't
swan with you all right we got switch
plates switch plates
how much damage did you guys do
um
a quarter yeah
but how come this is actually nice but
it's not all like his damage is not old
yeah but if you're not damaging him it
seems like he's healing little by little
it looked like
yeah it's weird
um
king i have a uh sorry
[ __ ] what's up uh i have a revised spot
for the well all right
stick it like right next to the totem
that way like the bottom of it like
circum navigates the totem so we're
always in it when we're looking around
it what you gotta do
oh you talk about just yeah i'll show
you you're putting the things in
just when you're putting the well down
if you're putting like a well down that
way like we can always be in it so long
as we're close to the totem
like like you can stick like you can
stick it down like you talk about during
damage phase or weird
no just like during oh just regular yeah
all right hold on show me where i scream
just you can just stick it down like
right like here yeah like any like right
up against it just so that okay it'll
always go around
the whole thing right the whole thing
maybe like place it like in like one of
these weird corners so that it's not
like blocking
the symbols or whatever just like in one
of the corners because then it'll reach
around the whole thing
okay i think the best thing we can do is
do your best is me sitting for tabi at
the bottom
because we we we was stunned by him he
wasn't walking anyway but i do need some
help up top when they get crazy yeah
ready for symbols
through heart sword and mexican flag
i'm coming out all right we have a
bowling heart staggered
a sword it looks like a flag here to the
left
braid banner we'll just call it ray
banner over here to the left
okay oh okay
okay all right they've rejected it
rejected
three two
one it rejected it man okay that's what
you're calling okay never mind my bad
because
it's like a raid banner
call it raid banner
it's called
go
they're shooting with solar from what
i'm seeing
i think
the snipers are using solar
thermal shock plating does both are yeah
yeah i got that on my chest but i got
yeah i'm putting thermo on
back at it again
whatever
the chat
oh he's back oh man
that man trying to sell his wares
all right shall we give me one second
okay
okay i'll put sniper damage resist on
because those are the only thing [ __ ]
me up
yeah
everything else i could really deal with
all right let me get that ring banner
all right you really ready yep
everyone ready yeah are you hot and
horny for raids
wow
okay um
umbrellas
rain
and
scorn
okay
right here you gonna brilliant
ah he turned the other way i can't
really okay three two one go
take
it okay i'm going in
yep i'm dead i'm down he shot so much
[ __ ] out of his back
dark sun stagger
i got him so are you
okay
okay
i like this guy's name
this is like the thing that he keeps
posting
[Laughter]
all right
starting in three two one
[Music]
i got mexican flag and whispering here
rainbow compass stagger three seconds
i don't know
where's whisker did you get witchcraft i
got it yeah i got it okay cool cool
with the
pyramid okay i got hands down in black
sun
stagger all right pink blood's right
here three two one go
okay i'm going in it's just the last
three so find them
yeah i'm gonna go back to doing uh uh to
focusing on
on the staggering because like me
clearing out stagger stagger
do you have to call out
i don't know what is it
nothing um
it's just the last three that are lit up
so okay i got all of them are over here
actually okay
cool okay there we go we're gonna get
rid of that
that was just some time too
get me up
can someone get them up you gotta wait
i'll get them up
can we damage now yeah yeah
nope it doesn't say damage it's late now
you can't now you're getting again
that took way too long
i don't know
why let us do damage yeah that took a
long time
gotta go to the next on the plate are we
wrong plate we're on the wrong plate no
we we're on the right we gotta rotate
now it's gonna play the yeah
right here
what's a good role for the
the what for the the red one i need i
need a different row because i'm not
doing enough damage
a different role for what for the uh
right hurry up
oh i don't know that i was using it did
a couple people get teleported there's
only four of us standing here yeah it
must be my oil must be teleported
somewhere else
did people get teleported do we have to
go up
yeah
yeah sometimes it looks like they
they'll teleport the orb somewhere weird
oh i got killed
okay
just white
what's a good role for the red hair
i don't know
i don't know
as long as someone throws a void grenade
i think my
does anyone shoot in gallahore
yeah i got guy with him okay
hold on let me get galley out
all right let me change this
i was using wither horde and i did a lot
of damage seems like yeah
you did you were shooting with the horde
on him as well
yeah
and then running like combo
which rocket you're using
i'm using the palomar b plumber b with
uh lasting impression yes
all right i'm gonna switch to my rocket
i mean i'm sure a galley would probably
do pretty good but i think it would be
like that
yeah yeah well you don't need to get one
with a galley and everybody you know
somebody
uses uh yup i'm gonna switch anybody's
gonna
[Music]
and i don't know i guess that's a good
role for a rocket launcher if he was
asking i think i think the the one i
have has quick draw and golden uh trigon
let me get that with him i think we're
gonna be really supposed to make it
stronger like like like for the
whole i mean and then you know
tracking with the rocket launchers i
think all the only thing that that is
important is just
to get the blasting up as much killed
we got the raid weapons so early
that dim has it unclassified as an
unknown weapon
those ray weapons that we got
they don't even know what it is
that's good
[ __ ]
sorry
i got a helmet
that's good to know
thanks uh
yeah we know that for us
all right but with there it goes gotta
infuse it and then
[Music]
try to i'm gonna try the raid weapon
you know i tried it's okay
it was just i don't know i got the
deliverance
shoes and rifle
oh
let me look at that where yeah
it looks
get a new chair
i haven't
[Music]
the boss
yeah the boss
i think we'll do more damage this time
because i'm using uh all right i'm using
different
stuff
yep i'll switch my brain out now i'm
ready to rock
okay i'm gonna do that with a horse
strat i think that might be really
effective
and let me switch
damage i kept messing with um
deathbringer like i would shoot it above
this head but i i'd like [ __ ] shoot
it wait are you guys ready
people are still in there
wait yep
okay well um
flower
and
okay good [ __ ]
going in
stagger
oh i missed i can't
i'm gonna get on the back side of him
okay
i'm getting
a circle white circle or a traveler
sorry i'm looking for him
okay
i'll get inquired get the other two
three two one let's go
stagger
get it i did it yep
damn i can't i killed
yes said i got my warlock stretching
attic sound like you weren't throwing
the towel
that was done yeah i think during the
call there's too much talking
but they they got to call out the stun
it's very critical for the stone to be
called out
we've been calling
okay no i'm just saying but i know you
want the comms clear i'm just trying to
figure out
actually i switched um
to what i've been studying him with the
the funnel web like really easily like
half a clip and yeah you know you only
have to you barely have to shoot them
really so all that you can just for
example
[Music]
ain't doing no damage to him he's just
stunning him
okay the biggest thing is we got to stop
him from shooting those balls because it
stops them from doing [ __ ] well you're
supposed to shoot the balls with um
umbrellas rainbow umbrellas and what was
the other one
i got you here
right here yeah
yeah we gotta shoot those things that
rainbow three two one go
logo
watch out incoming i got mexican
and
which
they're right over here on the left side
i'm dead
he's there
i screwed that up
[Music]
you got a couple more seconds
yeah no it took it away from me
oh i took it
yeah if you die it takes more oh
okay got it
getting better that's why we keep that's
why it keeps sparking off
what we have to do to help them
there are yellow bar snipers and either
that spawn in the middle of the phase up
top and then they'll they even be beasty
i try to rocket them and they'll put up
the in the bubble anti-barrier sometimes
so be cognizant those dudes are doing
mad damage to to these guys and us down
here
they'll yeah they'll be in those corners
you see where there's like green yeah
and i i've been shot
they're spawning right there we got to
pay attention they'll
they they do crazy damage not really the
ads it's those guys those things
let me know all right we can get it we
just have to we get it
we just got to clean up
all right let's go
there you guys ready yeah yeah i'm ready
okay
um
oryx
[Music]
okay i got you on this side all right
four days looking at you
you got brain then
stagger yep three two one let's go
stunned
i don't know just go back in
all right
dagger
yep
brain
and
mexican flag
okay
coming out
there
got
can't hide in the show anymore
there's another one at the other end
i can't get him i got the one over here
okay man with those i got him
okay
right i'll get rainbow
ready to come out
okay i need to be lit up
okay three three two one go
go ahead okay
this is the last
pyramid
they have one mistake screwed up
yeah they just have one mistake when
they come up did you think
and then yeah really good on the um
those uh dudes that we i was talking
about before i go on watch stanford i
switch back to israeli i'll kill i'm
gonna kill one on i'm gonna go on that
side and kill one and i'm gonna snipe
the other one
now you want me to focus on just left
side ads and you focus on right side
i've been i've been just killing any ads
i see
well i'm gonna try to kill both the
snipers this time with is an argue
and then i'll i'll keep checking
and i'll i will tell you if i can get
them i'll tell you if i can't all right
no doubt and then i'll keep the well in
the middle for uh frost and scream up as
much as i can okay they need it when
they're when they're calling out and
they come outside to shoot they cannot
be distracted they need the help
and i've noticed if we keep those balls
from coming out of his head uh his
backpack yeah you guys will stay alive
as soon as i stand on my shoes
rainbow flag is right here as you come
out there's other two
okay okay yeah go back to here
three two one
okay go ahead nice good [ __ ]
[ __ ] put a bubble up soon as i
shut around
um
like coming out of here i missed him uh
he's still alive
um
downward
facing
arrow black arrow and
the
guy with the um
i need out i need out
uh what is that the um
guy with the
ghost above his head
all right guys
all right here's get the uh
two
two the other two are right here i'll
get two you get the ghost all right
three two two one go
they're rejected
and they're doing damage to it as well
yeah they're speeding up the process
yeah that's the problem
sniper got me
yeah that sniper man is a pain
okay
sometimes these symbols are just so
annoying described diamond
my threes let me out
okay
okay you got them all
yeah i tried to but it's not letting me
do it
reject
yeah just swipe it
it's like do we need to have four
different like pyramid diamond things
like
it's just
like if i could if i could like
punch
a bungee dev in the [ __ ] balls right
now
whoever came up with these symbols yeah
the symbols were off that's the guys
challenge
really good
do you mind if i go in first this time
frosty
go for it
before y'all start don't start
khakis look like he's walking dead right
now
look but i need to beat this for a video
look yeah because he gotta beat it for
the video he gotta beat him so he can
put up his uh ray guy for dummies for
dummies yeah yes that's a fact what's
the fact though
there you go he got through it
all right you guys ready
it was thank you
bigger difference i don't think
sure i think yeah i think well i mean i
think any grenade any rocket launcher
and like
it's gonna probably do i'm just worried
about dps where we finally do the clean
runs you know what i'm saying
what are you using as a primary
i'm just switching back and forth let me
see his face real quick
yeah i'm gonna go back to galley man
who's to help out
he's about to go let's see he's like
you're coming
face just like completely
look at that
red square
i got face earth
praying man
okay i got earth and frame and red
squares right when you come out
okay
all right three two one go
all right i'll get i'll get uh great
banner
snipers
all right read better
yep
uh heart
outside's falling apart
snow cone yeah we're dumb that's all
right too many people died outside yeah
like we can only hold them all for so
long
are you guys
is there a reason why you guys are
getting further can you clump up or you
have to be kind of close
there you have to be kind of far away
from each other
where me and forte are on top of each
other and
attic if someone wants to switch holding
me i can do it clear
no no
you guys got it
you got to flow though
yeah yeah
you guys just got got to make sure that
you get the the originals right that's
awesome
yeah
because because when you guys mess up
when you guys mess with that one time
it makes us have to do a lot but when
adds are like hitting you while you're
trying to shoot it it makes you flinch
and you shoot other ones so it [ __ ] up
the whole thing
so that's the only problem
we're shooting the right you know we're
shooting the right ones it's just we're
getting flinched and shooting things
above or to the side or
below it i i i get that but if we do
everything we can to get to clear the
heads they all red bars it's no one's
fault it's no one's fault i'm not i'm
not blaming anybody
it's just unfortunate
all right guys ready
all right earth
yep
man with hole in his heart yep
and
uh
man with ghost
all three of them are on my side
let me know when you're out
i am out
okay hit it
three two one go i already got it
all right cool
dodge dodge heading back in
okay three two
one go
ahead that's the last three
rainbow
sniper on that side on the right
red square
and
crazy jumped in front of my rocket god
damn it rainbow red square phrase man
okay i got red square get those two all
right ready three two one go
there we go
oh my gosh look at you
did we get the damage face
yeah we got the damage someone's got to
get me
it's just i'm coming
all right i'm going to switch from a
nice heavy to my ostio so that i can
with their coming forward for the
we gotta wait for the plate that we need
to be on yeah we gotta wait
the world
oh
yeah oh yeah
so many ads
over here
and some units
yeah they not having it
the current well begins to fade oh you
got to look at yeah
that way now the stairs comes down and
we have to go up
there we have a reef it's all right yeah
it's all right yeah no revive right
well i'm gonna suggest so that that that
worked out good because i was going
literally to the sides to kill the
sniper so they weren't up as much
i'm gonna suggest uh
control seems to be doing a lot
all right
yeah
i was fine
okay
that damage phase though man if we lose
that
yeah
that's so key
because we barely did damage last time
yeah but we have two doors here now
yes there's more than one door
there's one on the left and one on the
right
triangle black triangle and
witch queen i think that back triangle
is
what we got to do is while we're waiting
for him to activate that
that
that's fault we need to just go ahead
and add control kill as many as possible
before he activates that spawn
and i got that much but
you know what i'm gonna sleep in that
one for that dude
hold on let me switch to sleep all right
i'm just gonna keep on osteo because it
did really good damage actually would
take damage and then you switch your
ones so
how do you shoot the thousand stairs
how do i shoot it i just
triggered it
it shoots like a fusion rifle like i've
never shot it before
you hold it and then once it lets
everything loose it's going to burn on
him and then you should be shooting the
next round
all right all right all right then
switch
okay
okay i can get all right i'll get inked
blood i'll get inquired he smashed both
of me
how did he close his back
you should have went down
oh
just like the other one if we keep
beating our head against it we're gonna
get it but
all right i've already figured out how
to solo the first ray chest
[Music]
somebody figured out how to solo the
first rage hits
how you can get the first ray chest
look video from tomorrow
might be tonight
it'll stay up tonight i figured out i
figured that this is this is the best
way to do a cog because i'm able to at
least get him to get into a shield so
you can kill him because i was shooting
him from over here i switched to a scout
rifle
yeah scouts are amazing for this
boss are you guys ready all right yep
yeah and i've never used this thousand
of your stairs
that's the funny thing
i mean one capability yeah 1k voices i
don't know why i said that yesterday
no okay
hey usually
[Music]
yep the two percents are here all right
three
two one let's go there's a bunch of
those things up you guys gotta watch out
together
all right
thank you for the well
um
red hands
black triangle
mexican flag
all right i'll get uh
i'll get
hey go for it
snipers are up
yep
from the corner all right three
two one go
got it
perfect okay get ready for dps he
knocked me off the map
i got you then
don't put your will down
clear ads play your ads
it's on his side
next one middle middle middle middle
middle
to help y'all
yo
that yeah that damage
the thing is though yeah i need the luna
factions on the finish protocol y'all
need i need y'all fastest reloads
all right now
this one is two i think i was gonna have
to beat them let me go through one at a
time you think
yeah like
go through one go through the other one
and then go yeah
you would meet forte over here i think
we only do one round per room
yeah i think so let me see if there's
three
there's two right there
i don't see that there's one that's
actually good he's stunned right off the
jump just one right here
things that came on his back between
that him and slamming and the ass in the
back
and i'm at the door
yep
man come on okay i got ghost head and
brain
let me switch the factions okay snow
cone
earth
so it is going back and forth between
the two rooms and then
okay so yeah that's how we do it
okay
i think i need to use the bathroom
really quick yeah i'm gonna have to take
like a 10 minute minute go go go go
yeah
let's take a time
second 10 minutes
okay i'm gonna charge my uh headset just
a little bit actually
be back in like five minutes
i'll go back out
great
at this part i wish i have a worm husky
rick cack is here
ugh
[Music]
oh damn dj's
going through pissed
ray day
breaks the strongest of us all
i didn't even have
but i have no sleep
just connect it
uh
oh
out
spring
[Music]
there was a couple parts for unstoppable
unstoppable glade was really was really
good
certain parts
in the box right now
um
uh
2600
what's that 180.
so
cool
um
okay i'm back
cool cool
sorry about that my headset is wireless
so i have to charge it
now you good you good
i feel like we can get this man in like
one nice little run we got good damage
and the communication was on point we
didn't [ __ ] up once the stun the stun
just unlocking is tight
the key is the ads
i'm putting on the faction so we can do
more dps
that should help
significantly
and then um
yes
yeah
yeah
i'm gonna upgrade these new boots as
much as i can
yeah i'm putting luna factions on for
when we get the dps you got one shot at
max dps reloading
oh man but i didn't get a chance to see
how much it did last time
we did pretty good damage actually
mm-hmm
yeah the damage was promising
the key is you know what the bungie's
slick
they know we like to stand in wales long
so it's almost i'm trying to think
when's the best the best probably place
to put the well on the last two i don't
know or maybe the first two last it's so
weird because they fade i have a well so
you use
as many as you want use one i'll use the
first one you use the second one about
that okay and then at the end just one
and two and then
no well on the third one
because then you gave you the first one
you knew the third one
yeah because they're slick man like they
know
what destiny players want to do and
they're moving the dps plates
like callous
sit there and just stay there try to
melt and think that's gonna
everybody's back it's four times
i don't know if everyone's here addict
are you good are you still you gotta let
i had to get that fool man
i found a
skip for the second encounter
really
yeah of course you did of course you did
oh no
we can sample that out later
[Laughter]
he's here
[Music]
how long it takes you can't go back for
a secret chest
yeah but i don't want to use my secret
chest on [ __ ] legs again
that's true
if i get if i get a good weapon i'll
probably go back through and do it yeah
like [ __ ]
[Music]
he's like freaks
[Music]
that's just sounding sounds
get off like that
you gotta have somebody to test these
theories out
make sure it's good i just want to make
sure it's good for the rest of the team
you're right
i want to make sure the rest of the team
thing you know i mean wasting their time
so
do that
see those chests working then you know i
mean once we can finish
yeah he definitely
to be honest with you guys i just want
i'm doing it because when d get on
tomorrow i want him to be able to get it
easily you know what i mean
[Laughter]
that was a classic
saying that they're saying right now
that people don't know
oh it's classic that day
yo we got every year we have a classic a
sigmoid
moving like it always happened
and we always remember this
that night that happened
[Music]
that was a funny one
in a
minute about to get this advanced gg
focus
mm-hmm
don't worry
about that
it's coming soon
coming soon
everybody ready we waiting on forte
yeah
all right we waiting on for attack cool
we don't want to see let me get my
little
advanced gg baja blast
this red light
this
i don't know look a little more
aggressive right
yeah look at that school dude
he ain't got no teeth though
yeah
a player
yo
hold up before i tell you back give me a
second you about to [ __ ] with my
advanced gg focus
so i can power through the final
sections of the raid
cool would you
guys check out
um his flavor i got his i got his cup he
ain't got a flavor yet but i got his ice
shaker you got the [ __ ] got daddy ice
shake on the deck
well is that this
dude
uh no this is just can i see how the
raid
what what armor did y'all get for the
raid i want to know how i got legs
the legs look okay i mean they're
nothing crazy they kind of move
they said they kind of move they kind of
[Music]
uh
yeah he got his legs
you gotta grab it
oh it's called resident
fury cow okay
president fury
i see the test oh it's it's moving oh
that's crazy yeah i see the test before
me
she doesn't look for me
well i got a lower tab
collections armor
let's see
end
oh you can just see all of the armor
oh yeah
let me look i'll try these raid webs we
have a little laura the hunters kind of
look so nasty dude a little different
but it looks nasty
okay
[Laughter]
i got
[Applause]
[Laughter]
rainbow well this is good for me to test
out these guys
okay
earth
red square yep
okay i got earth and red square i can't
shoot it there's a shield in front of it
i got you
i got earth in red square
that took way too long
you're done i'm surprised this is still
up this is after dark right now
do chair pop real quick
share pop
so we could
remember before take that back
damn bad oh
now he's back
[Laughter]
[Music]
mexican flag and
workspace
what all right i got all three of them
okay
go ahead
i'm almost tempted to start over since i
wiped it
okay
praying man
um
guy holding a branch
and brain
okay
i'll get branch and brain and i'll get
all three okay okay three three two one
go
yeah let's get all three okay your turn
so it's just the last three so they're
going to be on the other side i'll grab
all of them or shoot all of them
inkblot and
raid banner
all right i'm ready to come out
there you go
all right go for it
okay get ready for dps kill ads
killers
these yellow guys in the middle
oh lord all the way from quick
oh look he's slashing me
there it is you just crossed it i got
the first one i don't have the second
mount at all
you don't need a bubble
wrong plate
oh yes
sniper right behind us
yeah just pick this up
let's find out yeah
we lost
your man yeah
it's almost not even the luna faction it
even really worth it to be honest
because it's like
it's better for me to have phoenix pearl
hard to have more of the supra yeah more
times yeah it's a really small play too
and if you step off yeah and we don't
have like all night
yeah forget luna i'm gonna really really
crack it for that
yeah try it try it
absolutely try it
switch that joint off
what scout you're using it's um attic
one which one i need a cousin
the person just run right into it
started that i need a better scope what
let me see let me see which one you're
using
no why don't you use that inquiry joint
oh
you talk about the okay using this one
the stasis one here let me grab that
let me grab that because what what is it
is that a
because i feel like i tried hunger your
journey really was hidden like that
for some reason
fusion rifle
right there
worth a shot
it's up to y'all
up to yeah
do better damage
do better damage here all right let's
work a shot let me get that better
and uh all right i'm ready
here